foreign
welcome to this video on SEO full course
today we'll begin this full course video
with what is SEO and how SEO works then
we will be looking at a bunch of on-page
and off-page elements after this we will
learn how to analyze and measure website
metrics using Google Analytics tool we
will also see how to use Google tag
manager then we will discuss some of the
important techniques to rank number one
on Google and YouTube
simple ways to increase website traffic
basic knowledge of SEO tools and finally
we will conclude this video by
discussing the important tips and tricks
of SEO for this training with me I have
our experienced AWS specialist Rob and
Rahul together we will take you through
the various topics of SEO
so let's start with an exciting video on
SEO full course before we begin make
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn
Rachel is a baker who runs her own
Bakery to expand her business she
decided to create an online presence by
first setting up a Blog she began
posting on her blog regularly however
even after regularly posting on the blog
there were barely any visitors showing
up deciding not to give up Rachel began
searching for a solution on the internet
that's when she came across SEO or
search engine optimization a term she's
never heard before so let's take a
journey together and help her learn
about SEO
search engine optimization is a method
that could improve the quality and
quantity of the audience coming to
Rachel's website from search engines it
could increase brand awareness attract
local customers and build credibility
and trust and all of this is possible
without having to spend a single penny
to bring visitors to our website Rachel
would have to take advantage of the two
types of SEO on-page and off-page SEO
Rachel first decides to tackle on-page
SEO and get that sorted on-page SEO
involved Rachel optimizing her website
both in terms of content and the
technical aspects including the HTML
source code schema meta Tags and More
she started off by using tools like
Google AdWords allref and semrush to
identify popular Search terms associated
with the recipes she planned to publish
on her blog she began to look for Search
terms related to the broader area of
baking cooking and related topics once
she found these Search terms she began
to incorporate them into her recipes
she started off by providing an
introduction to the recipe with this she
could provide an engaging beginning to
her story like how the dish reminded her
of her childhood and enabled her to
naturally include the Search terms into
the blog she also included these
keywords in the actual recipe as well
additionally she added pictures videos
time lapses and more to increase
credibility and engagement for her
content and subsequently persuading
search engines to show her content to
more people
after this she moved to the website
metacontent that search engines display
when her blog appears in search results
she optimized The Meta tax alt tags
header Tags and More this completed the
on-page aspect of SEO thanks to this she
saw a significant increase in the number
of visitors coming to her page having
done all she could on her webpage she
now decides to explore what could be
done off page to improve her Page's
visibility on search engines off-page
SEO involved Rachel doing things outside
her site page to help increase its
search engine rankings making
optimizations outside the site would
improve the site's popularity relevance
trustworthiness and Authority this is
possible with the help of reputable
websites vouching for your content with
backlinks social media marketing guest
blogging linked unlinked brand mentions
influencer marketing and much more
Rachel also understood that for her
content to reach people she would have
to promote it on social media platforms
like Facebook Twitter and Instagram as
well as Niche platforms like quora
Reddit and medium these could help her
achieve greater reach for her website by
sending stronger social signals to
search engines leading to the page being
shown as highly relevant for related
searches and audiences and even after
understanding and implementing all of
this Rachel had just scratched the
surface of what was possible with SEO
before we find out what she did next
let's have a look at a quiz which of the
following is the most effective way to
improve off-page SEO one creating plenty
of web pages of a content 2. getting
backlinks from relevant and
authoritative sites three acquiring
backlinks through link Buy
4. none of the above let us know your
answer in the comments section below for
a chance to win an Amazon voucher now
let's go back to Rachel Rachel decided
to take up simplylearn's digital
marketing certification with classes
covering just about everything she
needed to know about SEO it was only a
matter of time before Rachel began to
implement her learnings on her website
and see a massive uptick in the number
of viewers coming to her website in time
she could even earn money off the site
by setting up an online shop and with
that we've covered an introduction to
the concepts of SEO welcome my name is
Rob Sanders I'm a course instructor at
simply learn today we're going to talk
about why you would want to rank using
SEO and SEO as search engine
optimization also known as organic
search you also May us here a say
organic listings where we're going to
talk a little bit about why you would
want to rank your website in organic
search okay what is search engine
Optimum organization then we're going to
follow that up with how does Google rank
websites so why does it rank one website
over another and how do we get our
website to rank number one then we're
going to talk about the different types
of SEO or search engine optimization
techniques so you can get your website
ranked number one and then we're going
to finish that off with the do's and
don'ts of SEO so let's get right to it
and talk about why SEO so we're going to
use a basic example and let's just say
you have a Blog you're a food blogger
you're passionate about food and your
Niche is ice cream and let's just say
you have a lot of ice cream recipes you
want to get traffic to your blog you
want people to read your blog and you're
curious why am I not ranking for my blog
why when people type in ice cream
recipes and say Google my blog posts
don't appear at the top of organic
rankings and there's a number of reasons
why you wouldn't be ranked for or your
blog post or your ice cream recipes and
the main reason would be your
competitors so there could be somebody
else out there who is also passionate
about ice cream and has been blogging
along longer than you and they have more
content and more blog posts and more
pages for Google to rank so that's
usually the number one reason the other
reason is improper usage of keywords and
we're going to talk a little bit or it's
actually a lot more about you know
keyword usage in your content so what
kind of keywords do you want to rank for
that's really what we're talking about
when we talk about usage of keywords
what keywords do you want to rank for
and how do we work those keywords into
the content another reason is poor link
building practices and really that means
our other blog posts or other websites
linking to you also are you linking to
other pages on your website and so it's
all about link building and with link
building it's internal linking so are we
linking in from one blog post to another
and it's external linking are other
websites of high quality linking to us
and so that's what we talk about when we
talk about link building and then
another reason is web page load time so
you could be running your blog post on
say WordPress for example and your blog
post isn't loading fast enough well if
you look at it this way think about it
if you're Google would you really want
to rank a website or blog post in this
example number one on Google rankings if
that particular page loaded very slow no
you wouldn't because when somebody
clicked on that link in organic search
and went to your website they're going
to have a bad experience because the
page is going to load slow so Google
doesn't want their users to have a bad
experience you don't want your users to
have a bad experience and so that's why
web page load time is a critical factor
for ranking so we need to make sure that
our web pages load fast and then your
user experience is not good enough so
Google again based on my example about
the web page load time Google wants
people to have a good experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot at play there
specifically web page load time but also
you know Google doesn't want any spam
content Google doesn't want any pop-ups
or overbearing ads on the web page they
want people to are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what Google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is the indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is the indexed
is Google needs to be able to index all
the pages on your website so if you have
a Blog with a hundred recipes you want
Google to have access to all 100 recipes
so we're going to talk a little bit
later about how to get your pages ranked
or indexed on Google organic search so
let's move on to what is SEO so sticking
with our ice cream Blog theme really SEO
search engine optimization really is the
practice of increasing your pages that
Google has indexed up the rankings so
the end result is we want all our pages
to be ranked number one for particular
keywords so if you want to be ranked for
ice cream recipes well there's certain
things you need to do so that's
generally how it works we need to apply
search engine optimization to increase a
page for keyword we want to be found for
so let me give you an example so let's
just say there's a hundred students that
participated in an essay competition and
so the competition in this particular
case is evaluated on the basis of is the
content relevant are they using suitable
titles for for their essay do they have
structure when they're participating in
this essay or talking about the essay
and do they have a suitable synopsis and
is the content neat and readable these
seem all logical for an essay
competition well guess what they seem
logical for SEO because that's exactly
how SEO works it's exactly all those
points I just made mentioned about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in SEO and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our Pages
Google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called The Meta
description and then again the the
content needs to be readable and that's
important and so in order to be readable
again we're going to talk more about
site speed because site speed's
important okay and when we talk about
responsive design when I say responsive
design that means your site your page
needs to load both on desktop and also
on mobile and so all these things are
important just like an essay competition
Google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine what page is best to
rank number one number two number three
Etc on Google Search and then link
building remember I mentioned link
building a moment ago we'll link
building internally and externally also
plays a vital role and so we're going to
talk about that a little bit later in
the class when we talk about off-page
SEO how does Google rank website and
basically Google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they call back to their servers and
when they take it back to their servers
your web pages they need to you know
have them available for indexing so when
somebody actually types in a keyword
into google.com it'll be available to be
found on organic search so that's what
indexing is all about and then Google's
job when somebody does type in a search
query is to basically write rank though
those pages that they've indexed from
number one to Infinity depending on how
many pages are relevant to that search
query so really it's about crawling
indexing and ranking so praline is
simply a process done by which Google
has Bots and what these Bots do is they
go to your web server and they're going
to crawl every page that they can find
and how do they find these Pages well
they basically follow links you might
have heard the term Spider-Man that's
what they call search engine spidering
so basically what Google's doing is
they're building a web so to speak all
the links that they're following and so
when they can follow all these links on
your website they're going to be able to
crawl them and when they crawl them
basically they're going to take that
content and store it on their servers so
it's available in their index So based
on this method Google finds out which
websites have relevant content and which
ones don't based on certain keywords
that are typed in a Google Google
because if they can't crawl your website
you're not going to be found and if you
can't be found then you're not going to
show up for Relevant keywords so we need
to make sure your site's available to be
crawled and we'll talk about that a
little bit later okay but let's show you
an example so let's just go to Google
Search and if I type in the keyword
simply learn okay I could see I have 1
million 10 000 results okay and that's
how many results are showing up for
simply learn okay now they may not all
be simply learned pages but nonetheless
simply learned is ranked number one here
organically and there are one million 10
000 Pages related to the keyword simply
learn now when it comes to organic
search we don't want to get it confused
with paid search so anytime you see paid
search you're going to see something
that says add next to it okay so we
could see that there are paid ads here
but when it comes to organic search
those are generally below paid ads and
so that's where Google counts the 1 1
million 10 000 results and so that's the
whole idea behind crawling and indexing
Google's able to cross simply learns
website and based on all the pages that
they gather they're going to make those
pages available in organic search so if
you type in a keyword and your web page
is not available for indexing then
you're never going to show up for that
keyword so that's why it's important to
make sure your website is available for
crawling and indexing and so when a user
types a query on search Google search
the most relevant websites that are in
Google's index are going to pair in the
search results so in the example I gave
with simply learn well simply learn is
the brand name of the company simply
learned so there's a lot of relevancy
there so that's why you see simply learn
show up here organically number one like
we mentioned about what is SEO and why
SEO we talked about that user experience
so there's a lot of factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learned example simply
learn is relevant to a lot of the simply
learned Pages because that's who they
are simply learn however simply learn
also needs to make sure that you know
for their Pages the page load time is
fast meaning these Pages load very fast
for the end user and Google also takes
into account other factors like how long
someone is staying on a website or are
they bouncing meaning are they going to
one page that they land on and then
leaving the website okay and so the user
experience is very very important there
are other factors also like language and
location and so for example location if
you do a search say in India the results
are going to be a little bit different
than say the results in the United
States why because Google is indexing as
many web pages as they can find so if
somebody's doing a search in India their
results may be a little bit different
than the results show up in the U.S
because Google has different Bots and
these Bots are crawling different pages
at different times and so Google's index
is updating continuously but it's not
real time syncing so if you do a search
in India you may not see exactly the
same thing because both search engines
the Google in India and the Google and
the US are may not be exactly synced up
so an example would be you know if
you're looking for Cafe so if you search
a cafe in say San Francisco you're going
to see different results now if you do a
search for cafes in Mumbai you're going
to see different results there's going
to be local search here at the top there
may be some paid search but again you
may see different results because one
location but two Google search engines
in India and United States google.com
aren't exactly synced up exactly at the
same exact time you do that search so
location mission is important language
is important and relevancy is important
along with user experience so all those
are important factors in how Google
ranks websites okay so we're going to
talk about the types of SEO now so if we
want to rank for a particular keyword on
Google we're going to have to apply
search engine optimization and so
there's two strategies to search engine
optimization on-page SEO and off-page
SEO so first we're going to talk about
on-page SEO so on page SEO is nothing
more than optimizing your own website
and so when we say optimizing your own
website there's certain elements on your
website and on your web pages that we
need to take into account and so some of
those elements are headers meta
descriptions title tags linking so all
of those elements are something we can
control as an end user who wants to rank
our web page in our website on Google
and before we do anything with our
website the first thing we need to do is
understand what keywords we want to rank
for in order to understand what keywords
we want to rank for we need to do
keyword research and if you do anything
in SEO keyword research is the most
important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for SEO and
why do I say it's the most important
because you need to understand if you
choose a keyword that you want to rank
for you need to understand how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on Google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on Google so you need to understand what
the volume is and then number two we
need to understand what the competition
is for that keyword that you want to
rank for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for a web page on your website
quicker than say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a keyword and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keywords you want and then once you
choose the keywords you want then you
can go and apply on page SEO you can
change the title tag The Meta
descriptions the headers all those
elements can be changed but first you
need to choose your keywords and so
again the primary components we're
looking for are how much traffic you can
get or the search volume how much
competition there is for that keyword
and of course relevancy okay you need to
be able to choose a keyword that's
relevant to the web page you're trying
to rank for and so let me show you
example how to go through this so the
first thing we want to do is we want to
use a tool and the tool I would
recommend is Google Keyword Planner and
why why do I choose Google Keyword
Planner because if we're trying to rank
on google.com or Google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so Google's going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if I want to use Google's
Keyword Planner and I want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then I'm going to
type that keyword into Google's Keyword
Planner and what Google is going to do
is they're going to give me some Trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword I can
see that there are trends that that
appear for both desktop and mobile so
mobile is important because people start
their search process a lot of times on
their mobile device so we want to be
able to get data from mobile as well as
desktop and so we could see see a trend
here that for each particular month over
the last 12 months we can see how much
volume this particular keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
gets per month and so on average on
average over the past 12 months I could
see how to become a digital marketing
specialist is averages 30 searches a
month and this is on google.com and so
Google gives us the volume what they
also give us is the competition and so
here I can see Google says for that
particular keyword the competition is
medium and so in the Google's Keyword
Planner what they also do is give me
other relevant keywords that I might
think about optimizing for because you
don't want to optimize for just one
keyword so how to become a digital
marketing specialist they're going to
also offer up other types of keywords
that are relevant so just digital
marketing Specialists social media
marketing specialist so for those
keywords I can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist I
can see the average volume is one
thousand per month on average of the
last 12 months I can also see the
competition is medium but for some other
keywords I can see the search volume
being high like digital marketing course
at 2900 per month but also the
competition is high and so what I would
recommend is a best practice is to
collect all your relevant keywords okay
and put all your relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet and when you put all these
relevant keywords in a spreadsheet you
want to get the data on those keywords
and the data I'm referring to is the
volume of competition so in this case we
have volume from Google planner Google's
Keyword Planner and I have competition
from Google's Keyword Planner and so if
I go into a spreadsheet and I put all
that information in here I'm going to be
able to see the volume and competition
and so that's important however one
thing to note here is that Google's
Keyword Planner if I go back just gives
us low medium and high and if I I want
to compare numbers to numbers maybe I
want to be able to get exactly the
competition number for the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
what I can do is go into Google and I
can type in that keyword so if I type in
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist I can see there's
76 Million results so I could see 76
Million results 76.1 actually and for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist now that's a whole
lot of results for this particular
keyword especially when the volume is
only 30 per month on average and so what
I want to do is get a more clear picture
of the competition and so what you could
actually do is type in the syntax all in
title and then colon and then your
keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist and when I do that
I get a different result here I can see
only 136
listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136 with that particular
keyword that we want to rank for in the
title tag okay so the title tag is what
you see when you type in a keyword or
search query in Google search and the
title tag is what you see at the top of
every search result and so now I can see
I typed in how to become a digital
marketing specialist with the all
entitled syntax and now I can see every
listing every one of these 136 results
have that particular keyword in it so I
could see every one of them how to
become a digital marketing specialist
and why is that important because now
that tells me I only need to climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from Google's
Keyword Planner but you want to get your
competition from Google search and again
that's simply typing in the the syntax
all in title and then your keyword in
this example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize for and that's
important because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page SEO so
again you want to
great content for say a keyword like
digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search how to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use Google search see first
when they talk type in a query and get
results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page SEO it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in Google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
Google will truncate the title tag so if
I go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag Google
truncated it meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because when we have the
right keyword in the title tag and
somebody types in that keyword then
chances are it's going to be relevant
they're going to see it and they're
going to click through to your website
and that's the whole idea behind ranking
we want to get clicks so that's how the
title tag appears so when you optimize
it you're going to update the title tag
and this is how it shows up it's going
to show up at the top of your listing
okay and it's going to be bigger and
Bolder than anything else Google
displays so the second thing you want to
optimize is the meta description and The
Meta description is simply just a brief
description up to 155 I would say about
155 to 60 160 characters but probably no
more than that and so the meta
description is nothing more than a
summary of the web page itself so if I
go back to my Google search results I
see my title tag and I see the page that
this particular listing belongs to and
underneath that is where I can see my
meta description so in this particular
keyword query how to become a digital
marketing specialist I see the meta
description an ultimate guide on how to
build a career in digital marketing and
the skills required to become a digital
marketing specialist note that it's a
well-written meta description within 155
characters and it includes the keyword
digital marketing specialist so we're
trying to rank for how to become a
digital marketing specialist and here
you can see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag and the
keyword but the meta description and the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description and you leave The
Meta description blank then you're
leaving it to Google to add in copy that
they deem relevant and so for on-page
SEO we want to take control of the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for so the
meta description is a powerful tool at
our disposal it gives us more characters
to work with it gives us more to talk
about so for that particular page and so
if the title tag is only 60 characters
maximum it's not a lot of information to
try and get somebody to click so the
meta description helps us in identifying
what that page is about in order to get
the click so the two working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element that's important
is the URL and URL stands for uniform
resource locator and why is the URL so
important because that's what people see
so if I go back to my search result how
to become a digital marketing specialist
notice that the URL also includes how to
become a digital marketing specialist
article okay so it's very relevant the
URL is very relevant one we can see it
in the search results but two you know
it's is relevant to the keyword query
and that's important for the end user
and Google Google wants to know hey is
this the page that's relevant to the
user's query and if it is then this user
is likely going to have a good X user
experience after they click on the
listing so the URL is an element that
helps not only with the click-through
rate but with ranking and having a poor
URL structure doesn't help at all
because not only does Google not
recognize the URL as being relevant but
the end user may not want to click on
that page given the the way the URL
looks so you want to try and avoid a
poor URL structure so the rule of thumb
is this if you don't understand what the
URL is then Google is likely not going
to understand what the URL is and so we
want to try and keep our URL structures
clean and when I say clean ideally you
want to make sure that whatever keywords
you're trying to optimize that's the key
word that's in included in the URL
nothing included that is not
understandable so again going back to
our example how to become a digital
marketing specialist it's very clean the
title tag is the keyword The Meta
description is cleanly written has the
keyword and then the URL is the other
element that the end user can see and
that URL includes the keyword in it so
after we've done those three elements
the title tag The Meta description and
the URL then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organization structure
to the content and with headers there's
a hierarchy so you have anywhere from H1
which is the top of the hierarchy to an
H6 and so you're free to use any one of
those headers when building on a page in
order to organize the content but
ideally you probably want to stick with
an H1 or an H2 because those are at the
top of the hierarchy and what those do
is they actually stress to Google that
hey this header with this particular
keyword in it is important so if you use
an H6 with the keyword in it it's
telling Google hey this is an H6 but
it's not as important so an H1 and an H2
tag show importance and so let's look at
an example of what that is so here you
could see an H1 is going to be at the
top of the hierarchy so that means it's
going to be bigger and Bolder then you
have an H2 which is going to be bigger
and Bolder than an H3 but not as big and
bold as an H2 so with headers not only
are you organizing the con content
accordingly but you're also signaling to
Google how important that particular
header is and of course the header needs
to include the keyword we're trying to
rank for so let's take a look again at
that example so if we go to how to
become a digital marketing specialist if
I click on that page I can look at the
content and I can see that there are
headers in here so the headers are there
to organize the content and that's what
we want we want to be able to organize
the content and if you look at the other
example I'm showing here how to become a
digital marketing specialist a learning
path Explorer you can see that's an H1
but below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an H2 and so we're not stressing to
Google that that's more important than
nh1 but nonetheless we're stressing at
Google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to Google
what's important and also to organize
the content because Google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on is internal linking and so
internal link and if you remember
earlier in the presentation it's
basically links from one page on your
website to another and so here we can
see on this particular article how to
become a digital marketing specialist
there's also links to other pages on
simply learns website and so for this
particular content it also links to SEO
Specialists PPC specialist social media
marketing specialist and digital
marketing specialist so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their web website that
are relevant to becoming a digital
marketing specialist and so this is a
best practice when you're optimizing a
web page so you want to be able to have
internal linking on your site and the
whole idea behind internal linking is it
also allows users to navigate through
the site naturally so when I say
naturally they don't always have to
refer back to the top navigation they
can naturally and seamlessly go from one
relevant article or page to another and
so that's the whole idea behind link
building and internal link building it
allows Google to identify you know pages
that they want to crawl and index
because they're linked to one another
but it also helps the end user because
it allows the end user to go from one
page to another and it's signaling to
Google hey this particular page is
linked to this page so we're going to
also index that page and so that's the
whole important part of internal linking
it's about the end you user experience
and it's about allowing Google to find
the pages on your website so they can
crawl them and index them so you can be
ranked for them and so also in addition
to internal linking we want to be able
to use natural language and so what do I
mean by natural language or natural
language processing so what Google does
is in terms of natural language
processing they're looking for the
content and the keyword it needs to be
relevant so when your website is about
digital marketing you don't necessarily
want to rank or try to rank for the
keyword digital marketing one it's too
broad two there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you want to choose
other relevant related keywords that's
going to be more natural and so that's
what we mean on natural language
processing we want to choose keywords
that are more natural to the content
you're writing so instead of the key
keyword digital marketing maybe we want
to talk about the types of digital
marketing or digital marketing examples
or what is a digital marketing strategy
or how to become a digital marketing
specialist so those are all relevant
keywords to digital marketing and more
relevant to the content because if you
try to rank for the keyword digital
marketing again it's probably going to
be a little bit broad probably more
competition and not as relevant to your
content and as a result probably not a
good user experience so think about some
other keywords that you could optimize
and rank for and that goes back to the
keyword research that's why the keyword
research is so important because it
allows us to identify other keywords and
the natural language process what
keywords are more relevant for the
content and then another element to
on-page SEO is the sitemap and so with
the site map it's basically a list of
all the pages on your website and the
whole idea of listing all the pages on
your website in one document is it helps
both users and search engines understand
the structure of your website so there
are two types of sitemaps one's an HTML
sitemap and that's designed for humans
so if you have a website with a lot of
content at the footer or the bottom of
your web page you probably want to have
a link to sitemap so if somebody clicks
on that side map they're going to be
able to see all the pages on your
website structured in an organized
manner well an XML sitemap an XML is
just a different format it's designed
for crawlers and so the whole idea
remember is Google likes to crawl
content when they crawl content they
bring it back to their servers and index
it and so we want to be able to create a
sitemap for Google or other search
engine crawlers and so XML is the format
so let me show you example of how that
looks so if I go to simplylearn.com and
simply we type in say sitemap.xml just
as an example I'm going to get this
particular page in this particular page
displays two XML sitemaps so these site
maps are there for Google to go ahead
and crawl and nothing more than a list
of all the pages on your website and so
this is a quick and easy way for Google
to get a hold of all those pages so that
they can index them and that's the whole
idea behind SEO you want to be able to
have Google index all the content you
want to be found for for the keywords
you want to be found for so it all
starts with the sitemap so let's go from
on-page SEO which in recap is basically
optimizing certain elements on your
website so that you are relevant for a
particular keyword and that meant
updating the title tag The Meta
description the URL the headers choosing
the right keywords to put into the
content having internal linking chain
and also updating the sitemap well those
are elements that you can do on your
website so we're going to switch gears
and talk about a different strategy
off-page SEO because without on page or
off page you can't have a page ranking
so the two work together so you can do
as much as you want on on page but you
still need off-page SEO and you could do
all the off-page SEO you want but you
still need on page so both of these
strategies have to be in full effect in
order for you to rank so let's now
switch gears to off-page SEO and so
off-page SEO is simply the process of
linking or promoting your website using
link building and so if you remember I
talked about this earlier on there's two
types of links internal and external
linking and so for on-page SEO we used
internal linking for off-page SEO we're
going to talk about external linking and
external linking allows us to improve
our website sites recognition or
relevancy or credibility and why do we
want to improve our relevancy and
credibility and trustworthiness and
Authority because we want Google to know
that our web page is trustworthy it is
recognized by other websites and it is
relevant for a particular keyword and so
if we can do that using off-page SEO
methods then Google's going to rank our
web page for the keyword we want to be
found for so it's really off-page SEO
synonymous with link building and
there's plenty of opportunities to do
link building it just comes down to
creating a strategy so again some of the
benefits to off page well we talked
about you know being credible and
trustworthiness and relevant we need to
do that in order to rank but there's
some other benefits there so if we're
have a link on another credible website
then it's likely going to increase the
traffic to our own website it also
creates high domain Authority and so
what I mean by high domain Authority is
if we have basically links to other web
pages pointing back to us then basically
our domain Authority is going to improve
and when our domain Authority improves
other websites are going to want to link
to us so the higher authoritative we are
for our website than other web pages are
going to want to link to us and so the
more external linking we have the higher
the domain Authority so it all starts
with linking to other high domain
Authority websites so linking to a high
domain Authority website for example
have any link on Wikipedia that points
back to our web page creates high domain
Authority for us and it helps Drive
traffic so some of the other benefits of
off-page SEO are in credibility so if
we're linking from Wikipedia to our web
page it does create credibility for us
it also helps us increase our page rank
so remember that external linking helps
build domain Authority helps build
credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn help us rank for that particular
page and then certainly not last having
a good off-page SEO link building
strategy increases our brand awareness
because if we're on other high Authority
websites Wikipedia or say a social
platform it's going to increase our
brand awareness and increasing our brand
awareness increases our trustworthiness
and so if somebody is looking to say
become a digital marketing specialist
then likely instead of typing in digital
marketing Specialists on Google they may
type in our brand name in this case
simply learn and so these are all the
benefits to off-page SEO so it's nothing
more than having links on other websites
that are pointing back to ours and again
there's lots of benefits its drives
helps Drive traffic and increases our
Authority so those are things that we
want to take advantage of when we want
want to rank and the key behind off-page
SEO or link building is always going to
be content so from an on-page SEO
perspective having quality content
allows that content to be optimized for
Relevant keyword and ranked but also
from an off-page SEO strategy having
high quality content allows us to have
other sites and it doesn't necessarily
have to be a website it could be a
social platform or can be another
blogging platform or blogging website
link back to ours why because the
content is original it's natural it's
well structured it reads well and so
that's the whole idea behind off page
you can't have links on other websites
if you don't have quality content so one
of the ideas behind off-page SEO is not
only do you want to create good content
but you probably want to spend a lot of
time or a bit of time on others websites
so remember the example I used earlier
in this presentation about having an ice
cream blog and ice cream recipes well it
probably wouldn't be a bad idea to say
spend some time on other blogs related
to desserts related to cakes related to
food in general related to vegetables or
other items that people could link from
so the whole idea is understanding who
else is out there who has relevant
content that you could share so you
could share your content with them they
can share their content with you and
generally that's how it works naturally
anyway in the web sphere if somebody
likes your content they're going to link
to it they don't necessarily have to
wait for you to ask them but it might
not be a bad idea to understand who else
is out there that has content somewhat
or yours so that you can you know get a
link on that particular website or blog
post and so some other ideas behind
having external links pointing back to
your website is social media so social
media is not just Facebook or Twitter
here but it expands beyond that there's
there's core there's media there's all
sorts of content generated websites like
Reddit so the list goes on and on you
just need to find what's relevant for
your content if it's relevant for your
content then it's worth putting or
trying to get the external link on that
social media platform and then again
going back to my ice cream blog recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog that you want to have an external
link on there's nothing wrong with
reaching out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant then why not it's only going to
help your end user experience if you add
somebody who has a say a Blog about
cakes having their link on your blog
post so there's nothing wrong with it
because it also adds to the user
experience and if you're going to ask
somebody to put an external link on
theirs you might want to be open-minded
and make sure that you're are able and
willing to put an external link on your
blog post or website pointing to their
content that's how the web Works
especially if the contents of quality
relevant and of good nature okay so
let's move on and finish up with the
do's and don'ts of SEO so we talked a
lot about why SEO what is SEO how do we
rank for SEO what is on page SEO what is
off-page SEO and so let's just wrap up
with some of the things you again want
to do to rank your page for a particular
keyword and some of the things you don't
want to do so the first thing on the
list is optimize for white hat
techniques and what I mean for opting in
for white hat techniques is basically
everything I just mentioned today you
want to do keyword research you want to
choose a natural language processing
form format so you could choose keywords
that are going to be relevant natural to
the content and you don't want to opt
for black cat techniques and blad hat
techniques are probably not even worth
going into detail but one example is
choosing a keyword arbitrarily like say
digital marketing and just stuffing that
keyword into the content so that's
probably not something you want to do
because again it's not going to be good
for the end user so stay away from black
hat and focus on some of the techniques
we talked about in today's presentation
the other do we want to do is get
backlinks from relevant sites so that's
off-page SEO again it's what I mentioned
earlier it's about linking your quality
content to another person's website that
also has quality content we don't want
to have a backlink from an irrelevant
site why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
Authority because if it's on a site
that's not of good quality then Google's
going to look at us and say well this
site is linking to your site but it's
not relevant so therefore you know we're
not going to look at you in this same
way as if you were on a quality website
we do want to use our keywords naturally
because title tags are what people see
first on organic search but you don't
want to use the same title tag on every
page of your website so we want to stay
away from doing that so you want to have
a unique title tag for every web page on
your website and ideally what does that
mean that means using our keyword
research to choose one or two keywords
per page and optimizing your web page
for those one to two keywords so you
ideally what you want to do is have one
to two different keywords for every page
on your website we definitely definitely
definitely want to write engaging
content so the content should be
engaging remember user experience we
want users to stay on our website we
want them to enjoy the content that
they're reading and we want them to go
from one page to another naturally we
definitely don't want to leverage or
plagiarize or just copy content from
others websites because it's not one
probably going to be relevant to what
you're writing about two it's duplicate
content and it's somebody else's so
that's a black cat Technique we want to
stay away from I can't emphasize this
enough we need to do keyword research
first before you do anything else you
need to find relevant keywords and not
only that you need to understand the
volume and the competition for each of
those keywords okay you don't want to
choose a key word that has low volume
High competition if you want to choose a
keyword that has high volume low
competition but above all you want to
choose keywords that are relevant to
your content we want to avoid keyword
stuff in so don't take a keyword and
just stuff it everywhere on the page
it's not going to be natural and
Google's going to be able to pick up on
that so we want to maintain some level
of quality with our content and quality
with the keyword that we choose so
reminder when you have quality content
it's always going to link internally to
another page on your website with
quality content but it's got to be
natural and don't just build site-wide
backlinks meaning don't just have an
internal link to the home page or don't
have every page on your website linking
to just one page so internal linking
should be natural naturally linking from
one page to another not only does it
help Google understand and crawl all the
web pages on your website but it's good
for the end User it's good user
experience and certainly last but
something I didn't talk about does take
time to rank your content so remember
the process you're going to write your
content you're going to choose keywords
you're going to change the elements on
that page for those keywords and all the
while you're going to make sure Google
can crawl that content and when they
crawl they're going to index it the
process to takes time especially if you
choose a keyword that's competitive so
just be patient if you have quality
content and you've optimized for on-page
SEO and off-page SEO then you will rank
for that keyword and then make sure your
website's user friendly and mobile
friendly so we talked about responsive
content earlier so remember most users
today start the process of search on
mobile so we want to make sure your
websites are mobile friendly well to get
this conversation started here's a
preview of what Matt will be talking
about today keyword research and search
Trends SEO friendly copywriting content
optimization website and landing page
optimization content Trends analytics
and of course we'll be answering your
questions throughout so feel free to
chime in so with that I would just like
to hand the mic over
for a bit here to to matte so take it
away Mr Bailey all right well thank you
Dan and as you can tell by the agenda it
seems to be content heavy and that is
certainly uh without an accident there
that if you've been in SEO for any
length of time you can see where things
are moving in the digital marketing
industry or social media content
marketing those types of things and so
the role of the SEO is becoming more
critical than ever in being that
connection from what are people
searching for and then what do we
publish SEO is that critical link
between the research and the development
of content and that is only going to
increase more and more over the next few
years so that's why there's a little bit
more of emphasis on that content side
that you'll see there
but just you know a little bit more in
detail on that that the role of SEO has
primarily been as that first line of
understanding what the search engine is
doing what do they require what are the
new technologies coming out of search
and what are the trends coming from
search how is Google changing results
what are they testing so seos first and
foremost are on those front lines of
seeing what especially Google Google is
pushing the the envelope more than
anybody and they're testing more things
and so understanding what is Google
doing what are the implications of it is
this just a test or are we moving what's
the bigger picture of what they're
attempting to do
and so understanding that role there of
being that early predictor of what's
going on with Google and then being able
to translate that inside your
organization or inside your agency that
is really becoming part of you know the
the representative role of the search
engine Optimizer it's understanding
here's what's happening and here's how
we're supposed to react to it
at the very base level it's
understanding those keywords it's
understanding what are people searching
for and what is their intent and how do
we then apply that into our content
strategy so that has been really kind of
the foundational part of what an SEO
does but it's also going to be a little
bit larger into looking at the larger
trends of what is Google attempting to
do what are the implications and how do
we respond to that
now of course with part of that keyword
research is understanding the long-term
trends uh over a year two years three
years because if something has a trend
and it's predictable well then that's
something you can bring into your
organization uh because I I love to say
if it's predictable it's monetizable you
can make money off it if you know that
it's going to happen every year because
you can prepare for it you can help your
organization prepare for those increases
in traffic especially if you're able to
tie those Trends into specific events if
you can come up with causality what
causes those to happen how do we react
to it how can we develop that and how
can we incorporate that into our
strategy again that is more of a
planning and prospecting work that a
search engine Optimizer would do and
those skills of doing keyword research
and understanding the long-term view of
keyword research of Trends throughout
the year creating those connections that
is a valuable skill which is only going
to increase
and of course those keywords are
important for anyone in a marketing
field or also customer service we've
seen more and more of this cross
marketing view across an organization
where marketing is getting more involved
in customer service they're getting more
involved in loyalty they're getting more
involved in many different aspects of
nurturing customers the customer
experience and so whenever you're
planning any of these things for social
media and what are we doing with social
media are we educating are we rewarding
are we trying to look for new customers
well all of that requires content that
content is going to have to be
researched as to when do we talk about
certain things and how do we talk about
certain things keyword research gives
you that agenda it keyword research
tells you when people search for certain
content and also the associate words
that they have and so that applies to
your content marketing your social media
marketing it also applies to when people
become customers and if you do any
amount of CRM marketing email marketing
or email automation or even triggered
your keyword research can help in
developing the content that will be in
those emails because you have done the
research and find out what do people
want after they make a decision after
they purchase a product what are the
needs that they have what is the
information need that they have and how
do we write towards that so again SEO is
influencing the content that is
generated by the entire organization in
nearly all Communications
this gets back to seeing the trends that
are happening within the search engine
and you've probably seen this lately I
love this example here so if I want to
make a latte and I type that into Google
uh this is what's interesting the answer
to my question is at the top of the page
now without even going to the website I
can have my answer
for the question and now there's a
couple implications to this
yes it's great we can be at the top of
the rankings you can have our answer
there but if the answer completely
answers the searcher's question
it doesn't generate a page view they
don't see much of our brand they aren't
in really they aren't engaging with us
at all they're engaging with Google and
so this gets to the point of how do you
then bring this to the organization as
far as a strategic view of this how do
we approach it how does this change what
we do with our website or with our
content
you can also see here that people are
asking different questions and this gets
to the copywriting of the website are
you generating content that answers
questions because this is where Google
is pooling this information as well as
pooling the related questions that come
from that type of content
this also is critical because this then
leads into voice search and so if you've
got a home assistant uh you use any of
the phone assistance or hey guess what
this is coming in cars that you will
have a voice assistant in cars and your
search result will be read back to you
and this is the beginning stages of that
that if you have a question or a search
you would speak your search and then the
first result would be read back to you
and as you can see it's not coming from
the site it's coming from Google so this
is where again we sit down we look at
the strategy what are we trying to do
what is our strategy as far as
visibility in the search results and
what's going to happen and what's
happening now with this is you could be
answering people's questions and never
knowing it simply based because Google
is delivering the result they're not
going to your site now the possibility
of them going to your site exists but as
more voice searches are being generated
Google is going to deliver a result that
doesn't require a click-through because
it's all happening through audio
so hopefully this uh doesn't uh all the
changes in SEO I would say over the past
uh 15 years have been largely external
driven by Google as Google has taken
away keywords taken away uh keywords and
analytics uh numerous things here that
have caused seos to have to react uh and
again this is one of those changes that
causes us to sit and figure out how are
we going to deal with this change we
have some questions already one of which
is Google's not spending so much time
focusing on keywords specifically even
though they're still important where do
you suggest the marketers look for
keywords
oh I think the the typical keyword
research tools are still very viable in
fact you'll probably get uh better
information out of keyword tools than
you will Google's keyword Tool uh Google
has been combining keyword Concepts
under a single keyword so for example
um a great one that uh we've seen in the
keyword research pool table and pool
tables plural and singular Google puts
that all under pool table whereas anyone
who you know does any amount of
e-commerce can tell you there is a world
of difference between people that search
for plural and singular
uh before the the changes in keywords I
could tell you with numerous sites that
we had that if people searched with the
singular version uh they were about
three to five times more likely to
purchase than if they searched for the
plural version uh the plural version
meant that they were shopping the
singular version pointed to they were
ready to make a decision
so Google won't show you the data
however between the plural and singular
for pool tables some other keyword
research tools however will show you
that
so even though you know even though it's
getting more difficult with the keywords
from a marketing standpoint absolutely
still do your keyword research right as
if you would uh you know you're gonna
have to do additional research maybe you
know customer research uh you know face
to face asking them to describe how they
would search or what they were looking
for or what problem you solved because
you're going to need a wider variety of
input for keywords yeah and if you have
any way to look into your competitors I
know there are some tools that let you
let you do that you can see what your
competitors are or at least in their or
their sem you can learn a lot yes
because uh you can you can tell a lot by
what's the valuable keyword by learning
what your competitors are paying for and
also check your Checker analytics to see
how people are actually finding you
what's interesting is how is um how is
your I know the rank brain is that one
of the most influential parts of Google
now and I know that that's basically a
lumping instead of creating separate
pages for plurals and
other iterations of words rank range is
sort of uh including all of that and
looking for those words in general
content is it how is rank brain
affecting uh Search terms and and SEO
with just keywords
um you know it's it's really trying to
learn more of what exactly do people
want uh from an intentional standpoint
uh so trying to put together
uh unfamiliar searches or unfamiliar
phrasings or I think I read the other
day
um I'm trying to think whose name it was
but it was oh Matthew McConaughey his
name in one week had
like 8 000 misspelled variations
uh so somehow you know a search engine
has to figure out over 8 000
misspellings who did you mean you know
who are you trying to figure out
um you know so it's it's trying to
figure out the intent and deliver the
right result and you know I think part
of this is yes they don't want seos to
be focusing on individual words
[Music]
um
it and by taking away all that data you
know in a way they have accomplished
that
uh so you know what rankbrain is
attempting to do is trying to tie those
things together of how do we figure out
now they're looking at the minutia of
the difference of words but they do not
want to show it to us right so there's
not a whole lot you can do with it it's
just you know it's from their standpoint
the best thing you can do is just
continue to write
great content that people want that
answers their questions using a variety
of
using a variety of words that explain uh
you know a great example is you know if
you're writing an article uh you know
baseball season started here in the U.S
if you're reading an article about
baseball you're going to use words like
umpire like balls strikes bats teams
those are all words that build context
and so
they're going to count just as much as
the primary term baseball and in fact
Google's going to look for all those
other terms that that build that context
and so it's it's not so much that single
word anymore it's that variety of I
would call those second tier words that
support the context of what you're
writing about rows are coming more into
play yeah and and of course putting that
in a in a more natural language type of
uh type of phraseology in your content
rather than just the old days of
keywords you know how many keywords can
we stuff in the first paragraph uh
what's the optimum number of words in
the in the meditation I mean because now
it really if it looks like you're I mean
this Google's been penalizing people for
doing stuff like that for years but now
especially with rank brain and the the
more you can do to look to write like a
conversation that people are actually
thinking and asking about I'm sure is a
better way they've always wanted that I
mean that has always been Google's goal
from the beginning they have told us to
write for humans uh but the problem has
been it you know there are a lot of seos
there that would rather take the
formulaic approach and
you know why should I write for humans
I'm just trying to get people to my site
you know I want they're gonna buy uh and
so they you know try to reverse engineer
everything to come up with this formula
of use this keyword this many times in
this part of the page and you know
whereas Google has always said right for
humans first and so by taking away some
of those other options or taking away
the keywords it's really guided the
industry to do what they've wanted to do
and honestly I think it's it's a good
thing because the quality of content has
to increase it has to get better uh and
that is one way that they've enforced
that what exactly what they've imposed
their will on on people who desire to
have better rankings right the uh I just
have one one more question that people a
lot of people are asking if you have any
specific recommendations for for keyword
research tools before we wow there are a
lot of them
um so if you've got like Raven or
um I'm trying to think what are some of
the others Raven SEO tools
um there's one right on the edge of my
tongue um
word tracker yeah uh
um
oh I've got a list of them somewhere
here
yeah
just look just
go and look at some of the keyword
research tools
um there are a lot of them many of them
offer free trials and so yeah just get
in do the free trial take a look at
what's there
um yeah yeah some come with full service
site management you may not want all
that you may you may want that others
are more Standalone independent they
just do keyword research never choose a
keyword research tool that doesn't show
up at least on page 10 of the serps
but yeah and and honestly the more you
do keyword research I I have always felt
this way and it's it's the more you do
keyword research the better equipped you
are to do your job uh and and by that
it's dissecting the keywords what are
people looking for what are the trends
what do they associate what are uh the
people places and things so as you're
looking at the keywords you're not so
much looking to see the volume that
someone searched for you know by uh you
know buy a pink car that's that's a
great you know that's good but they
talked about cars they talked about
buying and they talked about color
that's more what we're looking for is
let's start slicing and dicing this down
what words are they associating what
colors what uh features and by
understanding the breadth of how people
search and the questions they have it
helps you write better content because
because now you understand not just
optimizing for one word people have
questions across an entire breadth of
type style color uh Place uh City uh you
know all these types of things and so
that's really what I challenge people to
get out of keyword research is
understanding the full breadth of what
people want rather than just a single
word or a single phrase this gets into
copywriting you see like I said when you
when you get into you know are people
looking for colors are they people
looking for locations sizes I want to
understand the breadth of what they're
talking about and that helps me become a
better copywriter I can understand
intent if I know the questions that they
have then we can write answers and so
you know I want to see how people are
searching you know a great example is is
now we've seen searches increasing for
people searching for you know the best
or for the top rated or uh reviews I
think is Big too oh yeah for me uh
people are actually typing in what is
the best car for me and I think what
they're doing essentially is is directly
asking Google you know based on the two
million things you know about me what
would be the best car for me
um so people are looking for more
personalized information uh so what you
can do is get into the you know the how
to the why the you know what it means
all these different cues that people are
giving in their key phrases develop your
content to answer those questions yeah I
had actually seen a statistic that 82
percent of smartphone users use and this
is for businesses oh we're looking for
businesses use specifically the term
near me after their research so even
geographically I don't know if that's
anything you can include in the content
but uh well no you know it's it's blows
my mind because
um if they're on their smartphone
they're automatically going to get
results near them
that's kind of interesting so it's more
of a cue for Google than it is for a
website because to use that phrase in
any of your optimization really wouldn't
make a lot of sense
uh because you don't know who's near you
um and if anything especially on a
mobile search Google is pretty much
going to ignore that near me because
you're going to get the results near
where you are anyway
yeah um so yeah getting into the search
data people search for what they need
they they figure out what they're
looking for but now here is where the
role of the SEO is going to come in
organizationally is that when you add
people writing content generating
content for Content marketing for social
media uh especially if you're working
with uh you know like a publisher who is
constantly developing content now you
need to help them come up with ways to
measure success
and also to motivate them to implement
SEO tactics in their writing so rather
than developing catchy headlines uh that
may have a double meaning that may not
play well in search you need to help
copywriters understand that well your
headline while that might look great on
print in search it's actually going to
cause a problem and so you turn into an
educator for your content developers uh
you're teaching them what works well
what's going to click well what's going
to look well in the search engines
versus what might be confusing
also uh it's also helping them to
understand you know a great example of
this um before I move on someone
um gave me a great example is they were
writing an article about holiday time
travel and that was the title of the
article that they put out there and they
couldn't figure out why this article was
consistently getting hundreds or
thousands of visits a month uh well
after it was published and when we went
back and started looking at some of the
rankings and some of the keywords and
things like that we found out that the
article was ranking really well for time
travel uh even though the headline was
holiday time travel uh so it's helping
your writers understand
um you know what makes a good title uh
but then also one thing that I worked
with one publisher and one of the things
we did to motivate the writers was to
develop like a a leaderboard of whose
content is generating the most visits uh
and not only that whose content is
generating the most new visits to the
website and then you you can carry that
through to
you know for how for different writers
how many visits or views have you
generated in a month or over the past
six months how much is your content uh
performed compared to other content and
you can carry this all the way out to
you know which writers had the highest
amount of AD clicks uh in their articles
uh which articles uh led to people to uh
subscribe again or you know even get
into customer lifetime value uh there's
so many things that you could Implement
so from an SEO standpoint you understand
already how to look at the success of
game rankings and what it generates in
terms of page views click throughs time
on site uh click depth uh you know all
those types of things that you can then
develop into helping others in the
organization who publish content start
to measure the impact of their writing
organizationally and then especially if
you're able to tie that to a financial
implication uh that shows that this is
what it's contributing towards the
business in terms of Revenue then you
become the all-around hero because
you're able to help others tie Revenue
to activity that's great we have someone
asking can this backfire on you for
example if you're starting every
headline with one weird this one weird
trick dot dot dot
if you find that you have a lot of if
your bounce rate immediately starts
going up yeah you have because if you're
waiting for time travel or Star Wars or
something
that everyone's going to be looking for
um then could that actually negatively
affect how Google sees you if it's if
you have all these bounce rates they
might see you as uh no longer being
relevant absolutely and it's not just
Google with the bounce rate it damages
your brand it damages your credibility I
mean it's it's clickbait and I mean it
doesn't take long for people to realize
clickbait is clickbait
um you can just look at some of the data
uh but yeah I mean when you see articles
or headlines that are obvious click bait
people are you know you get caught a
couple of times you get fooled a couple
of times it's not always going to work
and so this gets to
you know how are you positioning your
brand are you positioning your brand as
a trustworthy source of information that
answers people's questions are you
positioning your brand as we give people
what they need what they want uh or are
you fooling them to click on an article
based on what's popular right now uh you
know there's a couple questions that get
to how the brand wants to be perceived
in the marketplace uh based on tactics
like that
but great question great question
because clickbait is powerful
um but you gotta ask yourself are we
giving people what they want or are we
fooling them into it and how will that
reflect on the brand
right
uh from another keyword standpoint one
thing that I found is very valuable to
do is go out and look and see how people
are searching for the brand and content
associations they make with that brand
uh now this can also get into other
areas you may find that there's some
crossover uh where there's another
company with a similar brand name and so
this will help you understand a little
bit more if you get some of that
crossover traffic but also from a PR
standpoint do people associate content
or ideas with your brand that you would
wrap this will help you become aware of
something that might be out there that
may not be getting picked up uh so I I
enjoy doing these kinds of searches
because I want to know what other words
associations are people making with the
brand right that you may need to deal
with yeah and also look at your
analytics and what is linked in your CRM
to see uh how people have actually
converted because if you have some long
tail keywords in there that would be
good to generate content on uh that your
best customers are finding you through
that can be super valuable and least
compensate for having some super
clickbaity
worth in there accidentally what's
interesting is that people people are
are a few people are really wanting to
hone in on this uh
backtrack a bit here to ways to
capitalize on certain things that
um I know people are looking for quick
answers to rank high on Google but the
question keeps coming up about for
example if there are any ways why you
could restructure your content to
capitalize on things like near me like
should you put in your opening paragraph
you know if you're looking for a near uh
that's that's almost I I personally
would would shrink from doing that
because I know that that's something
that that seems that a Google I don't
want to put words in your mouth it seems
like hey Google is already doing that
automatically based on if you're
searching mobile but two if pretty soon
they're going to catch up to people
putting best and near me and because
that's the other question like should I
should I use terms that are when I when
I see the results of the most commonly
searched terms and mobile should I put
those in my
in my copy so what do you say about that
like are there ways to that you can
legitimately without being uh penalized
capitalized yeah well okay if you're
legitimately publishing an article that
is well researched comparing different
products and you title it best pet food
products or something like that that's a
legitimate case I have no problem with
that do your homework and create
something of value and it will do well
if it's good content that people like
now the the near me is a bit more
sketchy because even though you may put
on your website something about near you
or near me
uh not everyone who visits your website
remember this is more of a mobile
uh phenomenon these are people on their
phone looking for something near them a
drugstore uh a car wash uh you know
something like that a restaurant
and that's being computed based on
distance based on uh you know past
preferences things like that
so it has nothing to do with the content
of your website what I would work on
more is your local business listing in
Google
and developing more reviews for your
business and working with that uh
listing to add more pictures like I said
reviews uh
they have a function there now where you
can add promotions the more you develop
that Google listing that will do a
hundred times more to increase your
visibility when someone is looking for
something near them and they are near
you
began adding words to your website great
well that's not smart
that's a bit forcefully on some of these
things
because I it's it's
it has never bothered me when people out
and Out Try to fool Google with some
really intelligent things uh I I
somewhat tend to admire it uh but when
people try to fool Google with what I
would call amateurish things that are
poorly executed that's where I S you
know that's where I get
I get a little ticked off at that
because it's
create a quality experience that's what
people want
quality experience uh and and that's
really what it gets down to with you
know we with content marketing you're
answering people's questions and so as
people are generating that content
you're also sending them back to the
site you're sending them back to get
answers to register to do things like
that so all those web pages from the
content marketing that they're linking
to they need to be optimized for your
inbound strategy
and what's interesting is also from a
paid search standpoint the landing page
from Paid search you know it needs to be
optimized just like any other page
that's part of the quality score
algorithm does the landing page reflect
the paid search headline does it also
contain the keyword that you're bidding
on so you've got to look at how people
are developing their landing pages
internally and maybe you can contribute
to that as well in helping improve the
quality score because the optimization
of that landing page is very similar
uh where I see employment and Industry
Trends now this is interesting because
talking with the uh director of omcp and
some of the surveys he's been doing of
hiring managers HR managers and
Technology
uh or in marketing across the across the
the globe here one of the things that he
has seen is there is becoming more
demand of people who can manage the
entire Tech marketing stack not the
single Channel Specialists because more
and more automation is handling that uh
more and more you know and this is where
we're going to see the entrance of AI
and machine learning is adjusting your
paid search campaign with those minute
methods of increasing your click-through
rate uh you know it's going to be
managing those bids So eventually you're
just going to focus more on the content
and eventually AI is going to take over
the content uh so the demand is for who
were the single Channel Specialists of
SEO paid search social to move into
understanding the entire omni-channel
digital marketing campaign and can run
and can change and can make
recommendations across the board for the
entire stack of digital marketing this
is where we're seeing more of the
employment trends uh going as well as
the skills demand is getting away from
that single hard skill to understanding
the entire campaign
uh and that's going to go into all
different types of things that's going
to include email CRM social display uh
and seos I think are probably very well
positioned in all of these things
because of the foundation of keywords
the foundation of keywords and
understanding intent and then developing
content that answers those questions
that's needed an email it's needed in
automation it's needed in Social and
display you know especially in the CRM
automation is someone has to write the
content that needs to be automated and
so again this then gets into looking at
the trends because automation you not
only need to write the content but you
need to then plan the content when is it
sent when is this completed when is this
done and so understanding the the sales
cycles and how long they go and when
people need certain information at one
times it takes that planning strategy of
being able to do that and I think seos
are well positioned to understand that
full stack of marketing and the
implications as well as the management
of it
and then we get to analytics uh this is
my favorite
um so as an SEO or if you're taking on
more of the the Omni Channel burden here
uh you've got to develop those
measurements that show how effective not
only SEO has been but now content
management content management is Big
everyone is moving towards it it has
become a significant piece of strategy
however what is lacking in content
management is the measurement how do we
know that this content piece that went
out whether it was a video uh whether it
was an infographic whether you know
regardless of what it was number one how
do we Track Performance number two how
do we know it affected anything number
three what was the pathway where were we
driving people and what did we want them
to do and how successful was that and
then also from an attribution standpoint
did this lead to other things you know
where did this content piece or where
does this channel help us overall an
attribution in driving New Leads or
nurturing people along the path and so
it's getting more than just getting you
know measuring clicks it's it's
measuring actual hard dollars that were
generated based off specific channels or
specific pieces of content uh and then
you know it's developing an
understanding of sales goals what did
the sales department need uh in terms of
information to enhance the CRM so that
they can nurture people along in the
path uh so it's more than just marketing
it's understanding that full scope that
a company has yeah that's a it's an
excellent point and I think another
thing to keep in mind too is is use
actual conversation with your sales
people oh as a one of the few things
it's funny that that marketing and sales
often are their own little silos and
yeah I think one of the best things a
marketer can do is just go and talk to
your best sales people and ask them
what why are people buying us what are
the what what are they what are the
questions they are asking you to answer
I think that can be a because those
questions since they're legitimately
people that are that are engaging with
your sales people and making purchases I
think those are the most valuable
questions you can answer in your copy oh
absolutely I mean short of talking to a
customer talking to your sales
department is the best way to get
information
um it now my before I got into SEO I was
in sales I took sales training and and
you know dealt directly with people so
it kind of I had that uh uh you know
that view of things but I I'm amazed at
how much people don't interact with
their sales department in order to learn
uh you know what do people need how do
we answer their questions what you know
what do they respond to but then also
your sales people are the first in line
entering information into the CRM and
when leads are created through your
marketing efforts it'd be good to ask
them what additional information do you
need that would make a better lead
you know there and there are many times
where we have changed the site on the
recommendation of the sales team and you
know we we may not have it we didn't
improve conversions but we what we
improved were the the the scenario
through which the sales call then came
after the conversion and increased the
close rate just based on changing the
landing page or the thank you page after
the registration right and it's it's a
good conversation to start having with
your sales Fields who said that they
know what kind of questions to listen to
because a lot of times they're just not
paying attention you ask a salesperson
they made the sale because I was a great
sales guy
um but the more you the more you work
with them as a team and say that hey you
know to get them thinking about actually
listening to what the customer is asking
for and passing that on to you
um you know that of course will will
help lead attribution and and all the
things you said so yeah definitely don't
forget the human element in SEO well and
this gets to you know this really gets
to it
if the trend now is moving more towards
you know someone who can manage a full
stack it's also moving towards people
who understand how to align sales and
marketing goals and beyond that it's not
just you know like the example I gave
before it's not just okay we increase
the conversion rate of our registration
okay that's great how did that
contribute to revenue but now it's
understanding that there are things that
we can do to increase a close rate that
don't always take place on the website
but it's a process and so now we're
analyzing processes that can be done
electronically and then how do we create
a better Revenue stream that way how do
we make a better nurture process now
we're getting into the effectiveness of
content and producing a result rather
than just you know a conversion uh a
sale or a lead now we're looking at well
how do we make more money based out of
this uh and that's really it's that big
picture of understanding that you know
our job is not just to get leads it's to
create better profitable ability which
rewards everybody
so it's understanding those touch points
from content uh you know so as content
is being pushed out does it answer the
question does it lead people to the next
stage how quickly does it lead them
there uh can you measure influence from
your content and you know through depth
of visitor to the depth of the page that
they got to
um and then again it's the experience
based on motivations can you understand
that can you tie together what a
customer was feeling at a specific point
through their nurture stream uh or
through this process as I said it's
getting away from more just stuff that
happens on the site it's Communications
throughout the entire process the entire
life cycle of a customer that's all
coming under the the management really
of the marketing team right now is that
entire customer life cycle communication
and management
uh and finally this is something a trend
that I've been seeing as well in terms
of uh jobs and hiring and also business
function uh omcp did a a survey at the
beginning of the year asking people
where they spent the most amount of
their time and specifically in SEO and
SEO managers uh and uh
anyone who dealt with SEO nearly 40
percent of their time was spent
uh presenting their research presenting
strategy as well as uh as well as
explaining their the reasoning for that
strategy and so seos you need to become
a lot more comfortable in front of
people uh presenting your findings
making recommendations presenting
opportunities Trends uh and presenting
it in a persuasive
format uh that shows not a bunch of data
charts but shows how smart you are in
creating new Revenue opportunities for
the company
and that is really where we see a lot of
things going are the presentation skills
are becoming part of the demand uh for
companies when they're dealing with tech
if getting your learning started it's
half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit skill up by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know more
keyword research so what are we going to
talk about when we talk about keyword
research we're going to talk about why
we would do keyword research for SEO
we're going to talk about the types of
keywords that we need to research we're
going to talk about some methodologies
best practices on how to do keyword
research some alternate suggestions
we're going to talk about keyword
clustering and then we're going to talk
about some tools that you can use to do
your keyword research so let's start
with the why we would do keyword
research so Jesse is planning to publish
a Blog of pizza recipes so she was doing
pizza recipe step by step piece of
recipes with sausage homemade pizza
toppings pizza dough recipes thin crust
pizzas she's doing a lot of different
topics on pizza recipes well what Jesse
needs to do is understand what's going
to drive traffic to these blog posts if
she's writing about you know different
topics around pizza recipe a piece so
she's Unsure how these blogs are going
to drive traffic so she really needs to
understand that hey you need to choose
the right keywords to drive traffic so
the question is if you're writing a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keywords he is maybe
maybe not so you need to take uh care
and shoes in the key words to align with
your content so that's really the idea
of why we would do keyword research
because some of the issues with keywords
that are poorly chosen are they can have
low search volume for example you may
choose a keyword that just a lot of
people aren't using to search for or
they can be highly competitive so if you
choose a keyword that's very broad or
popular it can be very competitive and
take you a long time to be found for
that keyword or you could just make the
mistake of choosing a keyword that isn't
aligned with your content or you can
choose keywords but use them incorrectly
with your content so these are some of
the issues that you can encounter if you
just go about choosing keywords randomly
without due diligence without the proper
research so low search volume will lead
to less traffic High competition you may
not even rank at all okay if somebody
finds you for a keyword that's not
relevant to the topic they're just going
to leave the page and if you're not
using the right keywords and or if you
are using the right keywords and not
using them correctly in the content then
your pages may not even be found in
organic search so you really have to
take care and choosing the keywords to
me that's the most important step with
SEO is keyword research so we're going
to talk about the types of keyword
research then so we have short tail
keywords and we have long tail keywords
so if you write a blog post about pizza
recipes well what are you going to
choose a short tail or long tail so
let's talk about short-term okay words
first so short tail keywords are
keywords that are usually three keywords
in a phrase or shorter in some cases it
may be two key words in a phrase or
shorter so shortcut keywords usually
have high search volume which means
likely means higher competition but what
it also means it could be lower
conversions because short tell keywords
like for example pizza recipes could be
considered a short toe key word but
maybe somebody's looking for homemade
pizza recipes or pizza recipes from
their favorite Italian restaurant so
short taking words may not be as
relevant so if we compare it with long
tail keywords chances are you're going
to have lower competition that's one of
the benefits but you're also gonna have
lower search volume but with longer tail
keywords the key word is probably going
to be more relevant with the content
you're writing about so therefore the
conversion rates likely going to be
higher so that's really the difference
between short-term keywords and long
tail keywords if you want to look at
simplistically short tail keywords are
Broad in nature it's going to capture a
lot of eyeballs but those eyeballs may
look at your content as not relevant
versus long tail K words that may be
very relevant but not as many eyeballs
on them so short tail keywords the
characteristics they're not as specific
usually they're less than three words
they have high search volume and high
competition so if you just choose pizza
recipes could take you a while to rank
for that keyword but when you rank
you're going to get the traffic but
again it may not convert because the key
word is Broad in nature so pizza recipes
is a short tail keyword that may not be
exactly what you're writing about in
your blog post so it may draw a lot of
traffic but the traffic may not do
anything so the longer tail keywords are
very specific they consist of more than
three words in the search query they
have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long take away
word is probably going to be greater
because not many other websites are
trying to rank for that same keyword and
so the benefit of that is if you have
let's just say homemade pizza recipes
with mushrooms that's a long tail key
word but if somebody's looking for that
type of pizza recipe then you know
you're going to track the right traffic
and chances are that traffic is going to
engage or convert based on the type of
conversion you have in place so example
would be homemade pizza dough recipes
that'd be another example more than the
key words in the phrase very specific
we're talking about homemade pizza dough
recipe so we're not talking about just
pizza recipes so it's a little bit more
specific in nature longer tail so these
keywords are used for targeted Pages
including blog posts if you're writing a
blog post specifically about pizza
recipes with homemade dough then this is
the key word you likely would want to
use versus just pizza recipes so let's
look at an example between a a short
tail keyword and a long tail keyword and
to accentuate the differences we're
going to use Google's Keyword Planner
tool so Google's keyboard Planner tool
is located in Google ads the Google ads
platform and when you're in the Google
ads platform you can simply click on
tools and then Keyword Planner and so
what Keyword Planner allows us to do is
get a sense of the type of volume that a
particular keyword has so what Google's
Keyword Planner does is they show you
the average monthly searches this is the
average monthly search volume of a
keyword over the past 12 months and so
in this example we're going to choose
pizza recipes and homemade pizza dough
recipes so one short sale and one long
tail so we enter those keywords in we're
gonna click get results and what
Google's gonna do is it's going to show
us the volume of those keywords so for
pizza recipe we could see the average
monthly search volume is thirty three
thousand one hundred for pizza recipe so
note that pizza recipe and pizza recipes
are closely related keywords and so what
Google does is they consider that a
close variance so meaning if somebody
ties a piece of recipe then they're also
in Google's eyes looking for pizza
recipes so it's a close variance and so
for the keyword pizza recipe which is
short tail we could see on average over
the past 12 months this keyword received
33 100 queries and so if we hover over
the graph we could see basically the
volume the average volume per month so
here I could see for this particular
keyword here the volume per month is 33
to 1000 and then I can see the actual
volume over the past 12 months and then
for the long tail keyword I can see
homemade pizza dough recipe again close
variants homemade pizza dough recipes I
can see over the past 12 months what the
search volume is for this on average
it's 2400 but I could see here in
December the volume went up to 3600 but
for example in May it was 1900. so it's
gonna fluctuate a bit over the past 12
months but on average it's about 2400.
so shorter tail a lot of more volume
longer tail not as much volume but
nonetheless there is volume here and so
these are the difference between a short
tail and a longer tail and so well
Google's Keyword Planner also does is
allow us to get a sense of what the
competition is and so here I can see the
competition is low for both of these
keywords fair enough so we now know that
if we want to optimize or choose the
keyword homemade pizza dough recipe for
our blog post we know for ranks on page
one of Google even in the top spot we
can expect about 2400 search queries for
that keyword now whether you get up 2
400 clicks for that keyword remains to
be seen chances are you're not going to
get all 2400 you're going to get a
Lion's Share of those clicks but you're
going to at least get some volume on it
so even the longer take keywords have a
lot of Promise because there is some
search volume here for this keyword how
to do a proper keyword research so we
looked at Google's Keyword Planner tool
and Google ads and we typed in two
keywords and we were able to get a sense
of what the average volume is so we
definitely want to choose keywords based
on the following factors we want to
choose it based on search volume search
volume is a good indicator of the
potential traffic we can obtain so again
for the keyword homemade pizza dough
recipe we know that it averages 2400 a
month in search volume again we may not
get all 2400 but we're going to get a
line share of that we also need to look
at competition and so Google's Keyword
Planner gives us a high medium or low in
terms of the competition but if you're
somebody who wants to get a better sense
of what the competition is and you
should because competition is a key
component in choosing keywords and so
what I want to do is get a sense of how
many people are actually optimizing for
that keyword so Google's Keyword Planner
tool is going to give me a low medium
high really what I want to do is get a
better sense of that numerically so what
I can do is go into Google search and I
could type in pizza recipes and I could
see there's about 1 billion results
that's a lot of results however that
means that every potential web page out
there on the internet that mentions
pizza recipes is going to be included in
this number here and so I want to get a
better sense of who's optimizing for
pizza recipes so I'm going to put in the
all in title syntax and so what that is
going to ask Google to do is tell me all
the websites that have pizza recipes the
keyword pizza recipes in the title tag
so if I do all entitled colon space then
pizza recipes my result drops down to
336 000. so what that tells me is that
there are 336
000 results with the keyword pizza
recipes in the title tag now if I want
to focus in on my other keyword if I
choose uh my other keyword was a longer
tail keyword homemade pizza dough recipe
so if I type that keyword in the
homemade pizza dough recipe or recipes
remember close variance and I just click
enter or type the keyword in and hit my
Enter key I'm going to get 35 Million
results but again is that really an
indicator of the type of competition I
have no because every listing that
mentions homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so I'm going to type in my all
in title colon space and then I'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and I get
2160 different results so here I can see
the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites or web pages that have that
keyword in the title tag so now I have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about SEO
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for SEO and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close Fair audience here
is pizza recipe what was the volume well
we know the volume was 33 100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in in our
volume column what was the competition
well if we go back and type in pizza
recipes it was 683 000 so I'm going to
type in 683
000. what was our next keyword well it
was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes so if I go back for this
particular keyword is 2400 so I'm going
to put 2400 in under my volume column
and then what was my competition well my
competition was I typed that keyword
back in
2160. so I'm gonna put two thousand one
hundred and sixty so now I have an idea
of what kind of volume and what kind of
competition I have now you want to do
this for a number of different keywords
and when you do it for a number of
keywords what you do want to do is
obviously choose a relevant keyword that
has high volume and low competition so
another way of saying it is the volume
or ratio of volume to competition and so
basically what we could do is take
volume divided by competition if I make
that a percentage I can see it's 0.35
percent is the ratio between volume of
competition if I do the same for my
longer tail keyword 2400 divided by 2160
I can see that 111 so this just kind of
proves the point that yeah I'm still
going to get some volume but I have a
better chance of ranking for this longer
tier keyword homemade pizza dough
recipes so you want to be able to do
that for a number of keywords and
examine the volume the competition and
the ratio between volume and competition
for your themed keywords in this case
pizza recipes so relevancy you want to
choose keywords that are very relevant
to the content that you're writing and
then again commercial intent what
keywords are going to drive more
conversions and Revenue for the business
so when we talk about commercial intent
we're talking about you know are you
choosing keywords that are going to get
somebody to do what you want them to do
so we could say You Know download pizza
dough recipes so somebody's typing in
the keyword download pizza dough recipes
then chances are they're going to find
you come to your site and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the key word is it going
to help you drive conversions and
revenue if you're an e-commerce site so
search volume is the average monthly
search volume made for a particular
keyword and phrase so we can get that
number using Google's Keyword Planner
tool in the Google ads platform we want
to Target keywords with high search
volume that will help bring traffic to
the website we want volume but we want
to take into account seasonality as well
so that's where the Google's Keyword
Planner tool comes in place because if
we go back again we can just hover or
over we can get a sense of any
particular Trend going on or season out
so for example if I saw large growth in
the winter months and not much volume
growth in the summer months then that
might indicate to me that this keyword
is more popular during the winter time
so pay attention to the grass that you
know the Keyword Planner tool gives you
use them to your advantage to take into
account seasonality so a good example
would be funny Halloween costumes well
we know that for Halloween you're going
to have a spike probably towards the end
of September all the way through October
and then it's going to drop after
October 31st which is Halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are are choosing to search
for pizza recipes during maybe the
summer months versus the winter months
so pay attention to seasonality it will
affect search volume so competition
based on our example it's one of the
most important key metrics you don't
want to choose a keyword that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of Google
depending on competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
Google's Keyword Planner tool to find
the volume we use the all entitled
syntax to find the competition so we
entered both of those numbers in and we
get our ratio and so when you have these
numbers for a number of different
keywords you want to be able to choose
that ratio of high volume low
competition but always relevancy always
trumps ratio so always go with a key
word that is going to be relevant to
your content don't choose a keyword
that's not relevant if you choose a
keyword that's not relevant it's not
going to bode well for user engagement
so the difficulty of a keyword ranges
from 0 to 100 in Google's keyword tool
so it's going to be easy it's going to
be medium it's going to be hard but my
recommendation is also to get the
numerical factor and that's the all in
title syntax and again relevancy is what
drives the traffic to your website and
keep the traffic there on your website
and also not only will keep the traffic
on your website but hopefully get that
traffic to engage and convert so that's
the key about relevancy you always want
to choose keywords that are relevant to
your content even if it's sacrificing
volume relevancy again trumps volume and
competition so always choose relevant
keywords first so when you do that
you're always almost guaranteeing that
at some point somebody's going to find
your content because somebody out there
might be looking for it and if they do
you're going to get found and then the
engagement is going to be better so
understand your business find keywords
that are relevant to your business and
then focus on those keywords that'll
help you with getting the right traffic
to your site always keep in mind the
commercial intent so these keywords are
more specific and result in conversion
rate for example buying is a good
commercial intent keyword so if you
really want somebody to come to your
website and buy then focus on those
types of keywords in the case of the
pizza recipes maybe it's download could
be our commercial intent keyword again
there may be low search volume but those
are the type of keywords you want to
focus on because that's the type of
traffic you want to drive to your site
so some other examples a commercial
intent keywords or discount deal your
coupon shipping you don't don't be
afraid to use some of these keywords as
part of your longer till keyword phrase
again the volume may not be high but the
traffic quality is probably going to be
better so keyword research is the found
foundation for SEO so if you have chosen
your keywords properly then if you do
get ranked for those keywords then it's
going to lead to better engagement with
some conversions and so when we talk
about keywords we also want to talk
about our primary and secondary keyword
so every page should have at least a
primary keyword and then a second carry
keyword to work with so primary keywords
are really defining the nature of your
content the secondary keywords are
relevant to the primary keyword so why
do we choose a primary and secondary
keyword because you may choose a keyword
as a primary keyword that is relevant to
the content but may not necessarily rank
very high or have a lot of volume that's
secondary keyword is also relevant to
the primary keyword but also relevant to
content and you may rank for that
secondary keyword so you always want to
go with two keywords versus just one
keyword you want to give your yourself a
chance to rank for at least two
different types of keywords of relevant
nature so for web page there can be
several secondary keywords but only one
primary keyword so your primary keyword
is always going to be relevant to your
content secondary keywords can be
relevant to the keyword but and you may
have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary in search Okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so if our primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
these secondary keywords are also
related to content and play off the
primary keyword and so what we want to
do is go to cool Google's Keyword
Planner tool and get an idea of the
volume for healthy diet plan and then
also the volume and competition for some
of these secondary keywords like healthy
diet for weight loss healthy diet food
low carb diet healthy meal plans and
diet plan weight loss so if I go in to
Google's Keyword Planner and type those
keywords in I'm going to choose get
results and now here I could see healthy
diet plan keyword I'm focusing on is my
primary keyword has an average monthly
search volume of 9900 and then some of
my secondary keywords healthy diet foods
diet plan weight loss low carb diet you
know Google will give me a number of
different keywords to work with so I'm
going to look at the search volume of
those as well and so ideally what I want
to do is be able to then look at the
volume and then look at the competition
so healthy diet plan to go into my
keyword analysis here that's my theme so
that's my keyword what's my volume for
healthy diet plan nine thousand nine
hundred what's my competition so my
competition is seventy four thousand
seven hundred and that's going to give
me a ratio of volume the competition of
13 so that's what my content's about
that's a considered a short tail keyword
because it has a lot of competition and
so my ratio is 13 and what I want to do
is I want to be able to put these other
secondary keywords in here as well maybe
even go to a little longer tail because
I want to be able to find two key
release two keywords I want to be able
to find my primary keyword that's
relevant to my content and then I want
to be able to find my secondary keyword
which is again related to the primary
keyword which is also related to the
content and so I want to be able to
choose two keywords basically and I want
to choose two keywords that are relevant
that have good ratio between volume and
competition so that's the whole idea
again I'm how to do keyword research you
want to be able to find your keywords
use the tools available to you and get a
sense of what the volume is what the
competition is look at the ratio between
the volume and competition and then
based on the content choose that primary
keyword and then again based on the
keyword you chose choose some secondary
keywords as well because you want to be
found for not just one keyword but
multiple keywords hey let's look at some
alternative suggestions to keyword
research so for doing keyword research
we want to take into account LSI
keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like quora or Reddit we can use
Google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use popular platforms like
Wikipedia and we can use social media
bookmarking like Reddit so there are
lots of suggestions that we can obtain
from various sources so let's start with
LSI keywords and LSI stands for latent
semantic insect indexing and so
basically what it is it's just keywords
that I'll link to your primary keyword
and so when you're choosing keyword
words you always want to choose that
primary keyword and then secondary
keywords that are similar to the primary
keyword and usually those are LSI or
latent semantic indexing type keywords
so they're used to drive relevant
traffic to your page so if you focus in
on one keyword we want to have other
keywords that are similar to increase
our visibility on the search engine
result pages so we could find latent
semantic index scene right in search so
if we use the term healthy diet if we go
to Google search for example if I type
in healthy diet and Google search all I
need to do is scroll to the bottom of
the page and I can see searches related
to healthy diet so healthy diet menu
healthy diet essay what does a healthy
diet look like notice at the top
Google's also given me some other
suggestions here so they're saying
low-fat diet veganism gluten-free diet
so there's lots of different suggestions
right in Google search bar so all of
these are LSI related keywords so if
you're optimizing a page for a healthy
diet then you could choose low-fat diet
as a secondary keyword you can use
gluten-free diet as a secondary keyword
it really depends on what the content is
but you always want to support your
content with as much LSI keywords as
possible so you can be found for as many
different keywords as possible in Google
search so it's important because if you
have a Blog that you know talks about
python so how do the search engines know
if the website python is about the
programming language or the snake so
Google for example uses LSI keywords to
understand what the page is specifically
focusing on so if you're just focusing
on Python and your content you want to
support that with LSI keywords and so
that will allow your web page to better
communicate with Google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured Snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you could certainly
be found for feature snippet for example
maybe you know healthy diet recipes if I
type that in you can see here there's a
featured snippet so if I'm talking about
recipes that's a key word I may want to
use and if I use that then Google has an
opportunity to see what my content's
about and place my information at the
top in this featured snippet you can
also again see what some of the
questions are being asked what males are
good for weight loss what is a good
healthy diet plan all of these could be
keyword phrases that you can use so the
answers are right here in Google so Cora
is a great platform because core is a
platform that people go and ask
questions in a community response with
answers or responses to that particular
question or topic and so the great thing
about core is it's a good eye is a good
place for you to go to get somebody
ideas about a specific topic so if we're
talking about healthy dieting so we can
find keywords with high search volume
writing quora so the whole idea is you
can look at you know the top five
questions for specific topic like
healthy dieting and find relevant
keywords to healthy dieting so if you
just type in that particular keyword in
quora you're going to probably get some
responses to questions or responses to
somebody else's question and so if we
take a look at core for example so if I
just type in healthy dieting what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna get some
responses to the the topic healthy
dieting so what's the best diet for
Healthy Living what are the top five
tips for a healthy diet habit so all of
these could be keyword phrases that you
could take away with for your own
content and so the benefit here is
you're getting kind of an idea of what's
trending what people are talking about
and if you use tips for a healthy diet
habit for example and you optimize for
that well well again I could turn around
and bode well for you because you could
be featured in Google as a featured
snippet at the top here you can also
turn around and use LSI related keywords
for healthy diet habits and you can
simply just look for those LSI keywords
right in Google remember at the bottom
or at the Top If you scroll down I could
see some related LSI keywords at the
bottom so writing Google as well you
could see in the Google search bar that
Google provides some LSI related
keywords to your query so if I go back
here and type in healthy diet recipes I
can see here Google's suggesting some
other related keywords healthy diet menu
healthy diet for man healthy diet foods
healthy diet for women so these are all
LSI related keywords that you can use to
support your primary keyword and the
content you're writing about so we've
talked about LSI keywords where to find
them so they're found right here they
can be found at the top of Google and
they can be found at the bottom you can
also then go to core as well and get
some ideas for the types of questions
that are being asked so if you ask a
question and use that as your keyword
phrase then again you have an
opportunity of showing up for a featured
snippet in Google just by doing some
additional research within Google itself
or on quora so according to Google the
autocomplete predictions are
automatically generated by Google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for terms so Google
collects all the keyword queries that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms that
people have typed in so if I go back to
Google again if I start to type in
recipes I could see some of the other
queries that somebody else has typed in
or some of the most popular queries
related to that topic so if you enter
the keyword healthy diet Google's going
to suggest multiple keyword suggestions
that users have asked in the past and
you you could certainly get the search
volume of those keywords just by looking
in Google itself I could see for healthy
diet recipes billions of pages related
to healthy diet recipes I can also get
the search volume by going into Google's
Keyword Planner so if I type in healthy
diet I'm going to be able to see what my
search volume is for that keyword and in
addition I can see the seasonality of
that particular keyword and in addition
to that Google is going to provide some
other related keywords to my search
query so if I'm looking for healthy diet
Google is going to suggest hey maybe you
should choose healthy food or healthy
eating or how to lose weight so those
are LSI related keywords that Google
provides in the keyword plan which is
built into the Google ads platform
another option for you is Wikipedia so
Wikipedia is a vast platform of content
so we could turn Wikipedia into our own
assets and use it to our own Advantage
by finding relevant keywords in an easy
fashion so with Wikipedia we can
identify a list of keywords in The Meta
description itself we could choose
keywords from the paragraph of Wikipedia
that has many relevant keywords or we
could take a look at keywords from the
Wikipedia content section so we can also
see additional Pages like the see also
section that gives relevant keywords
that you're looking for we can also look
at the references section as they
contain relevant keywords so go to
Wikipedia as an example and I type in
healthy diet into Wikipedia here I can
get just in the first paragraph alone I
can see some additional keywords that I
might choose to use like micronutrients
I never knew that micronutrients was
related to healthy diet but Wikipedia is
providing some information about what
micronutrients is and maybe I can use
that as a keyword an LSI related keyword
to my content so if I scroll down I get
to see also section so it might give me
some information food information
consumers for example dietary guidelines
I can look at categories like dietetics
and diets I can also look at the
references section so I can also see
what information was provided like
health effects of overweight and obesity
I can look at diet and physical activity
so all of these are related to my main
keyword healthy diet so the answers are
right in here on the platform they're
just all over the page so Wikipedia has
an abundance of information you just
need to know where to look so again with
Wikipedia you can look no further in the
first paragraph you look no further than
the see also section the references
section category section there's lots of
information right on the page itself to
help you get ideas for keywords so if
you Google your keyword with Wikipedia
term in the search query and get
relevant keywords from the title tags on
the search you can also do that as well
so if I type in healthy diet Wikipedia
in search I can also get some
information here as well so people also
search for healthy food advantages or
healthy food habits essay or information
about healthy food all of these are
related to my keyword healthy diet so
again another bit of information for you
to choose or look to choose some
additional keywords for so Reddit it's a
popular Community where people post
content and discuss a variety of topics
so that's what Reddit is so with the
help of subreddits an individual can
find relevant keywords with with high
search volume so in Reddit there's an
easy way to find out keywords they have
a keyword tool called keyword it so the
keyword is the average monthly searches
for a particular keyword so if we type a
Word in key Reddit and choose keywords
from the auto generator list this tool
will extract the keywords and give us
those relevant terms with search volumes
so if we go to the keyword it and Show
an example of that for example healthy
food if I get keywords I can see what
keywords are relevant in the search
volume of that keyword so if I just type
in healthy food keyword tool is going to
tell me some relevant keywords and what
the volume is so if you don't have the
Keyword Planner tool in Google ads
available to you this is a good
alternative solution to finding keywords
so it's free you just need to go to
keyword.com type in your keyword click
get keywords and what it's going to do
is give you some relevant keywords
related to your primary keyword with the
search volume let's talk about keyword
clustering now so the whole idea about
keyword clustering is to really take
advantage of the keywords that we're
optimizing for to gain higher ranking so
if we can cluster keywords together in a
theme and that theme of keywords is
relevant to a specific page of a web
website then we have a better
opportunity to rank so in other words
why do we have to Target just one
keyword when we can Target many so keep
in mind you know LSI keywords we want to
group a bunch of keywords together that
are similar for Content so for example
after some keyword research you can
thematically group keywords into a core
topic so for example we can cluster
these group of keywords together like
for example what is SEO how does SEO
work intro to SEO what are the basics of
SEO all of those are related to the
chord theme what is SEO another cluster
of keywords for example could be SEO
techniques SEO best practices tips and
tricks website optimization on-page SEO
techniques Etc so those are clusters of
keywords okay that we can group together
in themes and if we group keywords
together in themes we can apply that to
a particular content on our website so
the whole idea behind class clustering
keywords it's going to provide more
diversity more of an opportunity for us
to be found so that's the whole idea
behind clustering so some additional
steps remember stay up to date on
industry news to brainstorm your ideas
first and identify a list of keywords
like a thema keywords that you can
cluster together and then you could
determine the keywords that your
competitors are already ranking for so
for example if we want to rank for the
keyword SEO best practices for example
we can use a tool called keyword Moz if
I go to keyword the keyword Explorer
tool and Moz and just type in SEO best
practices what it's going to do is it's
going to give me some volume related to
that particular keyword but more
importantly what it's also going to do
is going to show me what pages are
already ranked for that particular
keyword so therefore I can get a sense
of who is already ranking for that
keyword so here I can see Moz Moz
medium.com alexa.com so I can get a
sense of what web pages are ranked for a
particular keyword or group of keywords
I want to write for myself so if we look
at tools for keyword research look no
further than Moz that's the mods of the
tool I would just use but you could also
use Google's Keyword Planner which we
used in the example so for example if I
go back to the Google ads Keyword
Planner if you're in Google ads you
click on tools you click on Cleveland
planner and what Keyword Planner does is
it provides you for a particular keyword
the average monthly search volume of the
past 12 months it provides you
information on seasonality so if I hover
my mouse over a graph I'm going to be
able to see the volume per month over
the last 12 months what the keyboard
planner also does is it provides me some
additional ideas for my particular
keyword and in addition to that it's
going to provide me some sense of how
competitive that keyword is by telling
me whether it's low medium or high in
terms of competition so there's sem Raj
there's also other additional keywords
tools out there like word stream or href
or the Reddit tool keyword it and then
Moz is a is another tool I particularly
use so if I go to Moz again here I can
just type in a keyword that I'm
interested in it's going to give me the
search volume of that keyword it's going
to give me the level of difficulty so 50
out of 100 so it's halfway between
difficulty and easy and then it's going
to give me some additional metrics like
for example what my expected organic
click-through rate would be if I were to
rank for this keyword but more
importantly what I like about this is we
could see exactly what other sites are
linked to this particular keyword we're
interested in so here I can look at the
top 10 list so this is moz's keyword
Explorer tool so that's what this tool
is and it's part of moz.com so there's a
lot of tools at your disposal I
particularly use Moz I particularly use
Google's Keyword Planner and those are
the tools I use but there are lots of
tools out there Google analytics I'm
very excited to be with you today
because Google analytics is one of my
favorite Google platforms and my
favorite topics so let's talk about what
we're going to cover today I'm going to
start out with how to set up a Google
analytics account and so we're going to
talk about everything that entails
including creating your Google analytics
account we're going to talk about
setting up a property in your account
and what a property is we're going to
talk about setting up a reporting view
in your property and we're going to talk
about installing the tracking code so
those are the series of steps we're
going to go through today in terms of
setting up a Google analytics account so
let's get right to it and so really the
Bruin prerequisite here when it comes to
setting up a Google analytics account is
to have a Google login and ID so when
you actually go to Google analytics you
need to be able to sign up or sign in
and so once you actually sign in then
you're gonna go walk through a series of
steps but really that's really all you
need to get the account going is a
Google ID and login so if you have a
Gmail account or an other email account
that you use for other Google products
then you're good to go that's all you
need to do so when you actually go to
sign up for Google analytics you're
going to be asked to set up a new
account and these are the series of
steps you're going to walk through or go
through to set up a new Google Analytics
account so you're going to choose an
account name and then you're going to
choose a property name okay so the
account name can be anything you want it
to be to name your company your name
whatever you want to name it the
property name is real really the website
name so what website are we talking
about so here I'm going to set up a
fictitious website name for now it's
called demo simply learn so the URL for
this website demo simply learn is going
to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
in analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn we're in jobs and education but
you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
this is important go ahead and choose
the most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and I'm going to talk about why
that's important here in a minute and
then you're going to choose your time
zone and the time zone is also important
because that's when the day starts in
analytics and the day ends based on that
time zone so the data that Google
analytics collects starts and ends with
that time zone so very important to
choose the time zone your business is
located in okay and then you have some
additional options here okay so you have
some settings and so the first setting
is to allow Google products and services
so if you opt into this then basically
what Google's going to do is share some
products and services with you via email
I would go ahead and opt into that
that's of course recommended by Google
it doesn't hurt to hear from Google on
related products and services that may
enhance your business the second is
benchmarking so benchmarking to me is
something you should opt into so going
back to that industry and category we
chose jobs and education so by opting
into benchmarking basically what
Google's going to do is share your data
that it collects on your website in this
case
demo.simplylearn.com it's going to share
that data anonymous anonymously with
others in the industry in this case jobs
and education and because you've opted
in it's going to do the same exact thing
for you it's going to share Anonymous
data on other websites in the same
industry and the benefit of that is we
get to see what other websites or how
other websites are performing compared
to ours what's the Benchmark in our
industry and so the benchmarking to me
is important and I'm gonna go over that
in a few minutes when we go over the
different reports but to me I would
always opt into benchmarking because
this is the only report Google provides
in analytics about how others in your
industry is performing versus your
website okay so it's a way to compare
your website performance against others
in the same industry the other options
here technical support and account
specialist I would also recommend you
opt into those because then it allows
you to basically Google allow Google
access to your account and they'll be
able to help you if you occur or run
into any issues so these are the options
in setting up a Google analytics account
it's very simple very easy to do you're
just entering in a few Fields note that
we talking about a website right now so
I'm talking about
demo.simplylearn.com but just know that
if you want to track a mobile app Google
analytics will allow you to do that as
well you just choose the option mobile
app so we're tracking a website we want
to know how users behave when they get
to my website and that's what Google
analytics is going to allow us to
measure and look at we just need to do a
couple more steps in the process so once
we fill out these fields here we're
going to click get tracking ID now I'm
going to accept the terms of service I'm
going to accept another terms and
service in relation to data protection
I'm going to click accept once I accept
I'm I'm going to be able to get some
tracking code the tracking ID is the ID
associated with your account and so this
number is going to be associated with
your account so your account ID starts
with UA and it's going to be this number
here now the dash one is the property
you set up so in this case I set up
demo.simplylearn.com if I wanted to
track multiple websites under that same
account then I can certainly set up
multiple properties just know that every
property I set up in that account is
going to have a dash 1-2-3-4
Etc depending on how many properties I
set up so by default I set up one
property so my first property ID is dash
one if I set up a second property the
same account number it's just gonna have
a dash too and that's important because
that ID that account and property ID is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking ID up here notice
the tracking ID in the snippet code now
this snippet of code needs to go on
every page of your website that you want
to track and you don't have to put it on
every page but if you want to track
website behavior on every page or
website then it needs to go on every
page of your website so if you're using
a you know platform like Drupal or
Joomla or even more popular platform
like WordPress adding the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
Google analytics plugin to Wordpress for
example and then just simply plug in in
the ID now there's is an alternative to
adding the Google analytics tracking
code to your site and that's Google tag
manager so Google tag manager is the way
I would recommend going so if you're not
familiar with Google tag manager I would
recommend watching the YouTube video we
have on Google tag manager you can just
go to YouTube Type in simply learn
Google tag manager and this will give
you a nice overview of you know what
Google tag manager is and how it works
but basically this is the way I would go
and I would recommend that in addition
having Google analytics you set up a
Google tag manager account and then that
way you can put the tracking code in
Google tag manager so if I go to Google
tag manager and I just go into an
account on tag manager I can just simply
put in the Google analytics ID right
into tag manager and so if I have it in
tag manager then tag manager is going to
be the place that holds the code and
fires page view when somebody comes to
my website so that way I don't have to
add the tracking code to my website if I
do it in tag manager so that's the
recommended method for me is to add the
Google analytics ID associate it with
tag manager if you can associate it with
tag manager then that's the easier route
to go versus putting code on your
website okay so again take a look at the
video we have on YouTube for Google tag
manager that's the route I would go now
once you do get the tracking code on
your website whether that be through
Google tag manager or through a Plugin
or you know just simply adding the
script to your site to pages on your
site then what's going to happen is
you're going to start collecting data so
that's ideally the way it works you need
to add this code to your website now if
you're not ready to do that and you
simply want to to basically understand
how Google analytics works then I would
recommend getting access to Google
analytics demo account and so if you
just type in and search Google analytics
demo account basically what you're going
to do you're going to choose the first
listing there and you're going to go to
demo account so if you have a Google
analytics or Google login then all you
need to do is click on access demo
account and so what Google is going to
do is put this demo account into your
account and so it's going to look
something like this so if I click on
demo account here it's going to add to
my Google analytics account so I'm going
to have then access to the demo account
from Google and Google analytics so I
would recommend going this route here if
you're not familiar or you're not sure
what you're getting yourself into so
think of the demo account as kind of a
test drive you're test driving Google
analytics before you even add any code
to your website so again all you need is
a Google account and if you have a
Google account and you add the demo
account to your Google analytics account
you're going to be able to see how
analytics works okay and so that's what
I would also recommend so if you're not
ready to start adding code to your
website then what you can do is just
simply add the demo account and then
once you add the demo account you're
free to peruse around Google analytics
to see the different types of reports it
has to offer now when you do actually
set up a Google analytics account you're
going to have some settings that you're
going to want to pay attention to so
when you set up the account you have the
account name and then you have a
property so under each property you have
by default you're going to have one View
and so here you can see this view here
so if we look at the account we set up
we set up a demo simply learn account
property is demos simply learn so that's
associated with the website where going
to track and then again by default under
each property you're going to have a
view and so by default the name of the
view is going to be called all website
data and so in that view is where all
your analytics data is going to be
stored so you can see my screen here
there's a lot of different settings you
have you have settings under the account
you have settings under the property and
you have settings under the view so
we're going to talk more about these
settings and future webinars for
advanced Google analytics users but for
now know that there's a bunch of
settings that you have that you can play
around with when it comes to Google
analytics anything from adding users to
your Google analytics account your
Google analytics property or view you
can actually set up goals you can set up
filters you can set up segments you can
link up Google ads you can you know set
up remarketing list there's a lot you
can do in term terms of the settings as
it relates to Google analytics but so
know those settings are there they're
located right down here and this little
sprocket icon that's the admin icon so
if you need to get to these settings at
any time you could simply just click on
the sprocket or the admin icon and then
you'll be prompted to choose any one of
these settings here that you want to
edit or alter so now let's take a look
at some Google analytics reports so once
you've actually set up your account you
have a number of different reports that
you have available to you in Google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customized reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in Google
analytics so if I'm in admin and I'm
looking at the Google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so so
if I click on the real time report and I
just click on overview so basically what
this is going to do is show me at this
point in time how many users I actually
have active on the website okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here I can see that 79 percent
of my users are coming from desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately three percent are coming
from tablet here I can see how they
actually came to the website so this is
the referring Source if they came from
say search or social I can see the
source there and I can see what pages
they're active on and then here I could
see what locations where they're located
and so if I want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview I can
certainly do that if I go to locations
under real time I could see a majority
of my users are coming from the United
States okay where are they coming from
I'll just click on traffic sources and
here I could see the different sources
and mediums medium is the means in which
the traffic was driven so if it's Google
it's either paid search or organic
search so I can see here it's organic
then I can actually see what contents
they're looking at on my website so I
could see currently you have three
active users on the home page two active
users on the Google's women's white t
page so forth and so on now most
importantly if you have a vent tracking
set up so if you taking a look at our
Google tag manager webinar you know that
you could set up event tracking in
Google analytics to measure engagement
on your website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if I click on
events I'll be able to see what events
are firing so here I can see we have
event tracking set up and I can see how
many different events are firing on my
website in real time so here I can see
e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
going to be able to see them highlighted
so if something gets fired it's going to
get highlighted and I could see that
these are the current events that I have
currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if I
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes I can
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look at what
conversions are happening in real time
just by clicking on conversion and so
now I could see I had one active user
who entered the checkout so that's goal
number four so in analytics you can have
up to 20 goals and so here I can see we
have goal number four has already had
one active user and so if I look at the
last 30 minutes I can see I still have
only one goal over the last 30 minutes
and that was somebody who entered the
checkout so that's real time reporting
in summary it just gives you an idea of
what's currently happening on your
website and so for me ideally if I'm
launching a campaign or let's just say
you do a new website redesign and you
want to see how users performing and
behaving then real time is a good option
for you so you could see how things are
happening in real time now let's jump
down to audience reporting so if I click
on audience this is just right
underneath real time I'm gonna see a
number of different reports available to
me under audience and so let's click on
the audience overview report so audience
reporting basically allows us to get a
sense of who is coming to our website
when I say who is coming to our website
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
specific person in fact Google doesn't
allow personally identifiable
information in Google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name uh social security number
credit card information
Etc however we could still paint a nice
picture on who is coming to our website
meaning what country city or state did
they come from what language what device
do they get to our website from how old
were they okay were they male or female
or other what interests do they have
what browser do they use so we can paint
a nice picture based on all this
information that Google analytics
provide providing us under audience so
if I go to audience overview here I can
see I have all these different options
available to me to get a basic
understanding of who is coming to our
website so for example I could see a
majority of the people coming to our
website speak English and are from the
United States okay in fact that
represents 61 of the users and so Google
analytics does a great job of giving me
an overall percentage so if I have a
hundred percent of the users I could see
61 percent of those users represented
English-speaking users from the United
States seven percent represented
English-speaking users from Great
Britain and so when it comes to
analytics we have users and users are
broken down into two categories they're
either returning or they're new so when
you add the Google analytics tracking
script to your website what's gonna
happen is if a user or when when a user
goes to your website they're going to
get cookied if it's the first time
they've been to your website what Google
analytics is going to do is store a
cookie in the browser so when that same
user comes back another day in the same
browser analytics is going to recognize
that that cookie is in the browser and
so then analytics is going to categorize
that user as a returning user okay so
that's how analytics is able to
differentiate new versus returning so if
that user doesn't have a cookie in the
browser then analytics is going to
recognize that store the cookie and then
count that user as a new user and so
when you're looking at analytics you're
going to be able to see a breakdown of
new versus returning so here I can see
over three quarters of my traffic over
the past week here I can see April 6
through April 12th three over three
quarters are new users to the website
here I could see about 23 24 are
returning users okay so I can get a good
breakdown of what type of users are
coming am I driving any traffic am I
driving traffic that's been to my
website before what language are they
speaking okay I can also paint a bigger
picture how old are they are they what
gender are they do they come from mobile
so let's take a look at some of these
different reports under audience and so
if I skip down now to demographics I can
click on overview and when that report
loads I can see now under demographics
overview I can see the breakout of age
ranges and so here I can see the
majority of the traffic coming to my
site again over the past week now if I
want to change this date range I could
simply do that I can change the date
range just by clicking on the date range
and then maybe going say the last 30
days and I can even compare it to the
previous period or the previous year I'm
going to choose the last 30 days I'm
going to click apply I now I'm looking
at data over the last 30 days and again
you can change the date range to any
range you want you can only go back as
far as when you actually created the
Google analytics account you can't go
prior to that so here I'm looking at the
last 30 days and I can see almost 47 of
my users were in their age range of 25
to 34. now when it comes to gender I can
say 66 percent represent males so I can
get a breakout of gender and age as well
as interest and click on interest and
look at the overview there and see what
the interest is of the users who are
coming to my site based on in-market
segments or Affinity I can also choose
language and location so if I want to
know exactly where my users are located
when they're coming to my website I can
click on location and here I can get a
breakout 43 percent of the users of the
last 30 days were from the United States
more importantly I can align my audience
with goals and we'll talk about goals
here in a minute but here I can see if I
have an e-commerce website I can see of
those 43
0.29 of those converted or purchased
something and that equates to 94
transactions so I can get a good sense
of not only how many users are coming
from a specific country but are those
users converting if I click on mobile
and mobile to me is one of those reports
I tend to spend a bit of time on because
I want to know what devices users are
coming to my website and so for my
website here or this is the Google demo
website I can see mobile represents
approximately 27 of the traffic so
desktop still represents a majority of
the traffic so for you you want to keep
an eye on mobile because mobile is
definitely a majority of what people use
nowadays that's how people start their
day that's how they transact Via Mobile
whether that's purchasing something
communicating or searching it all starts
with mobile so you want to keep an eye
on mobile and more importantly you want
to keep an eye on Behavior so Google
analytics is telling me that yes I have
approximately 27 percent of my traffic
of the last 30 days came from mobile how
are they interacting with my website so
if I look across this report I'm going
to be able to see different metrics so
if I'm measuring specific metrics
against my dimension in this case the
dimension is what we're measuring and in
this example we're measuring mobile I
can see that the bounce rate is
approximately 48 and bounce rate means
that if a user user in this case for
mobile landed on a page they left the
site without going any further so they
consider it a bounce if they don't go to
another page if they leave the site from
the page they landed on and they don't
go any further that's considered a
bounce so bounce rate is the percentage
of people who come to the site and leave
the site without going any further so in
this case we have 48 bounce rate that's
almost half of our users who come from
mobile leave the website from the page
they landed on so is that good is that
bad well it's open to interpretation is
definitely subjective but you want to
keep the bounce rate as low as possible
you want to keep people on your site
especially if you have an e-commerce
website you want people who come to your
website to purchase and so here we can
see 48 Mobile in desktop it's a little
bit lower at 41 percent now if I look a
little bit further at engagement I can
see how many pages on average do mobile
users look at so versus desktop it's a
little bit lower you can see 3.86 on
desktop it's 4.5 now if I look a little
bit further in engagement I want to be
able to measure how long somebody from
mobile stays on the website if they're
bouncing at 48 percent but they're also
looking at 3.8 Pages 3.9 almost four
pages per session then that means in
this report analytics is telling me
they're spending about two minutes on
the site and interestingly enough I can
see that mobile over the last 30 days
had more transactions so 51 transactions
versus 34 transactions from desktop and
interestingly enough the e-commerce
conversion rate is at 0.29 percent
that's higher than desktop at .07 it's
lower than tablet but it's higher than
desktop and mobile has the most
transactions and since they have the
most transactions they have the most
Revenue at 2 380. so yes the engagement
isn't exactly as great as it is this
desktop but we can see that people are
still purchasing with their mobile
devices so it's something to keep an eye
on and mobile is something I definitely
look at in fact since it's such an
important report one thing you can do in
analytics is if you actually like a
report and you think you're going to
look at that report multiple times then
you can simply just go ahead and click
save at the top here so if I click save
I'm going to enter a name for this
report I'm just going to call it mobile
report and click OK and then what's
going to happen is it's going to be
located under save reports and save
reports is located under customization
customization is located above real time
okay so if I close that up you can see
audience real time customization if I
click on customization if I click on
Save reports I should be able to see my
save report here and I do so here I can
see mobile report if I click on it I can
simply go to the report I was looking at
before I saved it so save reports to me
is a good feature and analytics because
it allows you to quickly access a report
that you've saved in the past so let's
take a look at one more report under
audience and let's go to benchmarking so
remember when we're setting up our
analytics account we had the option to
opt into benchmarking and I recommended
you do so and so if you did I actually
opt into benchmarking then you're going
to be able to see how your site compares
to others in the same industry so if I
click on benchmarking and then click on
channels what I'm actually able to do
now is compare my website with others in
the same industry so if I go back to say
jobs and education and I choose
education all education as my industry
vertical I should be able to see
websites that are in the same particular
industry and how I compare with those
websites so I'm choosing all countries I
can narrow that down if I wanted to I
can just search for the United States I
can choose a specific State and then I
can choose a particular site size so
here I'm choosing sites by daily session
so these are sites that have an average
of 5 000 to almost 10 000 sessions a day
and so in this vertical education in the
United States sites that have five
thousand to nine thousand nine hundred
ninety nine sessions per day that means
that they're approximately 310 web
properties contributing to this report
okay based on this criteria I chose now
off my site is similar meaning if I'm in
the United States if I'm in education
and I'm receiving 5 000 to 9 999
sessions per day then I'm able to
compare my site against 310 other
websites now Google sharing this data
anonymously from the other websites and
they're doing the same with your website
to those particular websites
benchmarking reports okay so it's a
shared data anonymously in particular
Industries and verticals and so now I'm
looking at a channel report so if I want
to see how I compare to others in my
industry then I can go ahead and see by
channel for example in my driving as
much traffic as others in my industry
and you can see I'm not in fact I'm 76
77 worse in terms of the amount of
traffic being driven from organic search
so anything in red is is going to show
as a negative result a negative
comparison whereas something in green is
a positive comparison so if I look at
engagement I can see that I might not be
driving as much traffic but I can see
that the pages per session are better
than the site average or the industry
average I can see if I go over again
looking just at organic search I can see
the bounce rate is better than the
industry average so the channel report
under benchmarking allows you to measure
how you compare to others in your
industry and you could do so by looking
at location and devices so if you opted
into benchmarking when you set up your
account then you'll be able to compare
your website against others in your
industry in your country region and
based on the size of your website in
terms of how many visitors or sessions
you're getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition so if audience
is who is coming to your website
acquisition allows us to see how the
traffic was driven to your website so
how do these users get to our website
and so under acquisition if we click on
overview we'll be able to see an
overview of how users whether they're
returning are new came to our website
and so what analytics does by default is
they have a number of default channels
and when we say channels we mean
analytics is grouping different channels
based on how users got to your website
meaning how did users get to our website
did they come via organic search meaning
did they type something into Google and
find you in the organic listing
analytics also groups users based on
whether they came to your site directly
meaning did they type in the URL
directly into the browser or did they
bookmark your website and come back via
the bookmark so they're grouping users
under Direct they also group users under
referral meaning do they come from
another website they group users by
social do they come from a social media
platform like Twitter or Facebook if
you're running paid search meaning if
you're running paid search on say Google
then do they come from Paid search ads
now if you're running display ads on say
Google's Network Google's Display
Network that's a default channel so
analytics for group users there so if
they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default Google analytics groups users
and how they came to your website via
these default channels and so I could
see how many users came to the site from
each Channel now if I want to drill down
on this report I can click on all
traffic and then if I click on all
traffic I can go to channels I can look
specifically at the channels report it's
so now I can see organic search again
over the last 30 days days is the number
one channel driving traffic and they
represent approximately again you can
see this number here in parentheses next
to the raw number of users I can see
that number is about 56 percent so 56
percent of my traffic over the last 30
days came from organic search and so
those are the number of users again as a
metric you're also going to have
sessions and you'll see sessions a lot
as a metric so users are broken down
between new and returning so every time
a new or returning user comes to the
website basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and so just like we looked at
with the audience report Sports when it
came to mobile we can also look at
engagement by channel so just like
mobile we looked at bounce rate pages
per session average session duration we
can do the same thing here with our
Channel report more importantly in
addition to behavior we can see
conversions and since we're running an
e-commerce platform we could see what
the conversion rate is by channel so
organic search did drive the most
traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the last 30 days and
the conversion rate in this case is 0.17
okay so how Google determines the
conversion rate they basically take the
number of transactions and divide that
by sessions so that means that over the
last 30 days organic search drove 38 123
sessions and of those 38 000 123 64
actually turned into a transaction which
equates to 0.17 which also equates to 3
000 in Revenue so I'm able to determine
not only how users are getting to my
website by looking at the channel report
I can actually see if they're engaging
and if they are converting and notice
when you look at a report in analytics
you can look at it by Channel you'll
also get a summary so here I can see a
summary or a total based on my date
range so I could see over the last 30
days I've had 54 000 users 49
000 of them were new okay that meant
that at this 454 000 users I had 70 000
sessions I could see my average bounce
rate was 43 percent the pages per
session were just over four and the
average session duration how long did
somebody stay on my website on average
about 2 minutes and 55 seconds the
average conversion rate was 0.14 and a
total of 97 transactions totaling 5500
okay and that's all over the last 30
days so any report you look at in
analytics is going to have a summary and
note that any report you look at in
analytics is going to allow you to save
it so if it's a report you think you're
going to go back and look at at a future
date then you simply just have to click
on the save button conversely if you
don't want to save it you can simply
just export it so you can export it as a
PDF if I click on PDF it's going to
allow me to export that as a PDF now you
have other options available to you as
well you can do a Google sheet you can
export it as an Excel or you can export
it as a common delimited file so here
you can see I can save it as a PDF if I
want to and if I click OK it's going to
save to my desktop or location of my
choosing and then I can go back and look
at it in that format at a later time so
that that's the export feature available
to you in analytics again if you you
could save it as well or you can export
it okay some other reports under
acquisition if you're running Google ads
note that you can connect Google ads to
analytics and this is key because now I
can see how many people are coming from
Google ads to my website and are they
converting now this is important because
with Google ads I'm actually paying for
the click so you can see here I'm
running a report based on campaign data
so I could see what campaigns are
driving traffic how much I'm paying per
click and you can see on average I'm
paying 34 cents per click and then more
importantly I want to be able to see if
they're converting so you can see I've
spent 810 dollars over the last 30 days
and received 858 dollars in Revenue so
you want to make sure that you link up
your Google ads account to your Google
analytics account for this very reason
you want to be able to see how your
Google ads campaigns perform once the
users get to your website and so I want
to see if they're engaging and I want to
see if they're converting so there are
all sorts of reports under Google ads so
you can look at it by keywords by search
queries by hour of the day if you're
running display campaigns you can look
at display targeting it says all sorts
of reports under Google ads you just
have to link it up and you link it up
under the admin now there are other
reports that you can look at so if I go
to campaigns I can look at all campaigns
so if you're running all sorts of
different types of campaigns whether
that be on Facebook whether it be email
whether that be you know other types of
advertising let's just say Twitter or
Instagram you're going to be able to see
those campaigns here and that's under
all cam campaigns and again you'll be
able to see the campaign name and you'll
be able to see metrics associated with
those campaigns and more importantly
you'll be able to see your e-commerce if
you're running e-commerce platform or if
you have goals set up so you'll be able
to look at how your campaigns are not
one not only driving traffic but two are
they converting let's go from
acquisition reporting to behavior so
Behavior reports are going to actually
show you how users behaved once they got
to your website once they landed on a
page on your website how did they behave
so when we looked at audience we got a
sense of who is coming with acquisition
we get a sense of how the traffic got to
our website did they come from organic
direct social Etc the behavior reports
allow us to actually measure how that
traffic behaved once they landed on a
page on our website and so if I go to
overview under B Behavior now I'm
looking at this graph here it's showing
me how many pages I've had and a page
view is simply once a page is viewed
it's counted as a page view so if a user
comes to my site they're initiating a
session and if they look at a page then
that page is going to have a page view
okay so a user can look at a page
multiple times in a session and every
time they look at that page it's going
to count as a page view so here I can
see in this graph how many pages I've
had again over the last 30 days and if I
look further at my overview report I can
see the specific pages and how many
pages they've had and I can also look at
some other metrics okay the average
bounce rate the average time on page I
can look at the exit rate which means
how many people actually exited or the
percentage of people who exited from
that page so I can dig deeper into my
behavior reporting so if I click on site
content and I click on all pages then
I'm going to look at a report by Page
this is my Dimension this is what I'm
measuring my page and now I can see how
many page views each page had over the
last 30 days now no you also have
something called unique page views so
unique page use is equivalent to one per
session in other words if a user came to
my site and looked at the home page then
the home page is going to have one
unique page view and one page view now
if the user in that same session looks
at other Pages then every page that user
looks at it's going to have one unique
page view however if the user goes back
to another to the same page in the same
session then it's still going to be one
unique page view but in this case the
home page if they look at the home page
a second time then the home page is
going to have two page views if they
look at the home page five times in one
session then the homepage gonna have
five total page views and one unique
page view okay so that's why unique
pages is equivalent to one per session
where pages is an accumulation of how
many times the page was viewed in the
same session so in other words you're
always going to have more page views
than unique pages okay so this gives me
a sense of how my pages performed so
again I can look at total page views and
then engagement so ideally what you want
to do with a report like this is if a
user is not engaging on the page then
that should tell you something about the
page itself if they're not engaging if
the bounce rate's high if the time on
page is low if the exit percentage of
exit rate is high then you probably want
to do something with that page now these
are all pages but if I jump down to
landing pages my landing page report is
showing me how many people actually
landed on that page and so here I can
see under my my landing page report I
can see the home page had 36 000 17
sessions in the last 30 days that's how
many people landed on the home page so
here I can see 71 percent were news
sessions meaning that I had a lot of new
users who landed on the home page in
fact 25
000 or 52 percent of the people who
landed on the home page were new I could
see the bounce rates about 42 percent
but of those who didn't bounce they went
on to look at about 4.5 pages per
session and spent about three minutes on
the site and the one thing I like about
the landing page report is I can also
see whether that particular page in this
case the home page did it help
contribute to a goal or conversion and
in this case I can see of those 36 000
sessions I had 22 transactions totaling
1200 in revenue and that that's an
e-commerce conversion rate of 0.06
percent so the home page over the last
30 days contributed to point zero six
percent of the revenue so this gives you
an idea of when somebody lands on your
website and they land on a page is that
page helping to move that person along
meaning are they not bouncing and is
that page helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
case we're measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports under Behavior including site
speed so site speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me site speed is
important because what Google analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they sampled
2835 page views and of that sample they
came back and said the average page load
time is about four seconds now ideally
you want to keep it as quick as possible
I would say even under three seconds
okay now there are other factors
involved with page load time the browser
you're using the country that you're
actually browsing that page from might
know how to have the best infrastructure
you may not even be on the best internet
Network meaning you're on a cell network
or the Wi-Fi is not that gray or you can
be on a page that just has a lot of
images or a lot of code that may slow it
down so there are other factors involved
and so what Google analytics does is
show you what those factors are so here
I can see by browser what the average
load time is if I want to look at
Country I could see what country is
contributing to the load time now the
great thing about the site speed report
is if I go to speed suggestions okay
okay what speed suggestions is going to
do is it's going to show me the page
load Time by Page and then it's actually
going to provide a link where I can
actually click on to get suggestions on
increasing the page load time so for
example I can look at this particular
page here this Google redesign shop by
brand slash YouTube page line number
five if I look at line number five I can
see the average load time of this page
is eight seconds almost nine seconds
okay that's an eternity to some people
now notice this link next to it so
Google's recommending seven total
suggestions so if I click on seven total
what it's actually going to do it's
going to open up a new window and it's
going to open up another Google report
called page speed insights and Page
speed insights is going to give me some
information about what I can do to
create correct correct the page load of
that particular page so so look at the
site speed report it's important because
there is a correlation between site
speed or page load time and user
behavior of that page and there's also
correlation between page load time and a
page ranking organically on search so
page load time is very important it's so
important that I'm even going to save it
so I'm going to click save and click on
speed site speed suggestions as my name
and click OK and now that report is
going to be saved under customization
under save reports let's jump from
Behavior to conversions now conversion
reporting is arguably the most important
section in in Google analytics because
what the conversions reporting allows us
to do is see how people are converting
or if they're not converting on our
website and so in Google analytics we
have the opportunity to set up goals now
you have the opportunity to set up 20
goals in your Google analytics View and
so to set up a goal okay so you're going
to click on admin and Under The View
you're going to see goals and so if you
don't even have goals the first step is
to create goals and so you have four
different goal types and analytics so
you have pages per session so how many
pages per session is so if your goal is
set to say three or two if somebody
actually looked at two or three pages
per session it's going to count as a
goal okay so if I look here I could see
I have pages per session set at 10. so
that means that if a user came to the
site looked at more than 10 pages per
session then it's going to count as a
goal another goal type is destination so
destination means that if somebody
actually went to a specific page then
it's going to count as a goal and in
this case I can see here that the goal
goal is set to this particular page here
and so when somebody actually lands on
that page it's going to count as a goal
now there are two other goal ties we can
look at one is duration so just like
pages per session in our previous
example is somebody looked at 10 pages
per session it's going to count as a
goal but duration it's based on time so
in this particular case if you set up a
duration goal and the duration is set to
say one minute and 30 seconds then that
means if a user comes to my website and
they spend at least one minute and 30
seconds then it's going to count as a
goal okay and then the fourth type of
goal in Google analytics is an event
based goal so when you set up event
tracking you could turn that event into
a goal so if somebody clicks on say the
submit button of a form you can turn
that event into a goal so here you can
see the category equals contact form so
so you can always verify if a goal works
just by clicking on verify this goal and
in this case this event is turned into a
goal so anytime somebody fires this
event it's going to count as a goal so
you have four different goal types in
Google analytics you have pages per
session destination event and duration
and so once you've set up a goal then
you can measure goals under conversions
so now if I look at goals overview I can
be able to see how many total goal
completions I've had so if I want to
look at it by goal I can just choose the
goal option here so if I want to look at
for example goal two engaged users this
was the pages per session I can see that
I had a conversion rate of 10 meaning
that I had 7 000 of all the users that
came to the website 7 000 goal
completions meaning
7106 user others looked at 10 pages or
more on my website and so that's how you
want to be able to measure whether users
wherever they're coming from whoever
they are whatever Pages they look at you
want to be able to look at the
conversion reports to see if they're
actually converting based on the goals
you've set up whether that's pages per
session duration destination or event
goal conversion tracking reports can
help you measure who is actually
converting and the great thing about
Google analytics here is that I can
actually see by segments so the default
segment in a segment is just looking at
a specific user set so the default
segment is always all users however I
can choose a different segment so if I
want to choose instead of all users if I
want to choose Mobile Traffic I can
select Mobile Traffic hit apply so I'm
actually now looking at a subset of data
I'm looking at at mobile traffic so if
all the mobile users have come to my
site I can see 1400 engaged or looked at
10 pages or more okay and that's a seven
percent conversion rate so the great
thing about Google analytics is you have
the opportunity to set up four different
goal types okay based on those goal
types you can go to goals overview and
look at the conversion rates of each
goal but you can also change the
segments of that particular goal to see
who exactly converted okay another
report I like under conversions is the
multi-channel funnel report so if I
click on multi-channel funnel basically
what this allows me to do is see how
different channels work together to
convert so remember the channel
reporting we looked at under acquisition
here I can see now how different
channels work together to drive the
conversion so if I look at three
channels direct organic and referral I
can see all three together drive two
percent of the conversions if I look at
direct and referral twelve and a half
percent if I look at direct and organic
12.24 so I can see how different
channels work together and so if I look
at top conversion paths as an example I
can actually see what channels how
channels work together to drive the
conversion so in this example I can see
over the last 30 days that my top
channel grouping was direct times two
meaning that somebody came to the
website directly meaning they typed in
the URL in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then converted so
that combination is my top conversion
combination of the last 30 days my
second best conversion grouping is
organic search and direct meaning that I
use user came to the website via organic
search first did not convert and then
came back via direct the second time and
converted so basically what analytics
does is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website via
referral or referring website and
converted then the referring website's
gonna get the credit for the conversion
but analytics does a good job of showing
you how different channels work together
so a channel may drive a lot of traffic
like organic search but that traffic may
not convert the first time around for
number of different reasons whether it
could be brand recognition Price
shopping reading content whatever the
case analytics is able to measure if
that channel actually did contribute at
a later point and in this case we could
see organic search drove traffic that
didn't convert but that traffic came
back a second time via direct and did
convert so that's our second best
Channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling Report top
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only have channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns from different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you can get a feel for each of these
reports under each section whether that
be audience acquisition Behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance now if you have any comments
or questions about any of the reports we
covered feel free to comment underneath
this video we're definitely going to
have more webinars in the future about
specific analytics settings that we
didn't get to today and other types of
analytics reports and features that we
didn't get to today the concept of
linking is foundational to good rankings
and understanding the internet at Large
it starts with the premise that good
content will be cited by others
recommending it to other people
how we cite and recommend information
online is by linking to it
we link to information that we find
valuable
based on that the search engines assess
content by how websites link to one
another
so we are going to cover the definition
and purpose of links and the different
functions that links serve
we'll also look at how links mirror
human judgment
we'll look at how search engines
evaluate links by mirroring human
judgment
and how that affects what's called Block
Level analysis
and how where the location of different
links and how they are used will greatly
affect their relevance
we're going to look at how visitors from
different link sources will behave
differently based on where they came
from
and also how you can measure the
effectiveness of links and finally we're
going to look at both good and bad
linking practices now links serve a
number of purposes
from a functional standpoint they
usually are our primary means of
navigation online we click on links we
go to different pages and from those
pages we find links to other pages
links are also a method of citing other
content
when we quote somebody when we use
information that we have found somewhere
else we cite that information to give
credit to the original author typically
online we do that with a link so that if
someone wants to see the original Source
document it's available to them that
also helps to provide credibility to you
credibility to the author of the
original source as well as assigning
importance to the knowledge that came
from that original source and the
authority of the original source
links also provide us with a clear
structure of how our websites are built
how the pages relate to one another and
how organized the information can be
so let's break down the functional part
of a link
this is important if you're going to be
developing anchor text and linking to
understand the structure
the ahref equals is the start of the
link tag
what you are doing is developing the
reference of where the document is
contained that's the href reference is
what it is short for
what comes next within the quotes is the
location of the document now this can be
a full URL or you may just be linking to
a document that's on the main root level
of your server
this is the full location where you can
access the document
and so you're putting the name of the
document the extension so that it will
be linked
the next part is what I have in caps
you'll notice off to the left I have
something in all blue text and
underlined which most people will
recognize as a link
you see when it is in between the
document location
and the closing of the link tag the text
you have in there is what's called
anchor text
you see instead of publishing the
document location and the full URL of
the document
we can put the link within text and
create anchor text so all someone has to
do is click on the link and the document
loads for them
this anchor text is vitally important to
understanding how we can add additional
relevance to linking content
then we see the closure of the link tag
this is what makes the internet the
internet is millions of pages connected
together by Links
so when we look at the functional side
of links and we look at this example
here as you can see the title of this
article is not the URL address of the
article
it's a title and the title is the link
that is the anchor text of the link
and so from a search engine standpoint
search engines look to see what words
are being used in the link and how
relevant those words are to the document
that is being linked
it also looks to see where is the link
is it in the editorial information in
the article
is it part of the navigation
is it in a sidebar or is it an ad
and then also search engines are looking
to see if this is a text link or an
image link
how long has that link been there
what type of link is it does it go
somewhere within your website does it go
to another website or is it a reciprocal
link which I will explain more later
they also look to see the text in the
link and the context to the page with
the link directs you to
we utilize links a little differently
you see from a human standpoint whenever
we refer information to another person
when we provide reference material to
another person or even if someone asks
us for a recommendation we provide this
information
you see offline we mirror the same
behavior as we do online when we link
people ask us for information and we
provide it
we just mirror that online by making a
link
offline we recommend we refer we provide
information to each other in much the
same way the way I want you to think
about it from a human standpoint is that
if you asked another person for advice
or directions or a referral
are there certain people that you would
trust more than others
I'm sure the answer to that is yes and
maybe you have some people in mind that
you are thinking about
you see we run across the same issue
with search
the search engines know that there are
some websites that are much more
trustworthy than others
just like if you were to ask someone for
information I'm sure you would ask the
right person
for the information you would ask the
most knowledgeable trustworthy person
you knew
who had Authority in that subject area
the search engines are trying to do the
same thing with the links that we
publish on our websites they're trying
to determine who is the most trustworthy
and relevant based on the
recommendations referrals and citations
of other websites to other websites
who are the websites that are trusted
that are authorities
the search engines are trying to do from
a technical algorithmic standpoint what
we do naturally from a human standpoint
now from The Human Side as I had said
before we need to think of links as
information that we receive from other
people
Word of Mouth advice information
directions recommendations this is where
we need to think about links not from
the standpoint of building false
relevance for a search engine but being
a helpful resource for our readers how
can we help them how can we provide
information and how can we be a credible
source of information
how can we develop our Authority within
the industry and so that people who have
questions about this content will see
our websites as authoritative and
credible resources
the best way to develop links as you'll
see is good content when people like
what they read when they like what they
see when they are willing to recommend
it to others it's because you have
created something of value
and they'll link to you when they feel
that you are credible
and that you are authoritative with this
information
only then will they share it with other
people
because you have earned that right for
them to share it with others by
providing content that is informative
educational
entertaining and you've provided that
service only then will people then want
to recommend it to others by linking to
it
now links serve a number of benefits
When I look at some of the incoming
links to my site one of the things I
notice is that if I get a link in
certain places that can drive a lot of
brand exposure I can have thousands of
people coming to the site looking to see
an article and that provides a lot of
exposure to a lot of people
however also getting a link from a
certain website especially if it's a
high relevant authoritative website I
can see my rankings increase because of
that
but then also a good link is going to
drive people that will convert and drive
sales or leads those who become
customers
so those are the three aspects of a good
link a good link will drive traffic to
your site a good link will assist your
rankings
and a good link will bring in business
if you can get a link to do all three of
those at the same time that's what I
call the golden link because it has all
three benefits
usually however you're going to find
that different links will provide
different types of benefits one of these
three or maybe two out of these three
one of the things I'm usually very
focused on is the link that drives sales
or generates leads that's getting links
in the right place that will benefit me
tangibly rather than just getting
thousands of people to see it
why it benefits me financially if I can
get a link in the right place
so from here let's break down the
different types of links
we have navigational links we see these
in our navigation our primary navigation
maybe the footer of our web pages where
we have links to typical information
such as about us or contact us
we also have sidebar links this might be
related information or offers or calls
to action
and then also I would break it down into
outbound or inbound type of navigation
outbound are links going to other
websites inbound links are links that
come from other websites and that also I
might send to other pages on my own site
now I've used the term editorial an
editorial link is a link that is found
within the content of the website
and by that I mean through an article
so if I am writing an article and I link
to someone else and cite them or
reference them
that is what's called an editorial link
it means that it's part of the content
a great example of this is that the
navigation on your web pages is not part
of the content
it serves a function as navigation
but it doesn't have anything to do with
supporting information with citing and
Authority
so information and links that you put
within the content and presented content
of your site are considered editorial
now there's also a call to action links
where you're bringing someone to a
landing page or a registration page or a
sale page
then also we have Social Links now these
can provide a variety of means but
typically a social link will go to a
profile
maybe it's a username that takes you
somewhere else or comment or maybe just
an image or something that goes to a
social site or that you have placed on
your own site as well
either way it's all contained within
that social network even though the
links are going on and off your site
they tend to be controlled in that
social environment
now I've used the term reciprocal link
now this is
something very specific
a reciprocal link is one where you would
go to somebody else and you would make a
trade such as if you link to me I'll
link to you and maybe you put those
links on the home page or maybe you
create a page just for that link
you see sometimes it just doesn't make
sense and so the search engines will see
that you've linked to each other but if
there's no contextual relevance if
there's no contextual relevance
most likely you won't get any benefit
because you've agreed to link to each
other for the primary purpose of
boosting rankings
now this is not to say that two websites
can't link to each other because there
is some relevance
we'll look at some examples of that
later on in this module
also then we have advertising links
these can be ads banners anything on the
page that is an advertising link that if
you were to click on it you would go to
that advertisers page
those links are typically through an ad
server and they take place in entirely
different ecosystem
but they are links and we need to know
what kind of links are advertising and
which kind of links are functional to
our websites
now when I broke down the different
types of links so we have our navigation
links we have links in our sidebar and
in our footer with Block Level analysis
does is that the search engines look at
the code of the page they break down the
page because it's very easy to figure
out which part of the code has to do
with your navigation which part of the
code has to do with your sidebar and
your footer and which part of the code
is calling ads from an ad server what
this leaves is the editorial content
your article and the ability of search
engines then to break down your page
into these different elements the reason
why they do it is that the links
contained in the editorial space are
considered to be more relevant in terms
of linking to other websites than any of
the other types of links on your web
page search engines don't consider all
parts of the page to be equally relevant
which is okay because neither do humans
we look at the navigation as utilization
pure utility because it's just helping
me navigate among the different pages of
your website I'm not expecting to learn
anything I'm using it as a functional
means of navigating your site but your
sidebar might have some calls to action
it might have links to other pages but
it's not an article it's what you've
developed and so it might be a little
more important than your navigation but
it's not as important as what you may
have written within content your footer
navigation is basically the same you
control that it's the same on every page
and so what the search engines are
looking for are the unique content
the unique article or information that
you've published and if there is a link
within the editorial content that is
highly relevant because it has to do
with content it has to do with
information that you are sharing and so
the links there are going to be more
highly relevant and are going to be more
important for the search engines to see
you see it's the same way with humans
we're not going to look at navigation to
learn something it's functional the same
thing with the footer and as humans
we're reading the content that you have
in your article and if you link to
another source well you've provided us
with utility but it's contextual utility
because you're citing where you found
information or you're citing an
additional Source or you are linking to
an example and it enables me as a human
to see that understand it and if I need
that additional information I can click
on it and go to it
so I'm going to look at the information
on the page in that article very
differently that I'm going to look at
the headings the navigation the sidebars
or the footer
because the article is what is informing
me and so the links in the article I'm
going to look at very differently and
hold them in a higher level of relevance
now over time search engines have had to
refine the algorithm about links
you see in the early days of search
engine algorithms they used to Simply
count the amount of links than if one
site had more links than another that
made it more credible
however once people started to figure
that out people started accumulating
links by really any means necessary
and they were just looking for the sheer
volume of links because they knew if
they got the most amount of links it
would affect their rankings
and so over the years the search engines
have had to change and adjust and add
more relevance to their algorithm refine
it in order to look at different aspects
of links in order to properly determine
relevance
so over time it wasn't just having a
link it was then also looking at how
many people cite this site as an
authority so looking at the source of
the link and the types of pages
then also looking at the text of the
link and matching it with the text of
the page
does it match is it contextual
and then looking at the type of Link
doing the Block Level analysis
and then also the context the relevancy
of your site compared to the linking
site compared to the link and the
information that's being shared there
also some of the ways that they can look
at it at the age of the link how long
has that link been there
humans do the same thing when we look to
see how long someone has been in
business we're looking at credibility
and then of course there are many many
other ongoing refinements that are going
into the search engines evaluations of
links sometimes the age of the link
isn't as relevant especially when you're
looking for something that has happened
very recently
an Old Link could mean that it's old
news or that something has changed since
then
so search engines are in a constant
battle to ensure that people are not
gaming the system by falsely creating
relevance through linking
the link relevancy and the algorithm is
all about trying to determine who is the
most relevant and credible within this
area
and that is the focus of most search
engine algorithm refinements over the
past few years and it will be into the
future
now this is where I'm going to start
bringing in some screenshots from a link
Management program
as a search engine Optimizer a link
Management program is probably going to
be one of your best friends as you move
along in this industry
in this example this program link Decks
that I'm using will track the incoming
links to my website and it'll also
provide a breakdown as to what type of
website those links are coming from
so I can see how many links I have from
blogs how many links I have from news
sites how many links from wikis how many
links from directories forums social
media public relations sites articles or
additional resources
then I can also add my competitors and I
can compare where I stand in terms of
the amount of links from each source and
where my competitors stand
in this way I can be sure that we all
have a similar link profile you see if
my linking profile looks vastly
different than all my competitors the
search engines are going to see that as
well and know that something might be
different with me good or bad and that's
going to raise a red flag
so I want to look at the linking profile
because every industry and almost every
business is linking profile is going to
be a little different but especially
among Industries we see that linking
profiles that is the amount of links
from different sources it's going to be
slightly different for every different
type of industry or business
so this helps me understand where my
links are coming from which is vitally
important because from a business
standpoint one thing that I've tracked
consistently in analytics is that people
will act differently and also I can
predict which source is going to send me
the best customers
you see just because someone comes from
a link doesn't mean they're going to buy
or become a customer or really become a
lead
many times they're going to come look at
your information and leave
and based on how they come to your site
whether it's through a Blog a directory
a forum or a new site has a lot to do
with how they view your website
and it's all about the context
you see this is what I've learned over
the years is that people will behave
differently based on how they find the
website
what I found is that people from blogs
news sites and articles they tend to
stay longer do more and have a higher
chance of conversion of becoming a
customer or a lead
the main reason is because blogs and
articles they have a lot of context it's
an article someone has taken the time to
write some information out and then link
to my site which means there is a highly
contextual reason for someone to click
that link
also what it means is that there's a lot
less competition for that link when my
link is in that article
compare that with social news or any
type of social site
you see when you're on a social site and
you're looking at your social stream of
information there's a lot of different
people competing for your attention a
lot of different things and it's not
just in one subject area it's usually
from multiple subject areas and so the
context is very low because there's a
lot of different types of information
and the competition for your attention
is very high
because of that people from social sites
or applications
tend to visit more often but they only
tend to view one page and leave
immediately
because they're looking to see what was
interesting and then they move on to the
next subject
that's the difference between how people
react based on where they come from
and so when I'm measuring links I'm
looking to see which links do I have
what's the source and then how do those
sources behave differently from one
another
and why
you see if I find that I'm getting links
from sources that people are staying
longer doing more and converting at a
higher rate then I'm going to continue
to focus on building links in those
areas because it directly affects how I
monetize my website
so here's a strategy in building links
one of the things I'm looking at is the
source of links like I said if I can
find a link Source that's providing
visitors that will stay look at my
content engage with the content and
eventually convert and convert at a
higher rate than other sources of
content or visitors
then I'm going to focus on that source
and so I'm going to look at some high
Authority websites whether they're
industry Publications news sites
education sites those are what are
considered high Authority
blogs articles news sites
that's what I'm looking to do I want to
find the most authoritative website
and sometimes it happens naturally if
people that work at those websites or
manage those sites if they find you and
they like your content they'll link to
it and that way you can get more
credibility more relevancy
certain people certain organizations
certain websites have more Authority
influence than others it goes back to
the question that I asked you early in
this module that how do you know if
someone is more authoritative than
somebody else
we also have mid Authority websites
which you can get some links on and low
Authority websites which are very easy
to get links but here's what I've
learned when it comes to link building
one link from one high quality website
can be worth hundreds or thousands of
mid to low quality links
ultimately it's about quality not
quantity
one of the things that I will do
utilizing my link software is look at
the context of the link
I want to see how relevant this is so as
I said if I want to find a high relevant
website what I'm looking for in terms of
this is I want to see the influence of
the domain as well as the relevance of
the domain those are two factors that
we're going to look at when we're
evaluating the quality of a domain now
as I'm looking at this report here what
influence means is that it is a high
quality website that within the linking
algorithm these sites have a lot of
authority
however they may not be relevant
so for example they may have a lot of
sites attributing authority to them
but they may not be relevant to my
industry which is why we have the next
column of keyword relevance
you see when I'm evaluating my links I'm
looking for the sources that are both
influential and relevant
that means that I've got a link from a
site that fits the two standards of high
Authority it's authoritative and
relevant now it's good to have links
from authoritative sites that might not
be relevant
it's still authoritative
however to get the full benefit I want
it to be influential and relevant but
not to say that I'm not looking for
links from these other sources this is
just a means of measuring what you have
as well as comparing it to your
competitors and other websites
now here's some best practices when I'm
optimizing anchor text I want to
maintain contextual relevance so I want
to use text in the text link and I want
to explain to people what's they're
linking to what they're going to find
when they click on that link if I use an
image as a link I'm going to use an ALT
attribute because if that image doesn't
show up
that ultrabute is necessary to let
people know where to go
but also I do get a little tiny bit of
benefit by using that alt attribute
within the image link
I also want to look at the relevance of
the source page that I'm linking to and
make sure contextually the link the link
text and the content of the page is
contextually relevant to the destination
page
I also want to be sure that I don't
overuse the keywords that I don't make
multiple links to the same destination
that I don't use the same anchor text
over and over
I can be downgraded or even penalized by
the search engine algorithm if that is
found on my pages
so as an example instead of using click
here
for a how-to article I might use the
exact phrase of how to fix whatever it
is and use that as the link to the page
that has the content
that's a simple way of looking at anchor
text am I directing someone to
additional information if I am then how
can I present it to them so they know
exactly what they're going to find and
Link it appropriately
I look at it as developing the next step
for your readers where do you want them
to go what do you want them to do what
resources do you have available to them
how can you structure them so that
they're easily understood and you're
explaining the Final Destination
like I said if you overuse anchor text
you can be downgraded or penalized by
the search engines
so what I will tell you to do is number
one avoid overstuffing anchor content
that means needlessly repeating keywords
in the anchor text don't do that
avoid being redundant meaning don't have
four or five or six links with the same
anchor text going to the same page
that's a clear way of letting search
engines know that you're going overboard
don't just randomly Place links
throughout your text just to get the
link
ask yourself are you really helping the
reader find the information they need
and do it once
and then also avoid extremely overly
promotional words within the linked text
such as best expert cheap number one
those types of things
so a couple examples we can say for
travel advice click here but I would say
here is my travel advice and Link travel
advice rewrite it be creative
if it were easy everyone would be doing
it
but this is where you can write things
in a better way to get the attention of
the reader and position it as a resource
also utilizing your url as the link or
as the anchor text as well for the link
in order to get that click
as I've got it here I would not
recommend that you use that I would
recommend that you avoid that
also the third line the checkout the
best website for iPhones and iPhone
accessories utilizing overly promotional
words is one of those ways that you can
easily get caught by the search engines
now for future considerations when it
comes to Links realize that the majority
of algorithm changes are link based
evaluation refinements because people
are constantly attempting to fool the
search engines and develop a false link
profile
you should work to create high quality
links with high quality content
I wouldn't chase after Poor or low
quality links
now as I've mentioned before there are a
number of tools available for you to
manage and measure your backlinks tools
such as link decks Moz Raven Advanced
Link manager Majestic SEO and then also
you can use your Google analytics as
well however Google analytics only shows
you the visitors that have come from
links and what they've done the basic
functions of Link management software
and there are many other types other
than what are listed here but the first
thing that it does is just provide a
catalog of incoming links from other
domains to your site and your competitor
sites they offer tools for comparison to
see which domains are linking to you
what type of link it is and on which
Pages those links are listed they'll
also report newly acquired links in the
past 30 60 90 days or something similar
to that the purpose of Link management
software is to help you assess high
quality domains versus low quality
domains in terms of importance and
relevance
like I said the first job of a link
management tool is to collect all of
your backlinks you add your domain and
the tools will usually spider the domain
they'll go out into search engines and
go out into many other formats in order
to find and retrace who is linking to
you what page that link is contained
sometimes what text is on that page and
what text is being used in the link they
will catalog all of your incoming links
organize them format them and report
back to you most of these link programs
provide additional filters and
management tools so that you can get
more insights about who is linking to
you how they are linking to you and the
type of site
personally I use Link decks in order to
Monitor and report on my backlinking
so the first report here that I'm
showing out of Link text is that I see
the total amount of incoming links to my
domain this says I have over 2 000 links
and those 2 000 links are on about 1 000
domains on average it looks like I have
about two links from every domain that
is linking to me so this is one way that
you start to look at your links number
one the total amount of domains that are
linking to you and then the total amount
of links available this way you can
isolate domains that are linking to you
consistently and also find those that
may not be the best domains or that are
sending a lot of links that are just not
relevant
the next thing I do in analyzing My
Links is to look at the type of Link
meaning the type of site that it's
coming from
this report breaks down the amount of
links coming from blogs news sites
directories forums social sites articles
or resources now it doesn't usually get
all of those links but it does get
enough to give you an idea of how well
you're doing in each channel one of the
things that I do like about this report
is it also has a timeline so I can look
and see when new links have been
acquired and maybe when some links have
been just disappeared that's called
churn and it's normal it's normal
because many times a link is published
on social media and it kind of just goes
away or it's not tracked anymore by your
link management software it can't find
it anymore and so linking is always
Dynamic you are always gaining new links
and losing old links there's going to be
a normal amount of churn
the next report shows me all of the
domains that are linking to me it also
shows me in the next column how many of
those domains are also linking to at
least one competitor and it will list as
many competitors as I have listed in
here if they list to multiple
competitors
it would let me know the influence of
that site or the authority that site is
seen because of the amount of websites
and credibility that Authority has for
that domain it'll also let me know the
keyword relevance how relevant that
website is overall contextually to my
domain and the content that I have
it will also let me know how many pages
on that domain have links to my website
so I can also go through and I can
filter this list by the type of site I
can filter by those domains that are
using anchor text to see how much anchor
text is being used and what type of
anchor text there are many different
ways that you can filter through all of
the domains that are linking to you in
order to get an idea of what's happening
on your domain
what are competitors doing and also the
relevance of those links to your site
now when I say that I can add
competitors this is another type of
report very similar to the one I showed
earlier where I look at my own standing
in the different types of sources of
links such as blogs directories forums
and so on I can also when I add my
competitors look to see how they are
performing in those different areas as
well and so I can compare my link
profile to my competitors
different Industries are going to have
different backlink profiles they might
be more heavily weighted towards blogs
or they might be more heavily weighted
towards forums or social sites in this
way I can look to see if my competitors
are actively link building and how
they're going about it I can see where
maybe they are excelling in one area
that the rest of the competitors are not
so I can compare different strategies I
can also compare different timelines to
see if I am acquiring Links at a faster
rate than my competitors this is very
important if you are a newer business or
a newer website trying to compete
now specifically what I can do is look
at an individual domain in this case
this domain has three pages linking to
me and that domain also links to two of
my competitors I can look at the
specific pages and what I'm looking at
here are Snippets this should be
familiar to you because what it's
showing is the URL of the page that's
linking to my page it shows me the page
title of that page and then in this
report it lets me know if there are any
keywords being used in the link in the
anchor text as well as the number of
links from that page now what this tells
me is that this is most likely a
directory something that is listing all
the different places that where you can
buy products because it's most likely
the linking to the domain name seeing
that there are no keywords being used in
Anchor text and also that there are 16
out about links from that page that
means that it must be a list of some
sort and they are linking not only to me
but most likely to competitors as well
so I can track my Links at the Domain
level and at the page level I can look
to see which Pages might have more
influence or relevance to my content I
can also see the link URL the page title
if any keywords are being used in the
anchor text and also within the context
of how many additional links are leaving
from that page if there are a high
amount of outgoing links on that page
then a link from that page might not be
as valuable since there are so many
links the less links there are coming
out from that page the more it will
benefit my site because I'm getting more
benefit from less links
now also what I'm going to do is compare
the link reports to my analytics I'm
going to go to my analytics because
linking software does not show traffic
it doesn't show how many people are
clicking on the link it only shows who's
linking to you but it does not show
visitor activity analytics will show you
visitor activity to see which domains
are most effective in sending visitors
to your site if you'll go back to the
primary benefits of linking visitors
branding and business analytics show me
visitors and business it shows me which
domains are sending me visitors and
which of those visitors are becoming
customers
so what I can do is go to Google
analytics look at all the domains that
are referring traffic to my site I can
also click on the domain and see the
destination page that they are linking
to I can see how many visitors are
coming either monthly or annually how
often they're coming back whether
they're new users or repeat users how
long they stay how many pages they View
and how many conversions as a result of
those visits this is a great way to get
a 360 degree view of your linking
because not only do you want links that
will help you rank better you also want
links that will send business and
customers to you as well
building links can take many forms
ideally it is through networks
relationships and marketing that other
websites and users learn about you like
you and recommend you to others
unfortunately there is a lot of bad
outdated and untrustworthy advice to be
found about building links to your
website
in this section I'll present the best
practices as accepted by the omcp
standard
the objectives for this module that
you'll be able to develop a link
building strategy
that you'll understand the value of
different link types
finally you'll be able to find inbound
link opportunities
the first step in building links is to
evaluate what you have
now there are many tools available that
you can utilize to do this for you
there are automated tools that you can
get that will catalog all of the
incoming links to your website
some of them are link decks Moz Raven or
Advanced Link manager there are many
that can do that you may also want to
utilize your analytics as well in order
to find websites that link to you
the first step is evaluating where you
are right now
your incoming links have a significant
impact on your rankings
and you can do a lot of on-page
optimization and see some results
however a lot of Google's algorithm
takes into account links from other high
quality websites
now when you evaluate what you have in
this example I'm showing you a
screenshot from link decks
link decks catalogs the incoming links
to my website and it groups them into
different areas
the first way it groups them is by high
value or high influence domains
those are websites that link to me that
have a lot of influence not necessarily
in my industry but High influence based
on the amount of people that link to
them as an authority on many different
subjects
the next way that it groups that is
based on relevance
now this is when it looks at the match
of my content versus the content of the
other website
in the first example we can see the
National Library of Medicine
it is a high influence website because
it is a government website with a lot of
information that is cited frequently
because of the amount of other websites
linking to that site it has a high
amount of influence
now based on the website that I am
measuring
there is a lot of keyword relevance
meaning that that National Library of
Medicine site with the government has a
lot of content that's very similar to my
site a lot of the same keywords are
being used
so not only is this website of high
influence it also has a lot of relevance
and that's key when evaluating my
backlinks
I want to look at which websites are
also referring traffic
so while I may have a link from the
National Library of Medicine I want to
look at my analytics and look to see is
it also providing visitors
our visitors following that link to my
site and I also want to look at the
quality of traffic that it produces
do these visitors stay longer than
average
do they convert more than average I want
to look at the quality of traffic based
on the source
next I want to look at the incoming
links from those other websites number
one I want to make sure that the
incoming link from the other site is
both accurate and relevant meaning the
text that is used in the link is it
accurate to the content that will appear
on the page when the visitor clicks that
link
is the content relevant this is
especially relevant if I have updated my
website changed the content or moved
things around
I want to be sure that that incoming
link sends visitors to the appropriate
page and the appropriate information
I also want to ensure that that link is
worded correctly that it uses the right
words that is sending visitors and
setting expectations of the content that
they will see
I may need to contact the website
manager or owner and maybe ask for a
better linked text or a more accurate
page destination
now this requires some interaction with
the owner or manager of another website
and you always want to be respectful of
their time and not demanding that they
make any changes
in some cases the organization may be so
big you may never find the right person
in order to optimize the text or the
destination of that link
you always want to look for accuracy in
cases where your company or website name
is utilized in the link
but also if there is any contact
information such as address phone number
a description of your business and any
content
make sure it's accurate and it all
points to the right place
another way to look for links is to
Simply go to a search engine and start
doing searches
search for your company your business
your company name and look for websites
that may mention you but do not have a
live link to your website
many times your company will be
mentioned or cited but there will not be
a live link you can only find these
through doing searches and seeing which
websites mention you without linking to
you
now this could be an opportunity to get
an Easy Link especially if you can find
some contact information and finding the
right person that could add a link to
your company information
again you'll need to be polite ask for
their help and it will help it if you
can develop the link along with the link
text and send that over
giving them just a quick and easy edit
to be able to add the information
so make it as easy as possible
as an example I've provided a sample
request format
again you want to be polite you want to
be inviting and respectful of their time
and their management
sometimes like I said you may find the
right person that can help you
however the larger the company the more
difficult it will be to make this happen
this just requires your patience
and again being polite and not expecting
the company to do what you are asking
many times this is just a formality and
sometimes companies will act on it so be
sure to approach this with the right
expectations
the next thing I want to look at are
business listings these are the easy
ways to establish links and ensure that
links are where they should be and also
opportunities
look for business directories especially
if your company has a local presence
you can utilize Chamber of Commerce
lists Association lists or local
listings
if they are on websites see if they
offer links that can go to your website
rather than just the list of businesses
that are in the area
even on a larger level you can look for
associations directories or listings
where you can add your business or
double check if your business is there
and always ensure that your business
name address phone number and URL are
correct complete and consistent with
other listings
the next level will require some active
marketing and that's where you search
for opportunities
you can go out and look for other
resource lists within your industry or
directories of businesses within your
industry and you can get a link many
times through membership or submitting
your business as a resource
however you may want to step up your
marketing
you can do that by interviewing your
clients seeing if they might be willing
to provide a testimonial and a link to
your website
you may also want to go out and find
other communities online maybe some
social communities that are relevant to
your industry
get involved with those communities fill
out a profile and get involved by
contributing information
by sharing information you'll find that
people like getting information and
they'll respond by linking to your site
another option is to utilize the tool
that you had for indexing your links
from the first step you can also add
your competitors and you can look at
their backlinks you can look and see
which websites and which domains are
linking to your competitors but you
always need to go and see why what are
those other sites linking to
and what is the nature of that link
sometimes it may exclude you from being
able to approach competitors backlinks
and ask them for links
however if they're being linked to by
companies that are simply stating here
are vendors in this space and they are
linking your competitors and you're not
there
then it might make a lot of sense for
you to approach and ask if you can be
listed as well
however be sure that the links to your
competitors are not from a consumer or
customer relationship
in that case it might be out of line for
you to ask for a link
make sure if you approach anyone who's
linking to a competitor and asking for a
link to your site
make sure the context is right and that
it makes sense for them
and that's the ultimate judge of value
does it benefit somebody else to link to
your site
we all know that it will benefit you
but when you present your link request
you need to offer value and a benefit
for others to link to you
so be sure that you present it in a way
that is beneficial
and good for those people that will be
adding the link they're the ones that
have to take the work to do it and
they're also the ones that are adding a
recommendation for you and your business
so as always you need to be considerate
and patient
now the best way to build links is by
creating something that people like and
sharing it
you see the best way to build links is
by creating value through content or
information or entertainment
you see when people like things they
link to it
if they find a study or a white paper or
research that you performed
they link to it
if you post a infographic that explains
something
and it's attractive people link to it
you see that's what's most amazing about
linking I find that when we put most of
our effort into creating content that
people like
that's what builds the most valuable and
the most relevant links
and so what type of content well you can
create infographics videos top 10 lists
or articles articles with advice or
analysis of Market data or even research
that type of content people love it and
so when you publish it out you utilize
social media to extend the reach and the
visibility of that type of content
and when someone likes it they'll link
to it and recommend it to others
now people also like depending upon your
industry or your business they also like
some personality maybe some humor
people always like expert information
they like the cute this is why pictures
of cats tend to be liked and linked to
more than almost anything else
and also the unexpected
if you can inject any of that into your
content that just makes it more valuable
more personable and again more shareable
by other people and every time someone
shares it it builds a link to your site
you see the best linking is when people
like something
when you create something that people
like and share you might be surprised at
the many opportunities there are
to get links based on your content
I've seen many many blogs based on
cooking fashion Arts Sports music
and when people specialize within a
specific topic they always find an
audience and so anything they publish
builds links
even on certain social media sites such
as Pinterest
people upload pictures on articles and
infographics especially about
landscaping flowers food cars you name
it there is a special interest for
anything and you can develop links from
those social sites to your site
and it can generate traffic
even with a Blog developing articles
that talk about upcoming events new
music Sports whatever it is when you
create content that people like
it takes the longest amount of time to
build content for building links when
you develop your own content that's the
biggest investment you'll make in time
and research and writing and
presentation
however
the result is that when you develop that
content
you will receive the best and highest
quality links and the most valuable
links are going to be to that content
as I mentioned before one high quality
link can be worth more than hundreds or
thousands of low quality links so my
best advice is to create content that
people like that they link to and that
will be high value links that you'll
generate to your site Google tag manager
thanks for joining and let's get started
with this simply learn webinar so let's
start out with why GTM so let's just say
you're Sam and you have your own
e-commerce website you want to
understand how people are interacting
with your website well Sam today's world
of websites contain a lot of
interactivity everything from videos to
PDF downloads to commenting to form
submissions uh to all sorts of chat
functionality interactivity going on
throughout the website so there's just a
lot that you need to track outside of
just page views and so really what GTM
does is they help you track all these
things I just mentioned everything from
somebody clicking on the play button of
a PDF to somebody clicking on the submit
button of a form to somebody entering in
something on a chat function so that's
what GTM is so why GTM because it helps
us track all that interactivity so all
GTM is is really allows you to really
place a piece of java code which is just
script and the script that's added to a
web page to collect information so
that's really what a tag is it's just
some script that gets put on a web page
in order for you to collect information
like page views clicks Etc and they send
it to third-party tools okay so that's
what GTM does it basically allows you to
take all these tags that collect
information and you can use them in GTM
so if you want to for example collect
how many people you know enter a chat
functionality and start chatting well
you're going to take that script and
you're going to put it in GTM and GTM
will then allow you to start tracking
that information so that's really what
GTM is it just allows you to put tags
into a container or think of it as a toy
box you have all these toys and you want
to track well you can put all those
those toys or tags in a toy box or
container and we're going to talk a
little bit more about that but before we
get into GTM let's just say you know
you're communicating with your developer
and there's a new user request on your
web page and you want to update the tag
well your developer considering it's
probably a small update your website is
probably gonna not
um hesitate and is going to go ahead and
turn around and do it normally and so
normally what happens is the developer
is going to go to the website and update
the tag well what if you have a few
things that you want to track all those
things I mentioned before from downloads
to clicks to you know somebody checking
out to watching a video well your Web
Master your web developer is going to go
well hold on a second now all these
requests are going to take time I need
to put them into the work queue so to
speak well what happens is when they go
into work queue usually it's going to
take some time and in some cases you as
a marketer need to launch a campaign and
you want to get that tracking added to
the website in time for the campaign
launch so you want to go ahead and
quickly turn around the tracking for
that particular campaign let's just say
you're launching a campaign and you're
sending people to a landing page that
has a form submission and you want to be
able to track how many people click on
the submit button of that form
submission well if you need to turn that
around your developer's like well I need
to put that in a work queue the time it
isn't going to always work out between
you and your developer is my point and
so that's where GTM comes in because
there is a solution update your tags
faster and that's Google tag manager so
when we say GTM that's what GT stands
for a Google tag manager it's a place
for you to add tags quickly and easily
so tags remember are just Snippets of
code that allow you to track things on
your website interactively interactive
actively and basically when you have GTM
you can bypass the webmaster and do it
quickly and easily so that's what GTM is
all about so why GTM because we just
identified two benefits one you could
track all the interactivity on your
website and two you can bypass your web
developer or webmaster and so that's the
benefit of GTM so the benefit you get
those tags updated very quickly via
Google tag manager okay so that's what
tag manager is so what we're going to
talk about today is specifically what
tag manager is and what it does we're
going to list some of the benefits of
tag manager we're going to show you how
it works and then we're going to show
you how to get started with attack
manager tag manager if you're not
familiar with working with webmasters
and dealing with JavaScript and tags and
all this jargon is just new to you today
okay well don't fret sit back we're
gonna take it slow this is an
introduction into Google tag manager
again let's start out with what is tag
manager so we've already introduced it
to some degree because we already
introduced it as a tool where you can
put all your tags into a toolbox toy box
or container so to speak right and we
already already mentioned that hey you
can bypass your webmaster so you're
probably thinking well if I'm if you're
not familiar with tag manager how can I
bypass my webmaster well first of all
it's a free tool and it's a Google tool
hence the name Google tag manager and it
helps you really that's the main point
it's deploy and track tags on your
website bypassing your webmaster so
that's tag manager and so examples of
tags that can be deployed via Google tag
manager are numerous these are just some
examples like Google analytics
Facebook's pixel tracking or Google ads
There's No Limit into the number of
texts you can track and tag manager
there is no limit you can add any number
of tracking tags and tag manager okay so
some of the benefits well again I we
just listed two you can put any tag into
tag manager and track that onto your
website and we know you can bypass your
web developer or webmaster and what it
also does is it also allows you to test
and deploy your JavaScript codes quicker
so remember these JavaScript codes or
Snippets of codes are just there to
track certain things on your website
whether that be a page view or somebody
clicking on a play button or tracking
somebody who converts or even just goes
to your website so the biggest benefit
is you can take that snippet of code
let's just say Facebook let's just say
you're doing Facebook marketing and you
want to put that Facebook pixel on your
website so that you could track people
who come from Facebook and convert well
you don't need to put that Facebook
pixel on your website you can go right
to tag manager and you can put that
snippet of code right in tag manager
really quickly and the other benefit
here is all tags are managed in one
place and that's that to me is really a
good benefit because when you start
adding tags on your website and you have
some tags and tag manager it just gets
very confusing so ideally all the
tracking codes you have on your website
needs to be in tag manager think about
that all the tracking so if you're doing
Bing or you're doing Facebook or you're
doing Twitter or you're doing LinkedIn
and you're doing Google you're doing all
this type of marketing on all these
different platforms you're going to have
tracking code for all these different
platforms and instead of putting all
that code on your website return gonna
slow down the load time of your web page
and website you want to put them all in
tag manager so they can be organized and
you you know exactly what you're trying
to track and the other great benefit of
tag manager is there's a versioning
control so let's just say you have added
tags to your website via GTM for the
last six months well and let's just say
you add another tag yesterday if you
added that tag yesterday and something
doesn't work well you can just roll back
to a previous version It's that simple
so you have versioning and that's that's
a good thing when you have versioning
you can control what gets published and
if something doesn't work after it gets
published then you can roll back to a
previous version so it's a a peace of
mind so to speak just because you've
added code to your site there's no
guarantee it's going to work and so you
can always control what version you're
dealing with in tag manager and we'll
talk a little bit more about that so the
biggest benefit here to me with tag
manager is you have event tracking and
so we talked about some of the things
you could track on your website from
videos from play buttons to somebody
clicking on the stop on the video or
causing it all the way to somebody again
chatting or let's just say somebody
clicking on that purchase button on your
website okay and you want to track all
these different things these different
interactivities and buttons well event
tracking is what you're going to use to
track all those buttons and to me this
is the biggest benefit of tag manager
and I'll show you some examples as we go
along and if we didn't mention it
already I'll mention it again it is free
tag manager is free there's no limit so
once you have tag manager going you can
add as many tracking codes as you want
there's no limit on the number of
tracking codes you can add to tag
manager okay so it's free and you can
use it to its fullest Advantage okay so
it's also high security meaning that it
has different levels of permissions okay
so you can have uh somebody just go in
and look at the different tags and
tracking codes you have in GTM or you
can ask somebody who is very familiar
with tag manager it can go go in and add
the tracking code to tag manager and
then publish that tracking code when it
gets added so those are all the benefits
let's tell let's talk how it works now
specifically how does tag Manager work
because you're like Rob okay again a lot
of jargon you know you you got tags and
JavaScript and and versioning and
Publishing and all this other stuff well
I know I'm throwing a lot at you at once
but just bear with me here okay so let's
start talking about how it actually
works so you have a website okay
whatever that domain is you have a
website and there's chances are on your
website you have some form of
interactivity whether that be a video
whether that be a Blog whether it be a
form submission you have a website with
some interactivity and let's just say
you're even thinking about getting ready
to launch some type of campaign on maybe
Google or Facebook and you want to drive
traffic to your website fair enough
you're joining the millions of other
websites that are out there that have
interactivity that also Drive traffic to
the website so incomes Google tag
manager and so tag manager is important
because again we know we want to track
people coming from that Facebook
campaign or that Google campaign and
interacting with our site so if you are
running Facebook and you are running
Google analytics well guess what you
want to put that tracking code in tag
manager so Google analytics being a
Google product works very nicely with
tag manager Facebook has its own
tracking code but you still want to be
able to track people who come from the
Facebook campaign to your website so
you're going to get that tracking code
from Facebook and put it in tag manager
that's generally how it works so here
information from your website is shared
with another data source through tag
manager so think about that if I add
Facebook tracking code to tag manager or
let's just say a Google analytics
tracking code to tag manager tag manager
is the one that's pushing out and doing
all the heavy lifting they're the ones
that are controlling what code gets
fired and what code doesn't so if you're
putting the code in tag manager tag
managers controlling the code think
about it that way and let's show you an
example of what that looks like so here
I am I'm in tag manager I just went to
tag
manager.google.com and here I could see
a list of tags so in our conversation
we're talking about tracking Facebook
and we're talking about tracking Google
analytics well Google analytics is easy
because it's a Google product so here if
I look at all the different tracking
code I have on my website through tag
manager let's just take a look at Google
analytics so if you're going to use Tag
manager you might as well put the Google
analytics code in here so here I can see
I have Google analytics as a tag in tag
manager now for Facebook if I'm running
a Facebook campaign well I can take that
pixel tracking and put it in GTM as well
and here I can see Facebook pixel that
is that code is added to GTM I just
basically took what Facebook gave me and
put it in the Google tag manager so you
can see I can add and Facebook and
Google analytics and again I can't
stress it enough any tracking code from
any platform I can add to Google tag
manager in order to track the behavior
from those sources so let's take a
little bit deeper dive into how tag
manager works so I just showed you an
example of how you could take Facebook
and Google analytics code and put it in
the tag manager but if you're not
familiar with tag manager then how do I
do that well let's talk about the
structure and how tag manager works so
when you have a tag manager account you
have a container remember I mentioned
Toy Box earlier you have a bunch of toys
if they're they're code and you're
tracking different bits of code from
different platforms like Facebook think
of those as toys and you have a toy box
okay well that's what this code is and
that's what a container is the code is
the code and that's going to go into the
toy box or container and so the way tag
manager works is you have tags triggers
and variables so if I I take my Facebook
tracking code and put it into a
container I need to set up a tag and a
trigger okay so let's take a look at
what that is so first if I go back to
tag manager I'm going to have an account
and if I have an account I'm going to
have a container so here I'm just going
to click on an account with a container
and a container is nothing more than
what website you're adding the tracking
code to okay that's all the container is
we're just letting tag manager know this
is the website we're adding all this
code too so you have tags triggers and
variables that's the structure of tag
manager so tags are just what it says
tags what are we trying to quote-unquote
tag well if it's Google analytics that's
easy here I could see I have Google
analytics added so if I click on Google
analytics here's my tag and if I take a
little bit of a deeper dive there since
Google analytics is is a Google product
it integrates already with tag managers
it's pretty easy I can just choose
Google analytics then I'm going to check
page view and that's my tag now every
tag needs a trigger okay so I need to
tell tag manager how or when to fire the
Google analytics tracking code so in
this case I'm going to tell tag manager
to fire on all pages so if I get
somebody a visitor to my website
analytics is firing on all pages so
whatever page that visitor lands on
Google analytics is gonna fire so that's
really what it comes down to is I have a
tag and I need to tell tag manager when
to trigger that tag that's really what
the structure of tag manager is it's
tags triggers and variables and
variables what we're going to talk about
here in a couple minutes but you have a
piece of code you're going to go ahead
and put that into tag manager you're
going to tag it and then you're going to
fire that trigger so let's take a look
at another example here if I go back
here you can see Facebook well here's my
Facebook pixel okay that's my tag so
when is it gonna fire well it's gonna
fire on a specific domain or subdomain
that's basically what we're doing we're
trying to tell GTM when to fire that
particular tag so those are the three
main components a tag okay which is
going to contain the JavaScript code
that you get from say Facebook the
trigger so you're going to go into tag
manager and tell tag manager when to
fire that code that's the trigger and
then you have variables and so variables
are basically just additional
information that tag manager may need
for your tag and Trigger to work so
that's what a variable is it's there to
get the tag and Trigger to fire so
variables are divided into built-in and
user-defined variables so common used
variables include say page path or page
URL or hostname or click class again
they're there and these examples I just
gave you are there to get your tag and
Trigger to work think about it that way
they're just that's a component and if I
go into tag manager here and here on the
left side I can see variables so
remember I have built-in and user
defined so built-in means that tag
manager already built these for me so in
case I need to get my trigger to work
with my tag I can use a variable so
those are built in and then I have user
defined so these are what I Define these
are what I created and again the
variables are there to get the tag and
Trigger to work okay so that's the job
of the variable the job of the tag is to
host that JavaScript code okay in the
case of Facebook or analytics that's
where we're putting our code so here if
I click on ADD where surgery marketing
again it's a Google product so I don't
really need to even deal with code I'm
just going to select Google AdWords for
marketing okay so you can see GTM
integrates nicely with some of the other
Google products but let's just say you
have a Facebook pixel tracking code
you're going to choose custom and you're
going to put the code here so that's
part of the tag and then the trigger
again is there to get the tag to fire so
you're telling GTM when to fire the tag
and the variable is there to help you
make sure that that trigger and that tag
work together so that's how all three
kind of work together you need the tag
to put the code you need the trigger to
tell GTM when to fire the tag in code
and the variables there to help you
define when that tag and Trigger should
work or how it should work so again
review tags are they're just small codes
of JavaScript or tracking pixels on your
website and so tags are allowed to
manage events like scroll track in
remarketing clicks downloads files play
buttons you name it even clicks on
external links for example let's just
say you have a click uh or a Facebook uh
icon on your site and when somebody
clicks on it they go to Facebook you
want to maybe track that you're going to
create a tag okay the trigger is there
because you need to tell GTM when to
fire that tag so it's a certain
condition whether it's you know fire the
tag if the URL equals facebook.com or
some other condition so the tag cannot
be created until the creation of the
corresponding trigger so tags and
triggers go together you can't just
create a tag and not have a trigger
otherwise your tag will never fire and
then the variable is there again it
stores the information when defining a
trigger or transferring data to tag so a
variable has a variety of data okay so
you pick and choose the variable you
want to use with that trigger okay so
you're making sure that that by defining
a variable you're making sure that
you're telling GTM how that trigger
should be fired so let's take a look at
another example here of how all three
play together if I'm in this account I'm
in this container if I look down here I
can see Google optimize that's another
Google product so what I'm doing here is
I just chose Google optimize as my tag
it's already integrated so what does
that mean I don't even need to deal with
any code I'm just going to select
optimize well we have the tag Google
optimize but we need to tell GTM how to
fire that and so here we're going to
tell GTM to fire it on all pages so
that's basically a very simple example
because we're firing it on all pages so
if I want to look at something specific
again Facebook here's my tag here's my
code what's my trigger well my trigger
is it's gonna fire on specific Pages how
do I I know that well if I look at the
trigger here I could see the trigger is
a page view but I'm telling it to fire
on this particular hostname so the tag
and Trigger go hand in hand
[Music]
so how to get started with tag manager
so first things first you have to create
that account so you're going to go to
tagmanager.google.com or you can do a
search for Google tag manager and you're
going to create your account and then
when you create your account what's
going to happen is you're going to set
up a container and when you set up a
container you have choices so you could
set it up for your website for an app on
iOS or maybe Android or you can even set
it up for amp Etc an accelerated mobile
page so most people by default are
probably going to set up tag manager for
their website and so when you do that
when you actually select website what's
going to happen is you're going to get
some Google tag manager code in return
and so the whole idea here is you're
going to do a swap what you're doing is
basically you're saying Okay Google I'm
gonna take this Google tag manager code
and I'm going to put it on my website
I'm gonna put it on every page in my
website so notice tag manager has two
scripts one goes in the head as high as
possible the other goes into the body
tag as high as possible and so what
you're doing is you're making a deal
you're putting this tag manager code on
your website and in return every code
you deal with whether that be Facebook
or analytics or optimize or remarketing
or whatever it is is gonna go in GTM
okay it's gonna go into the Container
you created so you need the tag manager
code on your website in order for tag
manager to work okay so when you add
this code to your website then you're
free to start adding all sorts of tags
to your container but if you don't have
this tracking code on your website then
none of the tags you add to your
container are gonna work so that's the
idea behind the container and then one
thing I wanted to mention on the account
is it's a Google account so when you
create your account then make sure it's
the same account you use with say Google
analytics or some other Google product
that's a good best practice is always
use the same email address when you set
up your account so that it integrates
nicely across all the different
platforms meaning you can go from say
Google analytics right to Google tag
manager in one browser without having to
log out or log in okay so when you
create the account you're going to
create your container if you choose web
then you're going to be asked to place
code on your website and when you place
that code on your website then you are
free to start using tag manager and that
means you're free to start adding tags
so if you want to know more information
about installing Google tag manager then
what I would recommend is visit the
quick start guide website of GTM so
again if you're curious as to where that
code is located in Google tag manager
well when you create an account and you
create a container that container is
going to have a specific ID so if I
click on that specific ID here's where I
can get my code okay so again when I'm
logged in to tag manager I'm going to
click on workspace but in the top
navigation I'm going to see my unique
GTM ID if I click on that that's where
my code is going to be located and so
again your code needs to go in the
header and there's another script that
needs to go in the body and if you're
not sure how to add the code to your
website well you can always click on the
quick start guide here okay and that'll
take you to a quick start guide page a
reference page related to Google tag
manager so let's talk about creating a
tag so once you get tag manager
installed I'm sure you're excited to get
going and create that first tag so let's
talk about how to create a tag and tag
manager so when you're in tag manager
all you need to do is basically you're
looking at all your tags if you click on
tag in the left side navigation you'll
see all your tags and there's a new
button there so you just click new and
so basically what you're going to do is
you're going to create your first tag
and so what I would recommend once you
get tag manager installed on your
website I would recommend setting the
first tag up as Google analytics so that
will get you going with tracking page
views on your website when some when
somebody visits your website okay so
ideally that's what you want to do you
want to get Google analytics as your
first tag and tag manager so what I'm
going to do is because analytics is a
Google product it's already integrated
nicely with tag manager so I'm just
going to click on Google analytics it's
going to be a page view that's what I'm
tracking and now I have to set up a
variable and and so what it's going to
do it's going to ask me to set a select
a variable and so what you're going to
do is you're going to select new
variable and what you're going to do is
you're actually going to go and add your
tracking ID here that's going to be your
variable so where do I get my tracking
ID and analytics well if I'm in
analytics I'm going to go to admin and
then under property settings I'm going
to see my tracking ID and all you need
to do then is go to tag manager and
paste copy first you got a copy over
that tracking ID then you're going to go
to tag manager I'm going to paste it and
then that's going to create a variable
for you and then when you create that
variable you're going to see it in the
drop down here so I've already created
it and basically that's your tag with a
variable then what are you going to do
you're going to set up a trigger so see
I have some triggers already set up
you're going to see a default trigger
already set up for you and it's going to
be all pages so ideally what you want to
do is you want to select all pages in
order for analytics to fire on all pages
so that's what we're doing we're setting
up a trigger we're basically telling tag
manager hey if I get a visitor to any
page on my website then I want you to
fire Google analytics so that's
basically in summary how to set up your
first tag and my recommendation is your
first tag should be Google analytics and
when you set up analytics you're going
to have to set up a variable for the
tracking ID and so you get the tracking
ID again from admin property settings
copy and paste that tracking ID over
save it you have your variable that
variable is going to be included in with
the tag then your trigger is going to be
all pages and there you go you have your
first tag you have your first variable
you have your first trigger so that's
basically what you want to do and once
you've added that tag once you've added
that trigger then the only thing you
need to do now is basically publish the
tag and so anytime you save a tag you're
going to go ahead and submit it so that
way it gets published so again what
you're going to do is take a step back
here you're going to choose new tag
you're going to choose analytics from
the drop down menu you're going to
choose page view then basically you're
going to add your tracking ID so you can
set up the variable and then basically
that's what you need to do okay you're
going to add that tracking ID and then
voila that's your tag with a variable
and then once you've done that then
you're going to click submit so when you
click submit you're basically saying Hey
I want this tag to go live now this tag
and Trigger and once you've done that
then analytics is ready to go and
anytime somebody goes to your website on
any page tag manager is going to fire
Google analytics so the great thing here
is you have something called Google tag
assistant and that's an extension that
works with chrome and so when you've
actually add a tag manager to your site
or you have analytics running in tag
manager you can confirm if those tags
are firing properly so let's take a look
at how Google tag assistant works okay
so if you just do a search for Google
tag assistant you're going to see here
that it's basically just an extension
that works in Chrome and unfortunately
it only works in Chrome browser it
doesn't work in any other browser so go
ahead and install that extension into
Chrome and when you do that you're going
to see this nice icon here in your
browser and now if you go to any website
and I click on Google tag assistant and
I click on enable Okay so basically I'm
loading Google tag assistant and now
once I refresh the page I can see that
this particular site has Google tag
manager installed and not only does it
have tag manager installed I can see
that it's also has Google analytics
running and I have also Google optimize
running and I have Google ads
remarketing tag running and tag manager
so that's what tag assistant does it
allows you to see if one tag manager is
on the site and if it is great what
other tags are firing on this particular
site so tag assistance telling me I have
these particular tags firing on that
site and they're firing within tag
manager so tag assistant is a great way
to confirm if one tag manager is on the
site and two what other tags are firing
on the site now another way you could
confirm if tag manager is firing on the
site is you can go into preview mode so
even before you submit and publish your
tag and Trigger you can click on the
preview mode so if I click preview in
tag manager so basically that's going to
put me in preview mode and so what does
that mean well that means that now I'm
free to go to my website and see if
those tags are firing and so let's take
a look at what that looks like so if I
go to the website and just click refresh
then what's going to happen is tag
manager is going to load in preview mode
just as you see here okay so that's
going to take a second couple seconds to
load up and now what can I see in
preview mode I could see that I have GTM
firing but I also have some other tags
found on this page remarketing I have
Google analytics I have Google optimize
I have some other tags firing as well
and so the preview mode shows me what
tags are firing on any given page and I
can also see what tags did not fire okay
so here I have a number of tags already
in GTM but they didn't fire on this
particular page so let's just say I
clicked on the Donate now button I'm
still in preview mode so I'm going to be
able to see what tags fired now I can
see I have a couple of tags that I'm
fired on this particular page and then I
could see what tags did not fire on this
page okay so that's the preview mode you
can use the preview mode before you even
submit a tag and Trigger to see if it
fires and that's the great benefit of
tag manager so if you're not sure if
something's going to fire or not then
you can always go into preview mode um
and if you are sure it's gonna fire then
you can go ahead and submit it so you
can leave preview mode and just go ahead
and submit that particular tag and
Trigger so here I'm going to leave
preview mode and now once I'm done and
I'm sure the tag is going to fire and go
ahead and submit all my changes that
I've worked on in terms of setting up
tags and triggers so that's really GTM
in a nutshell so I have my tags okay my
tags are just Snippets of code that I'm
going to put in whether that be Facebook
or vet tracking or any other Google
product like optimize or pay page view
then I have my triggers my triggers are
there to tell GTM when to fire that tag
and the variables are there to help
those tags and triggers work together so
remember that particular variable we set
up for Google analytics okay so here it
is right here because we want to tell
GTM what property to specifically fire
in Google analytics so that's why we set
up that variable but there are all sorts
of variables Google tag manager has
built in or variables already created
for you or you can specifically Define a
variable so variables are there to help
the tags and triggers work together so
when you set up a tag you set up a
trigger you use a variable you can
always go into preview mode preview it
by going to the website seeing if it
fires if it fires then voila you can go
ahead and click submit and that will
publish the tag and Trigger and you're
good to go that's pretty much how tag
manager works works and again I can't
stress that there is an unlimited number
of tags you can add to tag manager
there's no limit so you got everything
from anything from Google to non-google
to event tracking okay to Facebook to
anything that you want to track you want
to be able to put into tag manager and
again there's versioning that's one of
the great benefits of tag manager so if
I want to go back to an older version I
can simply do that so here you can see
I'm on version 32. that's how tag
manager works and I can't stress that
you know tag manager is there to help
you track interactivity on the site
because if you have a site that's
interactive that has a video that has a
download button let's just say you know
you have all sorts of newsletter
sign-ons Facebook YouTube buttons on
your website just like this website does
and you won't be able to track how many
people click on that particular button
well well you're going to need tag
manager and when you have tag manager
you're going to be able to track all of
these button clicks and interactivity on
your website choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
Plus hours of video content for free
visit skillup by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
we're going to talk about how to rank
number one on Google so let's get
started and um let's go with the
scenario that you have a friend named
Sam and he has a website where he sells
shoes but Sam doesn't understand
why his website's not ranking number one
on Google and so typically the ranked
number one on Google there are some
factors involved and those are factors
that are going to help Sam get his
website ranked number one on Google so
he can sell his shoes get traffic and
convert that traffic to conversions so
there are factors involved and so what
are those factors well it always starts
with keyword research so in order to
rank for a website where you sell shoes
or you sell products other products like
clothing or food or you're an automobile
website you know you're a mechanic it
doesn't matter whether you're selling to
customers or selling to other businesses
you have to start with the keyword
research and so we're going to go into
really explicit detail on how to conduct
a proper keyword research and then the
second factor involved is high quality
content so in order to rank high on
Google search you need to have high
quality content so we're going to go
over what's involved with creating high
quality content then we're going to take
that content we're going to optimize it
using on page elements and website level
factors so we're going to take into
account what's involved with your your
website and what's involved with
specific pages on your website in order
to rank number one on Google then we're
going to get into the off-site
engagement so when it comes to ranking
on Google you need to optimize your
website and you need to do some elements
off your website you need to be engaging
off your website meaning on other
websites and so we're going to talk
about what's involved with off-site
engagement so SEO being a major channel
for most companies and websites where
the opportunity to drive a lot of
traffic is there but you have to earn
that reward the reward is a lot of
traffic but you have to earn the reward
there's a lot of work involved and so
ideally what we want to do is follow
what we call the 80 20 rule when it
comes to search engine optimization and
ranking on Google and what do we mean by
the 80 20 rule well 80 20 means we're
investing 20 of our effort and 80
percent of the results are obtained so
we want to invest 20 and get back 80.
that's basically what we mean by 80 20.
so for example if 20 of our targeted
keywords bring in 80 of the traffic then
that's following the 80 20 rule or 20
percent of our landing pages Drive 80
percent of the overall traffic that's
following the 80 20 rule or 20 of our
backlinks past 80 percent of our link
choose that's the 80 20 rule meaning
these targeted keywords these targeted
landing pages these trying to Target
backlinks using off-site engagement we
want to put in 20 of our effort on those
keywords landing pages and backlinks in
return for 80 percent of the results so
without further Ado let's get started
with the keyword research let's talk
about that keyword research for a
website with shoes and it doesn't really
matter what particular product you have
if you need to rank number on Google it
all starts with the keywords as I
mentioned before and so in this example
if you have a website where you sell
shoes for kids you're going to want to
be found for certain keywords so the
obvious keyword here would be shoes for
kids well every keyword that you target
has search volume associated with it so
that means when we talk about search
volume we're talking about how many
people on average type in that keyword
or related keyword on google.com or
Google search and there's always an
average number of searches associated
with every keyword and we call that
search volume how much search volume so
obviously if we're going to Target a
keyword we want to have as much volume
as possible however there's always going
to be competition for those keywords
meaning there's always going to be other
websites who want to rank number one on
Google for the same keywords and we call
that competition or difficulty so for
every keyword you're going to have
volume and you're going to have
competition or difficulty and the
difficulty ranges as well depending on
the tool you use and we'll get into that
in a minute but search volume is how
much on average people are typing in
that keyword or close variance of that
keyword and the difficulty is measured
in terms of how many other websites are
trying to rank for the same keyword and
so ideally when it comes to keyword
research we want to find that nice
balance we want high volume and we want
low competition but at the same time we
want to focus on keywords that are
highly relevant to our business so if
we're selling shoes for kids and shoes
for kids is highly relevant has high
volume and low competition then that's a
keyword we want to Target so we always
want to focus in on those three areas so
there's always a trade-off with keywords
so shoes for kids might have have high
volume but also might have high
competition or difficulty if we look for
another keyword that's just as relevant
for example shoes for children it may
still have high search volume but the
competition or the difficulty may be
lower and if that's the case then that
may be a better keyword for us to Target
instead of something highly competitive
like shoes for kids we can focus on
another relevant keyword like shoes for
children with just as much volume and
lower competition and the reason why we
want lower competition is because we
want to be able to rank for that keyword
so the higher the competition the harder
it is for us to rank number one on
Google for that keyword and so the whole
idea be on keyword research is analyzing
and choosing the best keywords so we
want to identify a list of keywords that
are always relevant we want to choose
the keyword that your competitors are
ranking for and we want to use
third-party tools to cheese keywords to
identify which keywords have low
competition and what keywords have high
search volume so one thing to take into
consideration when you're doing keyword
research is that the longer the key word
phrase or in other words long tail
keywords or keywords with three keywords
in the phrase or more you're going to
always have less competition but there's
always a trade-off with long tail
keywords meaning the longer the keyword
phrase there's going to be less volume
but the trade-off is less competition
and so what we want to do is we want to
brainstorm some ideas and find those
relevant keywords so let's look at an
example here so if we go to Google ads
so Google ads has a toe call Keyword
Planner and let's just say I have a a
website where I'm selling dried figs and
if I'm selling dried figs I want people
to buy these dried figs however in order
to attract them I want to be able to
show them that hey we have a bunch of
recipes and if I show you a bunch of
recipes where you can use dried figs
maybe you'll buy these dried figs to use
in these recipes and so we're going to
look for keywords related to bread
recipes because if we can optimize for
our recipes page for bread then that
will attract an audience who wants to
make bread and use dried figs with those
bread recipes so that's the example I'm
going to give here and so if I look at
the Keyword Planner and Google ads if I
just type in bread recipes what Google
is going to do is they're going to give
me an average monthly search volume so I
can see the average monthly search
volume here is 60 500. and so in order
to do keyword research what I would
recommend is keep a spreadsheet and so
the idea behind the spreadsheet is to
document the volume and the competition
you're getting for certain keywords so
if I go into a spreadsheet here my theme
of keywords is bread recipes my keyword
is bread recipes and my volume therefore
is going to be sixty thousand five
hundred however if I go back into
Google's Keyword Planner Google's
telling me that competition is low so
that's great I want high volume I want
low competition but how low is low so we
want to be careful so if we're going to
put in numbers into a spreadsheet we
want to figure out what that competition
really is for the keyword bread recipes
so if I go to Google and just type in
bread recipes I'm going to be able to
see
771 billion results for the keyword
bread recipes now is 771 billion are
real competition maybe maybe not what we
want to do is put in a syntax and we
want to put in the syntax all in title
and then colon space and then our
keyword and the reason why we do that in
search is because we want to be able to
identify the true competitive number or
the true number of websites who are
trying to rank for bread recipes and if
we put in the syntax all entitled call
in and then our keyword bread recipes
we'll be able to see that there are 998
000 results that's a lot lower than 771
billion so that means that 998
000 sites or listings have the keyword
bread recipes in the title tag and the
title tag is what shows up in the search
engine results and so if I look down and
scroll down here I can see bread recipes
on every one of these title tags so
title tag is an important element to
rank number one on Google and we'll talk
about that in a few minutes but if we
understand that they're 998 000 results
with bread recipes and title tag then
this tells us that those are the
websites who are trying to rank number
one on Google for that keyword and
therefore those are the websites we need
to jump over in order for our website to
rank number one on Google and so
therefore I'm going to put in 998
000 in my spreadsheet as the competitive
number and so now I could see for the
keyword bread recipes I have 60 500 and
if my competition is 998 000 then my Kei
or keyword Effectiveness index or in
other words the ratio of volume to
competition is six percent so that's
nothing more than volume divided by
competition so that tells me that my Kei
or my ratio between volume competition
is six percent so remember we want more
volume than we want competition so
anytime you do a keyword research you're
going to find a number of different
relevant keywords so if I go back into
Google's Keyword Planner if I typed in
bread recipes you could see that Google
is going to give me a number of
different keywords related to bread
recipes let's just say I have another
keyword that I want to think about
optimizing for being ranked on Google
for and that's banana bread recipe very
similar keyword as bread recipes except
it's a little longer tail now if I type
in banana bread recipe and Google's
Keyword Planner now I can see the
average monthly search volume has
actually gone up it's 368
000. I can also say the competition is
low so those are good signs so now I can
see 368
000 I'm going to go ahead and put that
in my spreadsheet now I'm gonna go into
Google I'm gonna put in my syntax all in
title I'm going to put in banana bread
recipe I'm going to hit enter and now I
can see I have two hundred and thirty
three thousand results with the keyword
banana bread recipe in the title tag so
if I look at the title tags I can see
banana bread recipe banana bread recipe
banana bread recipe on all the listings
in the Google search results so that
tells me I have 233
000 results that I have to jump over in
order to rank number one on Google so
I'm going to put 233
000 in my spreadsheet now I can see my
Kei or my volume to competition ratio is
157 158 and so to me that's a lot better
number to work with or in other words
that's a lot better keyword because it's
just as relevant and it has a higher
ratio of volume to competition so
therefore banana bread recipe is going
to be a better keyword to optimize for
in order to rank number one on Google so
that's the whole idea behind keyword
research you want to brainstorm ideas
there are plenty of tools out there so
the tool I recommend is Google ads
Keyword Planner Google's going to give
you how much search volume they're going
to tell you the competition but then
you're going to go into Google search
you're going to use the syntax all in
title to get a more accurate read on the
actual competitive number and so to find
out how keywords that your competitors
are ranking for you can use those
keyword tools that I mentioned another
tool that I use is mass so Moz if you go
to moz.com they have a tool called
keyword Explorer so if we just type in
the keyword for example bread recipes
it's going to be able to tell us how
much volume and the difficulty so you
can use other tools at your disposal
figure out the volume and the difficulty
there are plenty of tools out there but
the one thing I would just make sure is
you use use everything at your disposal
so you can use social media to find the
most shared article for a particular
topic or keyword like bread recipes you
could check other platforms that have a
lot of shared content like Reddit and
quora where you can ask people about
certain topics using keywords to figure
out how much competition or volume there
might be you could stay up to date on
industry news to get an idea of what
types of keywords are trending but when
it comes to keywords and keyword
research remember for every web page we
want to be able to pick two keywords we
want a primary and secondary keyword so
when we do keyword research and we enter
all our keywords into our spreadsheet we
want to be able to have a number of
different keywords in this case we're
focusing on the theme bread recipes we
want to have different keywords because
we want to be able to choose a primary
keyword and a secondary keyword because
we we want to be able to focus on
multiple keywords for each page because
we don't want to put necessarily all our
eggs in one basket meaning we won't want
to put our emphasis just on one keyword
to rank for we want multiple keywords to
try and rank for so the primary keyword
can Define the nature of our business
the secondary keyword could be just
highly relevant to our keyword at the
end of the day we want to choose
multiple keywords to try and rank on
Google for that page so for example we
have a Blog and we're using ice cream
recipes and we're blogging about ice
cream recipes we can have a primary
keyword that is about ice cream recipes
or homemade ice cream recipes we're
going to always want to find out what
the volume and the competition is our
secondary keyword could be built around
other similar keywords like low-fat ice
cream recipes or fat free ice cream
recipes or low-fat homemade ice cream
recipe is those are complementary
keywords just like our bread recipes and
banana bread recipe so one thing we want
to do when we do keyword research is we
want to be able to Target one keyword
per content when you can Target many we
want to be able to Target multiple
keywords not necessarily Target one
keyword and so we want to be able to
Cluster keywords so we don't want to
Target just one we want to Target
multiple keywords per page and when we
talk about clustering if we go back to
our keyword research what we're doing is
we're clustering a bunch of keywords
under the theme bread recipes and so by
looking at the volume looking at the
competition looking at the Kei we can
choose different keywords for our page
and that's what we mean by clustering we
want to Cluster keywords into a Content
frame so why Target only one keyword per
content when we can Target many because
we don't want to put all our eggs in one
basket we don't want to Target just one
key word we want to Target many and so
that means clustering your keywords into
a theme and choosing multiple keywords
for that particular page and when we do
that we have a better opportunity to
rank high on Google Search and the whole
idea behind ranking high on Google
Search is we can get the volume so if we
know we're ranked number one on Google
search for bread recipes or banana bread
recipe we know we stand a chance of
getting a majority of the volume
associated with that keyword and if we
can get the volume and get the traffic
then we can get the conversions so let's
move on to high quality content and talk
about the impact content has on your
ability to get your website ranked
number one on Google so let's just say
you have content on your website and the
content is ranking on you know page four
of Google and it's that blog with ice
cream recipes and if it's just content
for the sake of content is not really
informative then it's not necessarily
going to get good engagement in the eyes
of Google you know they want to rank
content that's very informative it's
very fresh it's exciting to read it's
interesting it's going to have good
engagement so if it's a recipe or an
article about any topic if it's the
content is just non-informative then
you're not going to get good engagement
and when you don't get good engagement
if people don't stay on the site to
engage in the content and they just
leave the website after landing on the
page causing a bounce then the content
is just going to continue to fall down
the rankings and we want to prevent that
we want to move up the rankings we want
to be number one on Google we don't
necessarily want to fall in the rankings
for our content so content is a key
driver and being able to rank number one
on Google so if the content is on page
nine what can we do well we want to be
able to you know take that content and
do something with it we feel like we did
write engaging content so let's go ahead
and share it on social media and to me
social media is a good platform to share
your content because on social media
platforms like Facebook for example
you're building a community on that
platform that Community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an ice cream recipe especially
in the summertime and you're engaging
with your community on that platform
then the likelihood of that community on
that platform is going to increase
engagement increased engagement will
send social signals to the search engine
that says hey this content is good
quality likewise for any other platform
most social media platforms have
engagement metrics and those engagement
metrics pass signals is it good is it
not good do we like this content are we
giving it a thumbs up are we going to
want to follow it are we going to want
to share it and so if you share content
that you feel is engaging on social
platforms then it's going to be engaging
and it's likely going to cause an
increase in engagement for example a
decrease in bounces and once you share
that quality content then the likelihood
of it moving up the rankings even as far
as number one on Google is going to be
greater so you always want to start out
writing good quality content so let's
talk about good quality content because
Google does take content seriously they
do take into account what other people
think of that content so high quality
content is an important factor so how to
create good content that's always the
question so let's talk about some best
practices here remember in the last
segment we we talk about keyword
research so we want to perform good
keyword research why because we want to
choose keywords remember we're choosing
multiple keywords per page one keyword
could be related to our brand one
keyword could be related to the content
but another keyword could be related to
a user's intent like recipes if you
recall the example we use with bread
recipes maybe somebody's looking to type
in a keyword that says how do I make you
know a bread or how do I make a specific
type of bread or how do I make banana
bread or what's the best recipe for
banana bread they're question related
and we want to be able to answer those
questions so that's where choosing those
right keywords that's going to respond
to a user's intent so starts with
choosing the right keywords so remember
we talked about a number of different
tools when we talked about keyword
research so there's a research tool that
you can use called phrase.io and that
will help you do quick research on you
know keywords and Trends and whatnot so
if you know about a research tool that
you use for keyword research then drop
us a comment below I'd be interested in
getting your comments about keyword
research and what research tools are out
there so if you know something better
than phrase.io drop a comment below and
we'd be interested in getting your
perspective so keyword research is key
but creating content that fulfills users
requirements so answering those
questions it's a recipe we want to
answer that question if it's directions
we want to answer that question if they
don't know how to do something we want
to answer that question and that's the
whole idea behind content content is not
just to fill a page it's to really
fulfill users requirements that's when
you get good engagement so if somebody's
typing in something on Google and
they're looking for an answer your
content should answer that question but
we also want to make the content
readable so in other words you know
write for your audience don't impress
anybody with very high vocabulary type
words that somebody doesn't necessarily
know the meaning of don't use jargon
don't use a street language for example
use everyday common language that's just
easily digestible when your audience is
reading and then we want to keep that
content organized and so when we mean
organized we want to use headers and
subheaders you know break your content
into paragraphs keep the flow organized
if we can keep the flow organized then
it's going to be easier for somebody to
read and then it's okay to add resources
especially resources from credible sites
so if you can incorporate those
resources in there then it's just going
to add The credibility to your content
let the audience know that hey I've done
my research on this topic and this is
what this person has to say about it
this person who seems to be credible
okay so it only adds value to your
content so these are all tips to
remember when creating content and then
the one important tip here is we want to
use white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques that means you know
if we've chosen keywords that are going
to answer somebody's question we don't
want to stuff those keywords into the
content we want the content to be
naturally written so when we say opt for
white hack techniques that's what we
mean write the content naturally keep it
organized keep it readable include
third-party sources and make sure it
answers a question so there are
different types of content so there's
content where you just write words to
install text based you could also use an
infographic infographic is simply just a
graphic that visualizes exactly what
you're trying to explain for example if
we want to write an article about how to
write good engaging content we don't
necessarily have to write all that out
as a text we can create an infographic
so for example example here's an
infographic on 20 effective ways to
basically not bore your readers but
write engaging content so you could see
this is an infographic it's all
graphically laid out so infographics
tend to be easier to understand because
they're visual they're easy for the end
user to comprehend because there's
generally no jargon it's usually images
that are portraying the points of what
you're trying to get across and so it
tends to break it up the monotony of
just text it's more visually appealing
and it's laid out and organized so you
can see this infographic has 20
different steps or rules and they lay
those out all here in this infographic
and the great thing I like about
infographics is you could you could
share them on social media you can
re-engage them as a post you can save
them from really any social platform so
infographics tend to tell a better story
versus say just writing text you can use
video and images so you don't
necessarily have to lay it all out in an
infographic you can certainly insert a
video or an image into your content
especially if it's a blog post if it's a
blog post then sometimes video and
images on its own tell the story you
don't necessarily need text to go ahead
and tell your story a video or an image
as they say tells a thousand words and
so images and videos are great to use in
a blog post so using different forms of
content you know you always want to
review your content when a user dwells
on your web page for a longer time
Google will tend to think okay this
person's engaged so we're going to rank
that favorable so if you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
are going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out in a way that somebody doesn't
necessarily understand so be creative in
the types of content you use so longer
engaging content tends to bode well with
search engines so this is according to
HubSpot so the more word count you use
the more word you use the chances of you
ranking higher are going to be better
just take into account best practices
you want to maybe break up the content
with an image organize it make it
engaging use headers so it's not
necessarily just words it's the words
and how those words are written how
they're structured the types of keywords
you're using how you're engaging with
your audience is a lot of factors again
there's best practices we just went over
but the key is you know if you have
longer more engaging content then it's
going to bode better for you on search
engines so a couple of steps to create
high high quality content so you want to
begin with a comprehensive introduction
so always introduce your content
remember the content should be relevant
to the keywords so if you're choosing
keywords and your keyword research think
about answering that question if
somebody's typing in bread recipes maybe
they're looking for banana bread recipes
how to make the best banana bread or how
to make banana bread using dried figs we
want to be able to align our content
with that keyword naturally you want to
create a title that's worthy that's
click worthy so remember if you're in
Google search and you're doing search
for something simple like bread recipes
we want to make something that's going
to be you know engaging for somebody to
click on like easy perfect yeast spread
or easy crusty French bread or something
that's going to be engaging you know the
best bread recipes or how to make the
best homemade bread you know something
that's going to draw somebody's
attention into the title of that blog
post so we want to include LSI keywords
so what I mean by LSI keywords in your
content we mean you know long tail
keywords make it natural headings and
subheadings should consist of keywords
and variants so if you're writing
headers and subheaders include the
keyword in there and that way the
content always stays relevant to the
audience okay shorten your sentences in
paragraphs so don't write long
paragraphs remember we want to break
this up we want to make it easier for
the end user to read and we want to
always put internal links on our blog
post why because if we have internal
links then if we have a link from one
blog post to another blog post or say
our blog post to an internal page on our
website we want to make sure that it's
relevant content that way somebody's
reading something and you have an
internal link let's just say from a
bread recipes page to a banana bread
recipes page then they may find it
interesting click on that link and go to
the banana bread recipes page so it's
keeping somebody engaged on your website
so putting in internal linking will help
keep the end user engaged because you're
offering up links that's relevant to the
content you always want to break up that
content with images okay we want to use
alt tags meaning we want to pen the
image with text so that way if the image
doesn't load then at least the alt text
will load so we can incorporate call out
boxes and more importantly we want to
update our content regularly so we
always want to get the best recipe out
there if it's banana bread or different
ways to Crepe banana bread or always
just coming up with ways to update the
content so we want to keep our content
our blog post fresh and then we want to
include a CTA call to action if we
include a call to action then that's
going to keep somebody engaged and have
them act on your content so these are
steps to creating high quality content
and so let's look at an example here and
this is a three-month-old post on
BuzzFeed and it's 21 pictures that
restore your faith in humanity so it has
a lot of likes a lot of tweaks and that
means it's engaged people are engaged
when reading that and so if we go and
look at it as an example we could see it
on a buzzfeed here 21 pictures that will
restore your faith in humanity so this
was written back in 2012. again a lot of
Engagement but if we look at it we can
see immediately that it's taking into
account third-party sources it's got
some content it's got images it's being
broken up by images we could see there's
call to actions on there in the form of
social so people can go ahead and go
ahead and share it if they like it okay
it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
because says listen you know it's
engaging content it's probably answering
somebody's question about humanity and
we could see clearly that look you know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take action on this content so not
just video not just images but text as
well and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available so
this is a good post in that regard so
contents updated regularly it's engaging
and it includes sources from high
Authority websites some do's and don'ts
on the content so take into account the
best practices I mentioned about
creating high quality content okay
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know because that
likely is going to be their search and
so you want to be able to respond to the
end user that's part of creating high
quality content different types of
content I.E in the form of infographic
effects or videos or text or images you
can add images from public domain sites
you can be relatable and use examples to
clarify points just like the BuzzFeed
article simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language talk to your
audience as if you they were standing
right in front of you and use bullet
points to exemplify your examples your
points so some Do's the don'ts obviously
don't lift content we don't want to lift
content from another website so that's
plagiarism so we want to have our own
unique content we also don't want to
take images from other websites and so
if you do happen to find an image that
works for your post and it's on somebody
else's website ideally that's not a good
situation but if you do happen to do
that then always give credit to the
website okay so if you took it from
xyz.com credit xyz.com for the image and
even put a link back but ideally you
don't want to take images from other
websites just as much as you don't want
to take copy you don't want to take
images use your own imagery and content
but if you don't have imagery then you
can always go to stock photography there
are plenty of websites out there where
you can sign up for a subscription like
Adobe stock images as an example you can
sign up for an account and in some cases
you can sign up for a free account and
use stock imagery okay don't give less
information to your audience give them
to your audience what they deserve which
is the information they're looking for
they're looking for the best banana
bread recipes give them the best banana
bread recipes incorporate your own
images break it up with titles give them
a good quality piece of content that
they're going to be able to engage with
and so if you put long paragraphs in
your content then it's going to be less
engaging so try to avoid those long
paragraph graphs remember shorten up the
paragraphs keep the language simple add
in images answer those questions use
third-party credible sources but write
it in your own words and you should be
on your way to creating good quality
content okay so now that we've talked
about High
quality content in order to get your
pages ranked high on Google search let's
turn our attention to optimizing on-page
elements and discuss some website level
factors that are both going to help you
rank high on Google search so let's just
do an overview of what we're talking
about when we talk about on-page
elements and website level factors so
optimizing on page elements include a
number of different things but primarily
we're going to focus in on meta tags
also known as meta description tags
header tags also known as title tags and
URLs so those are just some of the
on-page elements we want to be able to
optimize using relevant keywords in
order to rank on Google search we also
want to take a look at some website
factors that will affect our ranking on
Google search they include website
architecture having a secure web site
having a site map and taking a look at
page speed so all of those are some of
the website factors we need to take into
account in order to rank high on Google
search so title tag and meta description
together are considered meta tags so
both play an important role in ranking
high on Google so we want to be able to
write unique title and descriptions for
each page on our website when I say
unique that means a title In The Meta
description need to be different for
every page on the website and so if
you're not quite sure what a title tag
in a meta description tag is if you go
to search and just type in any
particular search query the title tag is
what's going to show up here in bold and
then the description is going to show up
below it below the URL and that's going
to describe the page so both of these
meta tags are important because it
describes what your page is all about
and that's what Google uses in the
search results pages so we want to be
able to pay attention to the length of
our meta tags so if we go back to our
search results Pages met title tags are
generally 60 65 characters meta
description tags are generally 160
characters so anything really longer
than that then what's going to happen is
the meta description tag or the title
tag will get trunk at it and so if we
look here for example we could see all
of the title tags here fit the 65
character limit but if you run over the
character count on meta description then
Google is going to truncate the copy so
you want to stay within your parameters
in order to avoid getting your content
trunk headed and so the other thing when
we're writing title meta description
tags we want to minimize keyword
repetition so if we're optimizing for Q
word we don't want to necessarily just
plug that keyword into the title tag and
meta description multiple times we want
to make sure our title tags and meta
descriptions are naturally written so if
somebody's typing for banana bread
recipe with dried figs you know we want
to have a nice title tag and a
description that is going to get
somebody to respond based on their need
and so we definitely want to avoid
keyword repetition but we want to be
able to use that keyword in the title
tag because if you remember from the
earlier segment when we did the all in
title syntax to find out exactly how
many competitors were using that
particular keyword well we obviously
want to use that keyword in the title
tag because again the title tag is an
important factor when it comes to search
engine results so we want to use the
keyword but we want to avoid stuffing or
using it repetitively in our title tag
and our meta description we want the
title tag and The Meta description to
describe the page sound natural but also
be engaging because the point is we want
people to click on our link and go to
our website from search engines so title
tags with numbers tend to results and
higher click-through rates this is
according to mods so for example if you
just put in a title tag that says learn
digital marketing well that may work but
if you put a number in there like five
easy ways to learn digital marketing
that might get somebody to click on your
link and go to your website so having
questions in your meta tags can also
increase your click-through rate for
example if you just put learn the
importance of first page rankings not
too bad but again generic but if you put
it into the formal question how to rank
number one on Google it's more action
oriented it's gonna get somebody to
resonate with the question that they
have and that may be their query how to
rank number one on Google and and so
these techniques will help you get
higher click-through rates and so
according to backlinko title tag with a
keyword can improve site ranking so
remember we want to include that keyword
in the title tag even though we only
have 65 characters we want to include
that keyword but we want to avoid
stuffing the keyword in there we want to
again make the title tag action oriented
maybe with a number maybe as a question
with the keyword in there once naturally
not easy to do but that's the beauty of
SEO if you can follow these best
practices and write a good title tag
then the chances of you improving in
your search results are going to be
greater so having only one H1 tag in
your post is going to be good so
remember when somebody clicks on a link
so let's say they do find a title tag
engaging and they click on this this
link care and they go to that website
you know you want to start out with
having that particular H1 Tech because
the H1 tag especially with the keyword
in it is going to signal to Google hey
we're organizing our page and because
it's an H1 tag it's important we're
structuring the page according to best
practices so having only one H1 tag in
your post is definitely helpful having
multiple tags H tags in your posts help
organize the page a lot better so we
want to add that targeted keyword in
that tag and your header tag should be
relevant to the content so if we go back
to our example of the using dried figs
with banana breads well the title says
California fig banana bread and remember
the last segment when we're talking
about high quality content well look no
further than including a video into our
content so not only will this video help
keep the engagement high but it breaks
up the monotony of the page and it's
from a third party source so it adds
credibility to the page so adding a
video based on the last segment of high
quality content definitely helps with
ranking high on Google search so
following hierarchical structure that
means putting those H tags in there H2
tags help break up the content and we
want to avoid repetition of H1 tags on
your different web pages of your site
meaning don't just put the same H1 tag
with the same keyword in it and keeping
it blase we want to make those H1 tags
exciting to read but also used
appropriately to break up the content so
remember all white hat techniques we
want to avoid hidden tags we want to
avoid stuffing keywords we want things
to be natural we don't want things to be
forced and your H1 tag should be 20 to
70 characters don't make long H1 tags if
we go back to our page example a short
sweet tag here California fig banana
bread it's relevant to the content it's
short sweet and breaks up the monotony
of the content and more importantly and
again any content you have on the page
should always answer the user's intent
remember people are using search to
answer questions find information our
content should be able to answer that
for them so according to John Moeller
senior webmaster Trends Analyst at
Google header tags would definitely help
Google for rankings in the search
results so we want to use header tags so
when it comes to URLs we want to use
hyphens and avoid underscores so if we
look at this URL here this uses hyphens
fig and banana bread so it's all broken
up with hyphens that's the best practice
remember canonical URLs a canonical URL
signals to Google this is the original
content so we want to use original
content and if you have multiple sources
of content out there on say different
websites we want to use a canonical tag
to signal to Google this is the original
content please Index this content and
that doesn't hurt to use a favicon URL
meaning a small icon and helps to break
up the monotony and help your URL stand
out we can add targeted keywords in the
URL so again looking at the URL here I
can see we're using targeted keyword as
part of the URL structure Fagan banana
bread and that is the H1 tag is fake
banana bread so it's all consistent and
it flows naturally URLs that are no
longer existing then we want to be able
to set up a redirect for those URLs
meaning a 301 redirect is a server
response for Google that says Hey Google
this page is no longer available but it
we permanently redirected it to this
page which is now available so that's
what a 301 redirect does it helps signal
to Google and all the other search
engines that if the page is no longer
there that's fine you're just going to
go to this page this is the page that's
permanently there now and another thing
we want to do here is if you have mobile
URLs you want to include those in the
site map and we're going to hit on that
in just a minute but all urls should be
mobile friendly as well as desktop
friendly meaning take into account this
best practices keep your URLs short use
hyphens put the keyword in that URL and
make it easy to understand want to avoid
capital letters in the URLs the URLs are
case sensitive so go lower case you
should always go lowercase on the URL
readable URLs again the rule of thumb
here is if you understand what the URL
is then Google is going to understand
what the URL is so the shorter the URL
the easier it is to read the easier it
is to read the better chance you have to
rank high on Google search so according
to backlink to URLs that are shorter
definitely definitely help you rank so
we want to be able to shorten those URLs
keep them short and sweet don't make
them long and unreadable so those are
some on optimized ways or on-page
elements that help you optimize now we
want to look at some website level
factors that will help you optimize and
rank high on Google search so good site
structure provides better crawling for
search engine Bots and what do we mean
by that well we mean having your site
organized in a fashion that Google's
going to be able to find all the pages
so what do we mean by that create a
logical hierarchy structure so if you're
selling shoes you know you're going to
have a home page break the structure up
into men's shoes women's shoes
Children's Shoes then under men's shoes
you can have it by brand it could be
Nike Puma Adidas on the women's side it
could be Nike Puma Adidas on the child
side it could be Nike Puma Adidas and so
you want to keep the structure flow and
a hierarchy so we want to balance the
amount of subcategories within each
category so the men's if it has Nike
Puma Adidas the women should have Nike
Puma Adidas and so you want to code your
site navigation and CSS or HTML meaning
we want to be able to use something that
Google's going to be able to index so
most sites are built in HTML and that's
what Google likes to index they like to
index something that they could take
back to their servers and then more
importantly build a comprehensive
structure for internal linking so
internal links mean that if you're on a
site you should have natural lengths
pointing to other pages on your website
so to keep the flow going we don't want
to have unnatural inbound links you
always want to have natural internal
links to keep the flow of the user going
from one page to the other so here I
could see as an example all the
ingredients in this recipe well this has
an internal link to another page on our
site and this happens to link to a page
where somebody can buy the ingredient so
it's a natural internal link so John
Doherty of Credo has claimed that one of
the biggest changes that he can make in
fixing the Credo website is architecture
so for example in Credo John Doherty has
increased the organic sessions by 74 in
Pages by per session by 41 just by
changing the site architecture so you'd
be surprised by changing the side
architecture what that will do to
engagement and so let's turn our
attention to secure versus non-secure so
what we mean by that is securing your
site we want to make it sure that
compliance with certain protocols and so
if we go back here we can see that this
particular site is compliant it is
secure https means it has a sec cure
license meaning the site is secure so
Google likes secure versus non-secure so
non-secure would be HTTP so we want
https as our protocol and what that
means is just enabling SSL certificates
and that means when you enable an SSL
certificate that means your domain or
your protocol is going to be turned to
https so Google prefers sites that are
secure versus non-secure so if you use
hsts as a protocol that adds an extra
layer of security over the https and
hsts prevents cookie hijacking so adding
multiple layers of security always helps
in my opinion if you have an HTTP
website a non-secure website you should
look into buying an SSL certificate
getting your sites flipped over to https
because what's going to happen is you're
your rail structure is going to change
when your url structure changes Google's
going to recognize that because it's
going to index your site and when they
index your site they're going to see
those secure URLs and that's going to
work favorably in your favor and help
you rank higher on Google search so
websites using secure or https have a
higher chance of ranking higher so https
is a ranking signal because Google
indexes those pages so let's also talk
about site Maps so sitemap is one of the
most important ways to improve your
website ranking why well because
sitemaps are a way to organize all your
URLs into one file so we're basically
going to prioritize all our web pages in
a site map so if you go to any
particular website and you type in
sitemap XML you're likely going to see
all the pages on your website so usually
the site map is located in the root
Direct directory so if I type in
sitemap.xml I'm going to be able to see
all the pages in my root directory and I
can also prioritize them I can also
alert Google as to how often they change
and every page is going to have a date
stamp associated with it so Google can
actually see how often it changes so
remember we want our content to be
updated frequently so content's not
updated frequently or it's not fresh
then Google's gonna see that size that
date stamp that last modification down
so we want to be able to make sure
content's updated frequently we want to
let Google know that we change it
frequently and we want to be able to
prioritize our Pages let Google know hey
these pages are important to us so all
that can be set up in a site map we want
to be able to add canonical versions of
URLs in the sitemap so we want to be
able to add all our original URLs in our
sitemap and so we always want to build
Dynamic URLs site maps for larger
websites and what I mean by Dynamic URLs
that means that if I look at this side
map and we're always adding content
let's just say in the form of a Blog
well guess what we want those pages to
be added to the sitemap as they're
published so as we add pages to the blog
or to the site then they should
automatically be added to the sitemap
and so in effect what's going to happen
is we're going to be able to see the
site map grow with more URLs when the
sitemap grows with more URLs then that
means then Google's going to index more
pages they're going to index more fresh
pages so they're going to be able to get
those pages that are just published
quicker so that's the whole idea behind
Dynamic sitemaps is we want to be able
to capture all the URLs just as they're
published and we want to be able to
maintain our sitemaps and so I would
always recommend a dynamic sitemap but
you can always create your own sitemap
just by going to a tool called XML
sitemap so if I just type in XML
sitemaps into Google search here I can
see XML sitemaps generator and I can be
able if I have a small website just
create a free and simple site map on my
own when XML sitemaps creates it or your
platform creates a dynamic sitemap
either way the sitemaps going to sit in
the root directory and then what we want
to do in turn is let Google know where
that sitemap is so in search console we
want to be able to submit the sitemap so
you're going to add the sitemap you're
going to let Google know where it is it
should be in the root directory and it
should be called sitemap.xml and when
you do that Google's going to be able to
take those URLs and index them so we can
see we submitted 528 URLs Google index
521 so one thing about URLs here is when
we create a site map we're putting all
your URLs in there we do not add no
index URLs in your site map when what
that means is that any URL we don't want
Google to index we're just going to
exclude from the sitemap okay so we want
Google to take all the URLs we want
indexed and put them in the sitemap so
according to edgy using sitemaps for SEO
can increase your website's visibility
and help you get indexed why because
what you're in effect doing is taking
all your URLs that you want indexed
you're telling Google how often they're
modified you're telling Google which
ones are important and you're submitting
that to Google and so Google's going to
be able to take all the URLs quicker
index them quicker and when they're
index quicker you can get rent quicker
and when you get ranked quicker you can
get traffic quicker so that's the whole
idea behind sitemaps so let's turn our
attention to page speed now so when the
last factors for our website besides
architecture making it secure and adding
site Maps is you want to take a look at
how quick our Pages load here are some
tips and in order to optimize page speed
because ideally the quicker a page loads
the more engaged the user is going to be
if it takes a longer time for the page
to load all the elements of that page
then what's going to happen is the user
is going to get impatient maybe leave
the website all together or go to
another page and so we want to be able
to optimize images so any image that's
of large size in terms of megabytes we
want to be able to optimize that
compress the image so that's one way to
speed up page speed we want to use a
simple website design you know HTML with
CSS or cascading style sheets just a
simple design with simple a hierarchy
and website navigation structure so
nothing fancy nothing complex just a
simple website design with optimized
images we want to leverage browser
caching and we want to upgrade the
server response time meaning all your
files are sitting on the server so when
somebody goes to web page the server is
serving up all of those files the images
the text Etc and so we want the server
to respond as quick as possible so when
it comes to page speed we can look at
the factors affecting page speed and
Google analytics so if I go to Google
analytics and I go under behavior and I
go under site speed and I go to overview
I'm going to be able to see what my
average load time is for my site and
ideally we want our pages to load as
quick as possible so that means anything
under four seconds anything four seconds
or higher and it's likely the end user
is going to leave the page there's a
correlation BP between page load time
and bounce rate and so what Google
actually does is give you speed
suggestions so if we do have a page that
loads slow we can just go to speed
suggestions in Google analytics and we
go to speed suggestions then Google's
going to be able to tell us hey okay
this particular page load fast this
potato page loads slow and if it loaded
slow why is it loading slow so here we
could see the home page of the example
is loading on average of seven seconds
well if we look here they're going to
give us some suggestions so if I click
on this page speed suggestions it's
going to load a report and a tool called
page speed insights and basically what
it's then going to do after it's done
running is it's going to tell me all the
ways in which I can optimize my pages
not only for desktop but also for mobile
so here I can see for desktop or for
mobile I can look at some ways in which
I can optimize it to increase page speed
for example sizing my images properly
server response time reducing my server
response time avoiding multiple page
redirects so there's a lot of
opportunities that we can do to speed up
page load time and all that's found in
page speed insights and all that's found
within Google analytics so remember
optimizing code minimizing redirects
optimizing your images upgrading your
server response and all of those are
factors and so again you can go into
analytics page speed insights and you
can see exactly what Google is
recognizing as what's lowering or
slowing down your page load time so
Google takes site speed as one of the
most important ranking factors why
because they're going to rank Pages not
only with high quality content that are
relevant to the keyword queries but they
want those pages to have a good user
experience so if somebody clicks on the
page then the user should be able to see
that content fairly quickly and so
that's why it's such an important factor
so the quicker your pages load the
chances of you ranking higher are going
to be better so according to web
performance today Walmart as an example
experience decline in conversions so
what they did was looked at their page
speed and when they looked at their paid
speed you'd be surprised what that did
just increasing it from one to four
seconds or decreasing it basically
increased conversion so there's always
going to be a correlation between how
quick a page loads and how engaged the
user is because if it's users engaged
they're going to stay on the site if
they stay on the site then their chances
of converting are going to be higher so
just even one to two seconds increase
and Page low is low time will make a
world of difference in terms of
Engagement and conversions let's turn
our attention to off-site engagement so
previously we talked about on-page
elements and website factors that are
fact our rankings for search results but
we also need to turn our attention away
from our website meaning what we do on
our website and turn our attention what
we can do for our website off our
website and onto other websites so
that's offside engagement and so let's
look an example so that ice cream
recipes blog I'm going to talk about how
to rank YouTube videos today so it's
simply learn we take our videos on
YouTube very seriously meaning that when
we create videos we want people to see
them because we know we make good videos
and we know we have good content and we
know that our audience is going to enjoy
it and so we want our audience to see
the videos that we're creating and so
we're going to give you some tips and
tricks and methodology and ideas on how
to get your videos to rank on YouTube so
at simply learn if I go to YouTube and I
just type in machine learning you could
see we're right here is the first
organic video on YouTube for machine
learning if I jump over to Google and I
type in machine learning Basics you can
see where number or number one for
machine learning Basics under videos if
I click on all we're also ranked here as
well well under the video section on
organic search results another example
data science for beginners we ranked
number one for that if I look at another
keyword data science interview questions
okay we're ranked number two for that so
we're ranking for a lot of videos and
why are we ranking for a lot of
different content and videos on Google
Search and on YouTube well we put a lot
of work in behind the scenes of creating
the video and that's what we want to
show you so part of that has a lot to do
with you know how our audience engages
and sees our video so for example we're
looking at a machine learning Basics
video here and we can see that it has
over 221 000 subscribers for this video
234 000 views we've had over 2 000
people like the video and we have had
over 270 plus comment on the video so
when we get our videos to rank then we
can see there's a lot of Engagement and
so that's the whole idea is when you do
do a video and you wanted to show up on
YouTube you want people to enjoy you
want people to share it you want people
to like it you want people to comment on
that and that's part of the whole
ecosystem of YouTube It's you know we're
going to show you behind the scenes of
what it takes to get your videos to rank
and then we're going to show you some of
the metrics involved with some of these
videos to help you stay ranking so
without further Ado let's go into how to
get your videos to rank on YouTube so
we're going to talk about keyword
research for YouTube we're going to talk
about some ways to create high quality
videos so the importance of user
engagement just as I showed you with the
machine learning Basics video all the
shares all the commenting all the views
and subscriptions then we're going to
get into how to promote your content and
then we're going to just review a little
checklist for you and sum it all up so
let's get started with keyword research
so basically what we want to do is
Center our keywords just like our
website we want to Center our keywords
around sound or our content around good
keywords so the videos on YouTube are no
different than the web pages on our
website so if we have somebody who
states YouTube is the world's second
most well well-known engine well it is
because it's right behind Google it's
not a search engine per se it's a video
platform but if it was a search engine
it'd probably be second right behind
Google so YouTube is pretty popular
majority people use YouTube search every
day to watch videos on a number of
different topics so they can find these
videos in Google but because YouTube's
so powerful and so popular people go
directly right into YouTube for their
searches and so the whole idea behind
YouTube being the second most well-known
search engine is centered around
keywords so if you have the right
keywords for your video then the chances
of you ranking higher increases on
YouTube so we're gonna share with you a
few easy ways to do keyword research
this is the most important step in
getting your videos to rank on YouTube
just like for those of you who watched
any of the SEO videos we produced at
simply learn you know that keyword
research is so essential to getting your
web pages to rank on Google well it's no
different keyword research and choosing
the right keywords is just as important
for your videos as is for your web pages
so we're going to go into a few things
to do here to find the right keywords so
we have the search suggestion you can
look at your competitors we have
different tools we can use some other
factors involved in Google itself so
let's start talking about some of these
ways to really hone in and do some good
research on your keywords to align them
with your videos first thing is search
suggest so YouTube has a feature called
autocomplete so if you've done any
searches on Google it's very similar if
you're typing something in to YouTube
search then and YouTube is going to
suggest other related popular keywords
so let's take a look at that if we go
back to YouTube for a second and I just
type in machine learning YouTube is
going to populate on the autocomplete in
the search bar some other popular
keywords that we can potentially use or
in this case if I Choose You Know
machine learning tutorial I'm going to
see a video about machine learning
tutorial so here you can see Simply
Orange rank number one for machine
learning tutorial but there are other
videos that show up in my search result
so we want to be able to use the search
suggestion box in the search box field
so when we're typing in something new
YouTube just like on Google is going to
give us those suggestions so if we're
focusing a video on machine learning
then you know we have some ideas of some
other keywords that we could center
around because these are our popular
keywords these are key words that people
are using to search on YouTube so that's
one suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keywords used by our competitors in
their video and title and description so
let me talk a little bit about that what
you want to do is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitors YouTube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title and description and then once you
do that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to YouTube so if I go to type in simply
learn here's our Channel page just by
clicking on simply learn I click on
videos ever wonder if there's so now I
can see all the videos ever wonder if
there's an easy easier way go back so
here I can see all the videos sort by
most popular once they do that then I
can choose a video this is the most
popular video right now for simply learn
if I click on that video it's
automatically going to start playing but
what I could do is simply just look at
you know the content description so just
by clicking show more I can see all the
content that align with this video
that's one way to do it is simply by
looking at your competitors now what you
could also do is look at the tags
associated with the particular video and
so what you want to do is you want to
look at the HTML and so that means
looking at the page source so just like
web pages what YouTube does is they look
at meta tags so if you call from SEO in
order to get your pages to rank you need
to have a title tag and a meta tag
description so videos are no different
what we're doing uh for YouTube is
aligning certain keywords with the video
so if you take a look and do a search
for keywords by viewing the page Source
you're going to see all the keywords
associated with a particular video so
for example if I go back to YouTube and
I look at the page source of a video
Let's just say this video here
Facebook's ad tutorial I'm going to pull
up the page source and all I need to do
is control F and type in keywords and
now for that Facebook video I can see
all the keywords associated with the
video so you can see there's a lot of
different keywords we're aligning with
this video and so why do we want to do
that because we want you know our video
to show up for keywords that people may
type in and so if you use that YouTube
autocomplete it's going to give you
those ideas this most popular keywords
so if they're related align those
keywords with the video so here you can
see Facebook marketing Facebook ad
strategy Facebook ads for beginners so
forth and so on so there's a lot of
keywords we've aligned here with that
particular video and again all you need
to do is look at the page source so
right clicking view page Source do a
control F for keywords and you'll be
able to see the keywords aligned so you
could do that for your competitors
videos as well so you can see what
keywords your competitors using for a
video that's most popular for their
Channel and is also ranking on YouTube
and on Google so using the autocomplete
gives you those keyword ideas looking at
your competitors videos also gives you
some other ideas for keywords that you
can align with a video that's relevant
that you want to rank for so let's look
at some other ideas here so you can
install plugins and there are plenty of
plugins available on the Chrome browser
that will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples are vid IQ and
tubebuddy those are extensions that work
in Chrome and what they do is they give
you the exact tags that a particular
video is using so for example if I go
back here and I look at a video on
YouTube let's just say the machine
learning Basics video I have vid IQ
installed on my Chrome browser so just
by clicking on that vid IQ is going to
give me a lot of information about that
video you're just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information associated with Facebook
some engagement metrics really what I'm
interested in is those keywords so if I
scroll down a bit here I can see the
video tags associated with the machine
learning Basics video so vid IQ is
telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated I can also see where they
rank so for machine learning Basics this
particular video ranks number one if I
go down I can see what is machine
learning and how does it work I can see
it's ranked number two here I could see
machine learning algorithms it's ranked
number nine so I can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tags for that video further down
I can also see some Channel tags but
really this is the video tags or the
idea place I want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you to really get
an understanding of what keywords to use
at the particular video so autocomplete
you can look at the page source of a
competitors video or you can use a
Chrome extension in this case I'm using
vid IQ to give me some information about
the video tags for a particular video so
according to an industry study using
keywords and video tags will help you
rank well on YouTube so you have to use
keywords and video tags if you want your
video to rank there's been a lot of
studies YouTube is so popular and videos
are so prominent in today's world where
if you have videos and you're going to
upload them to YouTube then associate
the right keywords with those videos so
some important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on YouTube or Google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third-party
extension in Chrome in my example I use
vid IQ that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance it out
with keywords that have load difficulty
and are easier to rank for so you don't
want to choose something very broad
that's just going to be very difficult
to rank for and of course we always want
to go with relevancy so for talking
about machine learning Basics then we
want to choose keywords associated with
that and that's where that autocomplete
comes in handy because what Google's
going to do and YouTube's going to do is
give us keywords that are very closely
related to the video that we're trying
to optimize for and so we have a number
of different keywords at our disposal
that are relevant that we can look to
see if they have good volume and low
competition and so the whole idea is we
want to choose a keyword that defines
the nature of the content and then what
we want to do is support that with
secondary keywords so we want keywords
that are highly relevant to the primary
keyword so that's the way to go about
aligning your keywords you want keywords
that are high volume low competition or
relevant and you want to choose that one
keyword that is really what the
content's about and then the secondary
keywords that support the primary so if
you have a machine learning video you
could choose your primary keyword as in
this case the machine learning Basics
video so well chosen keywords help you
rank well on YouTube just like the
machine learning Basics so if I go back
to our video our machine learning Basics
video if I just type in machine learning
Basics I'll be able to pull it up and so
here it is if I click on it I'm going to
go to YouTube and so here I can see this
keyword we know humans learn from is
well aligned because it's in the title
it's in the copy and it's a line is a
keyword tagged with the video so we know
that that keyword has good volume low
competition is relevant because that's
what the video is about the basics of of
machine learning it's an introduction to
machine learning so instead of honing in
on just introduction and machine
learning primary keyword is machine
learning Basics and then we supported
that video with those secondary keywords
what is machine learning because
somebody who doesn't know machine
learning is probably going to type in
that keyword and then introduction to
machine learning is a good secondary
keyword because it's explaining the
basics of what machine learning is all
about so primary keyword machine
learning basic secondary keywords what
is machine learning and introduction to
machine learning so that's the whole
idea behind choosing keywords you want
that keyword that really is going to
define the content and then support that
with those secondary keywords so
remember when you're performing your
keyword research choose keywords for
your videos that Google shows on the
video results page so what I mean by
that is your video can get more views if
you rank on Google as well so the whole
idea is not necessarily to be found
found on YouTube it's also to be found
on Google so if I go back to Google and
I just type in data science for
beginners and I type in videos then you
can see we're ranked number one so even
if you're not looking at the videos
clicking on the videos link on Google
search you can always just when you do a
search what Google's going to do is also
put in the videos here on par as part of
the search results so what they're going
to show you is the top videos that are
ranking for that particular keyword and
so we may not rank overall for data
science for beginners but we're ranked
number one in the videos category and so
somebody's looking for a video that's
important and you can see here that
these first two are ads so what Google
is doing is they're saying hey this is
so relevant this particular video for
the keyword query data science for
beginners that we're going to show it
above the organic listings even though
it's a video so the whole idea is to be
found on YouTube and Google because
you're already seen your visibility
you're increasing your chances of
getting found on both search platforms
so according to backlinko google Ranks
videos with keywords like how to
tutorials so you know a lot of the
videos that you find on YouTube are
going to be instructional based and so
what Google's doing is they're saying
hey if somebody types in how to or
tutorial or an introduction to anything
that's going to signal to Google that
it's instructional it's going to help
you rank so when you search for machine
learning tutorial or how to become a
machine learning engineer you're going
to get results related to that because
if you look at these examples we have
machine learning tutorial in our title
or how to become a machine learning
engineer so keep that in mind if you're
creating a video and it's educational in
nature you know use those key terms like
how to and tutorials in the video title
because that will help you your ring so
let's move over now to video title so we
want to use our Target keyword in the
title of the video and again we want to
make sure if it's educational to include
that keyword tutorial or how to so for
every video title YouTube has a limit of
100 characters so we really have to pick
and choose really wisely so if we look
at the video that we were focusing on a
couple of minutes ago so machine
learning Basics here we could see under
100 characters we have machine learning
Basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so it takes
into account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really the key term
that really Google and YouTube like and
that's what is machine learning so it's
helping us Rank by having our keywords
in the title with that key phrase what
is okay so that's a good tidbit on
creating a good video title is to align
it with the right keywords your primary
and your secondary and so we want to use
those catchy words and numbers to gain
High click-through rates just like you
would on the title tag of your web page
we want to do the same with our video
title because the video titles what's
going to show up in search so if I go
back to you know search here we could
see you know data science tutorial data
science for beginners so we want to make
sure in this case you can see data
science in five minutes so that was
purposely done so that hey I don't have
time to watch a video I only have a
couple minutes data science in five
minutes okay great I'm going to click on
the video and now I have an opportunity
to watch something and learn something
under five minutes so choosing the right
words in your video title is going to
help you get that click-through rate up
remember click the array is clicks
divided by Impressions and an impression
is is how many times your video shows up
and the search results on YouTube or
Google so we want to keep our
click-through rate high and in order to
do that we want to be able to write some
really good title tags for our video so
use catchy words like a number or how to
or what is because that's going to
resonate with people when they're
searching now for the description what
we want to do is we want to use the
target word at the beginning of the
description the title and the tags
itself so if I go back to my video here
machine learning Basics we know it's in
the video title and right off the bat if
I look at the description of the video
here I can see this machine learning
Basics video will help you understand
what is machine learning so our primary
keyword is in the first sentence right
in the introductory of the description
and so that's going to bode well for
optimizing our video the description
length is 5 000 characters so we have a
lot of characters to work with so if I
go back to my video I click show more we
have a lot of characters to really
describe what the video is about okay
there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5 000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keywords but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that keyword that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with keywords at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your keywords naturally and then
include hashtags in your description to
help the audience find your video is
easily so if I go back here you know we
want to be able to include hashtags so
hashtags it's like anything else you
would use on social media it just
signals to the end user hey this is what
the video is all about and if I go ahead
and type in that keyword then it's our
our video has a better chance because
it's a line with that hashtag and then
there's Target keywords and LSI keywords
latent semantic indexing keywords we
want to be able to use those keywords as
Target keywords with our video so if you
recall the example I gave a few minutes
ago we used the Facebook ads tutorial as
our example here I could see all the
target keywords associated with that
particular video so don't be afraid to
use those LSI related keywords meaning
keywords that are related to the content
use them as Target keywords with the
video so between your LSI keywords
Target keywords and then using our
primary and secondary keyword in the
title tag using our primary and
secondary keyword in the description and
then using hashtags in the description
the combination of all of that if we
chose the right keyword then we should
find that our video will eventually a
rank on YouTube so just doing these
small tidbits with our keywords really
help get our video to rank so at the end
of the day we want to be able to use the
tools available to Us YouTube Itself by
looking at our competitors those
extensions like vid IQ the autocomplete
to really find our good keywords and
then incorporating those keywords into
you know the title tag the description
as Target keywords hashtags we should
really be off and running with our video
on YouTube that's our turn our attention
to creating high quality videos and some
of the best practices around that so
along with everything we mentioned about
choosing the right keywords we always
need to keep in mind that the videos we
create need to be of high quality so the
content itself in addition to the
keywords is a primary factor in ranking
so in order to have keywords we need to
have content and in order to rank we
need to have have you know good content
so let's talk a little bit about
creating content and what's involved
with that and what we really mean by
high quality videos so if you have a
video content that is not informative or
irrelevant to the topic it won't rank so
that's just common sense so you need to
create content that's aligned with the
topic obviously and then that way you
have keywords that are aligned with the
content so but if you have content it
really isn't aligned with the topic then
you're not gonna rank no matter how much
you've optimized that video so just keep
that in mind so there's a couple of
things we want to look at here so high
quality content is determined by really
two metrics so we're not sure about how
good our content is and how good of high
quality video we created we want to look
at audience retention and user
engagement so audience retention and
simply the percentage length of your
video that the audience has watched it
it's the percentage your audience has
watched so focusing on audience
retention is important for people who
want their videos to rank high so if you
want to rank you need to optimize for
the keywords but got to keep in mind
content so content is related to
audience retention and user engagement
so audience retention percentage length
your video of your video that the
audience has watched and for example it
can be both absolute in minutes or
percentages so audience retention can be
the average view duration or percentage
of the audience that watched then we
have user engagement so yours engagement
viewers who are engaged with your
content and so that means they're either
sharing it subscribing commenting or
liking so those are all forms of
Engagement so the percentage of users
who watched or how long they watched
versus engagement or in combination with
engagement are two factors for ranking
so let's talk about about some tips for
creating high quality videos so we want
to publish longer videos and so what do
we mean behind longer videos so what's
the reason for longer videos let's just
suppose we have two videos one shorter
in length and one longer in length first
video is 15 minutes long the second
video is seven minutes long so on
average if viewers watch about 40 of
both videos then video x which is 15
minutes long will have more than twice
the watch time of the video that's seven
minutes long so remember duration we
want you know people to watch our videos
longer so if the video is longer in
length if it's 40 then it's gonna have a
longer audience engagement audience
retention so that's one of the reasons
you know from a metric standpoint so
even when viewers watch you know both
videos the time is going to differ so we
want to take into account longer videos
for primarily that region is because you
know it gives an end user an opportunity
to watch the video longer and then it's
going to help us rank our videos longer
so when we talk about watch time so if
one video has higher watch time than the
other watch time is just the number of
views times the average view duration so
another tip is we want to plan our video
script so we want to keep the content
organized my recognition is you know
create an outline first and once you
create an outline of how the video is
going to flow then start populating with
content and so to me that's how you can
keep the flow organized okay is really
with an outline starting out with an
impound there's no videos are no
different than say a presentation if
you've done a PowerPoint presentation
you always want to start out doing an
outline then we want to upload a high
resolution videos high resolution we
don't want to create videos that you
know a small resolution like say you
know 400 100 by 400 resolution or
something you know something really
small we want to create something a very
high res so according to back or link
Oaks more than 50 percent of videos on
the first page of YouTube are high
definition so high definition videos of
higher quality are going to be shown on
the first page of YouTube more often
than not so high resolution videos
organizing the content publishing longer
videos or examples of creating high
quality videos we also want to make sure
that content is relevant to the title so
if we're talking about machine learning
Basics you know obviously the content is
going to be about you know intro to
machine learning or what is machine
learning and then the title should
reflect that content so aligning the
title sets the expectation for the end
user so when they see a title what is
machine learning then when they watch
the video they're expecting to learn
about machine learning and what it is so
if it meets expectations then the
chances are that person who's watching
the video is going to watch it longer
and that means it's going to fulfill the
viewers requirements and when you align
everything accordingly keywords titles
content then at the end of the day the
user is going to watch it and the more
they watch it the higher the engagement
the higher the engagement the better
chance you have to rank some other tips
that you could use to create high
quality videos so we want to be able to
you know use examples to clarify our
content so you don't be afraid to go
into another screen like I am if I want
to I'm talking about videos jump into
the machine learning Basics video which
I've done throughout this session I can
simply do that by keeping the user
engaged here this video is about machine
learning Basics well the titles align
with the video we made sure that we have
a nice description about what the video
is about and we're aligning the
expectation so not only that I'm showing
you example within the video itself so
we want to use examples throughout your
video to keep the user engaged it will
also help clarify what you're trying to
express in the video itself so we want
to make it visually appealing so
visually appealing means imagery or
examples in the video and then when we
talk about imagery you know you want to
use good images in your video so use
public domain sites that are available
to you like Shutterstock or flat icon I
mean there are plenty of those sites out
there so feel free to use any one of
those sites to use high quality images
in your video give more information to
your audience okay giving maximum
relevant information can help gain more
reviews and so when we talk about more
information again it goes back to you
know the examples you use there's no
shipping no shortages of examples here
description use all 5 000 characters at
your disposal imagery we want to build
build up as much information as you can
in the video itself to keep the end user
the viewer engaged we also want to
create original content so always create
original content you could certainly get
ideas from YouTube if you want to create
a video about machine learning see what
else has already been done do searches
on YouTube itself but you know when
you're going to create a video yeah you
can create another video about what is
machine learning but just make sure it
has your own take on it you're the
subject matter expert when creating the
video create it with your own original
content have high audio quality and
video effects so just like you see here
on this video we have effects in it and
the audio is of high quality meaning no
background noise no Distortion and we
want to be able to speak clearly in the
video so you want to speak clearly
loudly concise just as I'm trying to do
now so that you can understand what I'm
trying to say or what the viewer is
trying to to understand when they're
watching the video so watching and
listening are two of the components and
you want to make sure both of our high
quality avoid distractions we don't want
to pause you don't want to ramble on a
particular Point too long we want to
keep users engaged so you always want to
move from one point to the other
intermix it with examples those are ways
to keep the users engaged we want to
include transcripts or subtitles for
your video so transcripts is just more
content that's aligned with the video
and the search engines will be able to
pick up that content and help your video
rank so to me that's a key component to
creating a good video is having the
necessary content that go along with the
video that outline I referenced earlier
in terms of organization you always want
to have a Content outline so what topics
are you going to cover in the video
that's why you need the outline to point
that out confirm that before you
actually start creating the video okay
focus on the initial 15 seconds so
that's key you know somebody's going to
click play button of your video and if
you don't catch them in the first 15
seconds then they're likely going to
pause the video or just go ahead and
close it out altogether so you want to
be able to capture somebody's attention
right off the bat and even before they
click on that play button you want to
make sure again you're exceeding
expectations that title is aligned with
the content so in your first 15 seconds
it basically needs to be catchy but also
setting the expectation of what the user
is expecting so in this example here we
want to pay close attention to the first
15 seconds that's when viewers are most
likely to drop off so we can look at
audience retention and YouTube so use
the options above the graph to view
absolute audience retention or relative
audience retention so audience retention
is basically how many views a video
received and the percentage of the total
number of video views and that includes
every moment of the video as a
percentage so we'll show you an example
of what that looks like so here if we go
to the machine learning Basics video we
can look at the audience retention
report and this is since it's been
uploaded the lifetime audience retention
so here we can see a nice graph the
percentage of people who viewed it and
how long they viewed it so in percentage
so here for example I can see you know
43 44 watch the video for at least two
minutes here I can see
28.6 percent wash it for six minutes
plus so that's the audience retention it
gives us an idea in terms of percentage
how many people or percentage of people
watch the video at what length so that's
audience retention so we want to keep
that number high at the very initial
stage of the video and we want to keep
it high throughout and that's why you
always want to create high quality
content using those examples using
imagery making it organized content not
pausing you know going from one point to
the other those are all best practices
that to keep the viewer engaged and then
we want to add resources from well-known
sites so throughout this video we've
used backlinko there are other sources
we've used so if you have a source go
ahead and put it in your video to add
credibility and then we want to use
cards to your videos so this cards is
basically a feature that recommends
relevant videos to your audience so in
addition to machine learning Basics
there could be other videos about
machine learning that we can recommend
or you too can recommend to the audience
to set up end screens you want to make
sure that with end screens you can use
relevant videos to your audience towards
the end of your video so you can
recommend relevant videos towards the
end of your video you can also create
playlists so this is a feature that
keeps your audience engaged with
relevant content by Auto playing the
next video so if you enable this feature
it's going to go from one video to
another pattern interrupts keep the
audience engaged so basically it allows
for your audience to stay within one
video without having any interruptions
involved and so going back to the did
you know awnings retention report helps
you analyze how well your videos are
engaging to the audience so what do we
mean by that well if I go back again to
my audience retention report how
engaging was it well I could see 42
percent 43 percent watched it on average
of 3 minutes and 21 seconds so to me
that's pretty good of course we always
want a hundred percent of the video the
video is seven minutes long if almost
half of our audience saw over half of
the video then I would say that's pretty
good people were engaged so audience
retention just is a good report to start
looking at to help you understand how
engaging is my video if your video is
not engaging you know you can always go
back and edit it or fix it or tweak it
so remember the average view duration
for all videos and top performing videos
list tested by all time we can look at
that information as well in addition we
can look at demographics so we can get
an overview of the age gender and
location and we can look at playback
locations report and what the playback
locations report does is it helps us
determine the platforms where our videos
are being streamed from within YouTube
look at the traffic sources where did
the viewers come from devices did they
look on mobile or tablet and so there's
any doubts you know if you have any
questions please drop a comment below
but especially if you have any doubts on
the metrics so if we go back into
YouTube we can look at analytics and if
we're looking at analytics we can see
more and then this is going to show us
everything we need to see from device
type so if I click on more I can see my
playback location so this will show me
where the video is watched it was on a
watch page or a channel page I could see
the traffic sources I could see the
gender and age so if I click on the
viewer age report I can see the
percentage of views by age so I can get
a lot of information
about my video and how it's performed
who's watched it what they've done with
it where they come from all the
information they need to know and so
it's all within YouTube analytics so
again if you have any questions about
that you know just drop a comment below
especially if you're new to YouTube you
may have some questions but just know
that every video you publish to YouTube
high quality align with your keywords
you're going to be able to view the
metrics by looking at YouTube analytics
so let's talk about the importance of
user engagement so engagement is as we
mentioned important because basically we
can't rank without engagement our videos
won't rank unless we have engagement so
that's why it's important so engagement
is somebody liking the video commenting
sharing it or subscribing each one of
these is important to ranking so yes you
need to line keywords yes you need to
have high quality content so when you do
both of those and you upload your video
then it's up to the viewer and so the
hard work that you put out for the video
is hopefully going to pay dividends with
engagement so you want people to do one
of these four okay so let's talk about
what that means so how do I get
engagement so we already talked about
creating engaging content so there are a
lot of tips to creating engaging content
and so according to wordstream if your
content is entertaining then over three
quarters of the users are going to share
it so that's part of keeping uh users
engaged is keeping it entertaining is
part of getting a high quality video so
remember on that high quality video when
we say entertaining the audio portion
has a lot to do with it examples has a
lot to do with it quality of the video
itself has a lot to do with it so a lot
of component so all those components on
a high quality video are going to lead
to engagement so parts of what you could
do in your videos is conduct a quiz so
meaning the quiz itself is a way to keep
people engaged in your video so that
also help you get some more comments so
according to backlinku video comments
help and rank in your video higher so
just as I mentioned the last segment
about YouTube analytics and all the
different reports available on YouTube
hey if you have questions in those just
go ahead and add a comment so that's a
way to entice your users or your viewers
to add comments is if they have
questions because you know with videos
you're not going to be able to cover
every detail or every minute detail
about a particular topic you can only
cover in some cases the topic at a high
level so users are going to have
comments or questions naturally and so
the comment section is a good way to
remind viewers hey if you have a
question or comment go ahead and put in
the comments section because that will
lend to engagement as well so we want to
add sources from high quality websites
that'll help with engagement okay use
humor in your video we want to be able
to basically you know make it human
based we don't want to be robots so we
want to be able to sound like you know
we know what we're talking about at the
same time talk to the viewer not
necessarily at the viewer or looking the
other way and just going through the
motions so adding humor adding
personality never hurts at the end of
the day we are all human adding that
clear call to action at the end of the
video will also lead to engagement so if
we win the video with hey leave your
comments on this video or hey feel free
to share this video with colleagues who
are interested then that's a call to
action that's likely going to lead to
more engagement reply to your comments
as well so if you have comments we we
always want to reply to them likely
those comments are going to be questions
because again as I mentioned even in
this video about how to rank your videos
on YouTube okay there's a lot of
information and a lot of information
sometimes doesn't get covered in its
entirety and so we want to make sure
that if we miss something because we're
only human that we're able to respond in
the form of an answer to a question that
somebody leaves in the comments section
so more comments also lead to higher
rankings because it's engagement so when
you're getting high engagement and your
video starts to rank well you know
you're going to start feeling really
good and what is that going to do okay
that feel good is going to lead to
confidence which in turn is going to
probably lead to more videos and that's
exactly what we do at simply learn I
mean we're in the education business but
we're in it to not only educate but
making sure that our videos are shown to
as many people as possible so that we
can educate as many people as possible
so it's all it's contagious so getting
ranked feels good it and then once you
get ranked then you know you probably
have good engagement okay let's talk
about how to promote your content so
once you've done all the hard work
getting your video done high quality
content optimized with keywords and then
publish to YouTube we want to let
everybody in the world know about it
right so we want to promote it we've
done all the work we want to promote it
now so is it necessary to promote it I
would say yes because once your video is
published you want to reach out you want
to reach out to your audience not
necessarily on YouTube but on different
platforms so if you're active on
Facebook or Twitter that's an
opportunity for you to post or tweet
something about the new video so when we
say different platforms I am talking
about you know social media platforms so
it depends on what you're active on so
if you're active on Facebook yeah go
ahead and post something you're active
on Twitter go ahead and tweet something
it could be you know on LinkedIn group
if you're part of a LinkedIn group about
you know machine learning learning then
go ahead and post something to that
group to promote the video so that's
going to help Drive traffic to the video
and then help with engagement so we want
to engage with our audience on those
social media sites it really depends on
what you're active on so if you have a
large following on Twitter then go ahead
and you know share that YouTube video
link on Twitter with the Tweet that's
going to drive traffic from Twitter to
YouTube Remember You know you're going
to be able to see audience engagement or
retention by getting people to watch the
video so you're going to be able to see
right away by promoting the video and
driving traffic to the video how
engaging it is remember the more people
you have watched the video the more
engaging it becomes the better it's
going to rank so it's an ecosystem and
promoting your content is part of that
ecosystem so it all starts with social
media if you're active on whatever
platform that is go ahead and promote it
so you can also look get you know
content based social media sites or
social media content based platforms
like Reddit or Flickr for example so you
can participate in a forum discussion on
Reddit so in this example here it's
about machine learning so we want to be
able to post something about machine
learning with the link to our video so
we can also go to content-based sites
that are q a uh related like quora for
example Cora is a really good site where
you know if you go there post
information about machine learning or
the basics of machine learning with a
link back to the video it's going to
help because not only is it going to
drive traffic but it's going to signal
to Google hey you get a lot of traffic
coming from quora this is going to bode
well for this video in terms of ranking
so here's an example you know if you
find a question that you can post on
core then you're going to get people to
click on your video and respond
accordingly on quora or you can act as
the person responding to questions is
already there so somebody already asked
a question about what is machine
learning you can respond with your video
as the answer so you can just simply
embed your video URL as part of your
answer that'll help Drive traffic so you
can also create your own blog and embed
your video so in the case of machine
learning here we have an example machine
learning what is it and why it matters
so this goes nicely with the video so
here you can see the person the author
of this blog went ahead and embedded the
relevant video in the blog post so they
play off one another nicely you can also
opt in for influencer marketing meaning
hey you can reach out to somebody in
this example here you know Katie nuggets
posted information about machine
learning so in this case why choose
machine learning as a career well they
get information and then what do they do
they went ahead and embedded the video
about machine learning Basics and so
working with you know influencers in a
particular or category or topic will
help Drive traffic to the video you can
also create a YouTube playlist so
playlists tend to rank high in YouTube
searches so if you find yourself doing a
lot of videos we'll go ahead and you
know go to your channel and simply on
your channel you can go ahead and create
playlists so when you create playlists
basically what you're doing is you're
organizing the content into different
playlists no different than say the
music you have set up on your you know
your iPhone or iPad or or iPod whatever
it is you're using so you're just
creating different videos in a
particular category and it YouTube likes
it it's organized it's going to help you
get your videos found quicker and easier
on YouTube Itself by putting your videos
in a playlist so here you could see we
have entire playlist on machine learning
trending Technologies cloud computing
Big Data digital marketing project
management so a lot of different
playlists very organized if somebody
goes to the channel they're going to be
able to go to the playlist that's
interesting to them and see all the
videos there so it allows not only the
end user to find what they're looking
for but it's good for YouTube because
YouTube likes those playlists so we want
to engage our Audience by posting your
video link on a community page so you
could do that within YouTube and you can
prefer to link your YouTube channel in
your email so you can also do that so
for example if I go back to YouTube and
I'm looking at a YouTube video you know
I can always Click Share so here I'm
gonna get a particular URL that's
associated with the video and I can just
embed that so I can embed the whole
thing in my email I can embed it on a
web page or a blog post so just by
clicking share I can also immediately
share it onto the social media platforms
that we mentioned Facebook LinkedIn
Reddit okay Tumblr so there's a lot of
ways to embed the video not just on a
blog post or influencer blog posts but
in our email and on social media as well
so here's an example of what we can do
with a YouTube discussion so we can also
bookmark the video on a popular
bookmarking site you know like stumbled
upon or read it or you know there's lots
of other ones out there so there's
plenty of sites that you'll be able to
go to and bookmark that content so that
people can find it and you can always
opt for backlinks so that means that hey
if there's a blogger out there that
blogs about machine learning you can
always you know ask that blogger to
create a link back to the video and you
could reciprocate do the same thing so
that helps increase the authority of the
video so a lot of things you could do to
promote your video so let's do a quick
review on everything we talked about in
terms of ranking your video on YouTube
it all starts with the keywords so we
want to identify apply a list of
keywords that are relevant to the video
so we can use tools to choose our
keywords but remember we want to choose
keywords that have high volume and low
competition and so where can we go to
choose those keywords well we can use
the autocomplete on YouTube we can check
out our own competitors videos or you
know we could use vid IQ or tubebuddy or
any of these extensions in Chrome to
help us look at the keywords that are
tagged with a particular video so
remember we want to have a primary
keyword that's aligned with the content
then we want to choose LSI keywords as
our secondary keyword or keywords that
are related to the primary keyword so we
want to create high retention videos
meaning that first 15 seconds of the
most important but throughout the video
we want to use examples we want to keep
it interacting by adding quizzes imagery
good audio good video quality so we want
to focus on the user experience and we
also want to optimize eyes or video
content what does that mean well those
keywords that we chose we want to use
them in the title we want to use them in
the description we want to use them as
hashtags we want to use them and tag
them with the video themselves so we can
add keywords to our meta tag okay we
don't want to overdo it but we want to
add a handful of keywords that are
associated with the video so we want to
be able to write I catchy video titles
and descriptions so remember use some of
those key phrases like a number or a
question like what is machine learning
so we want to use relevant meta tags for
the videos and we want to use popular
YouTube tags so we want to be able to
tag our videos appropriately to watch
the length of your meta tags so there
are links involved remember keywords at
the beginning of the title Target
keywords in the title description and
tags we want to use interesting
thumbnails to increase our click-through
rate ensure that thumbnails are relevant
meaning when I say thumbnails I mean the
actual title tag itself or The Meta
description we want to use high res
videos we want to create you know videos
with good high audio quality don't be
afraid to put in video effects like some
animation don't be afraid to use
examples and then you know obviously
look at the draft of the video before
you publish it so does your video follow
an outline is it organized so these are
all the things to take into account and
there's there's plenty more you can do
you know you remember once you create
and optimize that video you want to
promote it you want to make sure that
you're sharing it on social media you
create a complimentary blog you know
generate backlinks from say other blog
posts so there are lots of things you
can do to promote your video so before
you promote it you want to organize the
content create good quality content
align it with keywords once you publish
it you know keep organizing it by
creating this playlists and then reach
out on social reach out on different
communities related to the topic and all
those things combined will help you to
get your YouTube video ranked we're
going to talk about how to increase
YouTube subscribers so with YouTube It's
All About subscribers the number of
subscribers you have on YouTube it's
just one of the key metrics to measure
success so gaining more subscribers can
help you achieve more view counts on
your YouTube videos so it's all about
how to get subscribers and today we're
going to talk about how to get more
subscribers and before we begin let's
just show you what we did at simply
learn so if we look at the past 365 days
on our YouTube channel you can see we
started here back in uh if we look back
at March 9 2018 we had 208 and you can
see just over the course of the year it
kept creeping up creeping up creeping up
and creeping up we've gained you know a
significant number of subscribers over
the last year and what's our secret well
it's posting videos so you can see we've
posted a number of videos over the
course of the year and then our
subscribers have gone basically 165
percent over the last year so you can
see it's part of it is about posting
videos because when you post videos you
have people who can watch those videos
we have people watch those videos you
can have engagement and then when you
have engagement you have shares and
people who like it and then other people
will see it so it's kind of a halo
effect so to speak so getting
subscribers it takes a lot more than
just posting videos and today we're
going to talk about some tips to help
you increase the subscriptions so let's
start out with some of those tips we're
going to start with creating engagement
informative content so engaging in
informative content that's where we're
going to start talking today about how
to increase subscriptions then we're
going to talk about publishing videos
frequently so if it's simply learn you
could see the past 365 days we were
consistent in publishing videos
consistently throughout the month and
the week weeks so another tip we're
going to talk about is how to optimize
your YouTube videos so there's a lot
that goes into optimization but this is
a key key tip to pay attention to
because when it comes to posting
publishing videos on YouTube you need to
align certain things like keywords and
content and metadata so optimize our
videos we're going to talk a lot about
that then we're going to talk about
optimizing the YouTube channel so
there's some tips and tricks here you
want to do to optimize your YouTube
channel producing high quality videos
we're going to talk about that adding a
subscriber Watermark to your videos okay
that's another tip we're going to
mention today engage with our audience
okay that's what we want to do we want
to engage with our audience that's a
really key tip we're saving the best for
last promote your videos and different
platforms so all of these tips we're
going to talk about today so let's get
started and talk about create engage and
informative content so that's the first
place we want to start okay so create
engaging an informative content so if we
want to gain more subscribers on our
Channel we have to create highly
engaging and informative content why
because not our audience is not going to
pay attention and they're not going to
watch the video and then the
engagement's not going to be high and
they're not going to share the video and
they're not going to tell their friends
or like it and so this is where it all
starts you have to be able to plan your
content and not only planning your
content but you got to create it so it's
engaging and informative so how do you
do that well let's talk about that so
the first thing is you have to know your
audience okay so when you create a video
who you're creating the video for I mean
that's where it all starts so when
you're creating your content you're
creating your content for your audience
you're not creating it for the entire
world now we know on YouTube there's a
lot of cute videos about kittens and
jokes and you know people playing games
and you know everybody likes positive
things on YouTube but you know when
we're talking about a specific topic you
know we really have to hone in on a
target audience and so if you know who
your audience is then you can really
hone in on your content okay so that's
the first thing ask yourself who is your
audience and then build your content
around that specific audience don't
build it just for the Mass general
population because it's not going to be
engaging and informative so that's the
first place to start then you want to
engage that audience with relevant
content so if you know your audience and
depending on the topic you want to make
sure that whatever the topic is the
content matches the topic don't there
off course if you Veer off course you're
not going to engage your viewers your
viewers are coming to watch the video
for specific reason the reason is the
topic okay so if they're your target
audience and they want to watch the
video that's a specific topic then the
content has to align so plan your video
script so if you know who your audience
is and you know you want to engage them
with relevant content go ahead and plan
the the script out so what I normally do
is you know have an outline and then
once I have the outline then I go ahead
and create my slides if I will or my
topics points I want to talk about and
then I write out those points I want to
make sure I get all my points in and
that's what you should be doing you want
to plan it ahead of time so that you can
get all your relevant points across
that's what makes a video informative
okay you want to ensure to give maximum
information to your audience so the key
here is maximum information so you don't
want to overload the audience but then
again you want to cut out information so
you want to make sure that when you're
planning your script and you're writing
the outline that you're making sure you
include all your points that you want to
get across once you include those points
then go ahead and you know write your
script and make sure all the information
for all those points are in the script
that's how you're going to ensure you
give maximum information but you don't
want to overdo it so if you feel like
it's too much information it probably is
too much information that back off a
little use the information to create
another video so it's all about knowing
your audience so all of these points
play against one another so be clear and
use more examples in your content just
like we're doing here okay just like at
the beginning of the session I showed
you an example of Simply learn
subscribers over the past 365 days and
so that's what we want to do we want to
be clear but use examples to punctuate
the content or the point we're trying to
get across so we want to include sources
from high quality sites so if you're
going to use examples make sure they're
from relevant high quality sites when I
make high quality meaning does your
audience know who that source is or that
site if it's really specific and your
audience may not know then it's probably
not high quality so just keep that in
mind always play to your audience so you
want to start your video with an
interesting hook so again I get it back
to this example if you're still watching
this then the hook worked we showed you
our subscriptions we showed you how we
grew over the course of a year you could
see our growth and part of it was
posting a lot of videos with relevant
and informative content and so you see
how we did it so you're paying attention
you want to know how to do it and so
part of what we did is exactly what I'm
telling you now we know who our audience
is we plan out our scripts we use good
examples and we start our videos with
interesting hooks now when we do our
videos we also create original content
so that goes back to planning your
script okay you always want to you know
come across as original and informative
when you do that you're going to be
engaging but if you're leveraging
somebody else's content then the
engaging part may not resonate because
it's not your content to begin with so
always always always use original
content okay so keep the content flow
organized so again that goes back to an
outline you know feel free to change up
the outline so the flow makes sense add
visuals to your content and make it
appealing always include images to me if
you can use images in your videos and
play off the video or the images then
it's just gonna flow and make it a
little bit more engaging and appealing
meaning the content so visuals help
guide and Aid in the points you're
trying to make so don't make it so text
Heavy you know accentuate it balance it
with some images use Simple language and
crisp sentences meaning don't choose
jargon don't come across and talk above
your audience you always want to talk to
your audience and talk in a language
that they're going to understand so it
goes back to point one if you know who
your audience is you're talking to them
as if they're right in front of you and
not you're above them or they're below
you you want to talk at them so add
cards and screens and pattern interrupts
to engage your audience and so YouTube
cards are just interactive panels that
slide in and out when a video is playing
so it encourages interaction by the
viewer okay so you can add up to five
cards which include images text or
clickable links so feel free to play
around with some of these features that
YouTube has to offer to make your
content more engaging so tip two publish
videos frequently so creating and
uploading videos consistently will help
you increase your YouTube subscribers so
suppose you haven't published videos
from more than say a month or two months
it's likely that that audience not gonna
subscribe to your channel so think about
YouTube videos as a popular TV program
that comes on once a week when a new
episode comes on based on the regular
schedule it's consistency and that
consistency is what helps your users
stay engaged so for example if I go back
to our YouTube channel you know what
helped us gain subscribers was our
consistency in publishing videos you
could see we were persistent in
publishing a couple of videos a week
every couple of weeks and so this helps
users stay engaged they know when the
video is coming out they know that
simply learn is good for two three four
videos a month and the great thing about
publishing videos is that when somebody
does subscribe to your channel they're
gonna get a notification or YouTube has
an option where they can get a
notification via email so I subscribe to
Simply learns Channel I subscribe to
other channels like Google analytics for
example so anytime Google analytics
publishes a video I get an email that
says Hey Google analytics YouTube
channel just published a video and the
great thing is I'm checking my email and
I'm getting this notification in Gmail
so guess what I can watch the video
right then and there just by clicking on
the link in the email I don't even have
to go to the channel but knowing that if
you publish consistently and somebody
does get the email once a week then it's
more likely they're going to engage
especially if the content is original
engaging and informative so frequent
video publishing equals more
subscription versions so according to
Social Media examiner YouTube channels
that publish videos more than once a
week are performing much better so if
you can afford to publish more videos
more than once a week the chances of you
gaining subscribers quicker are going to
be greater so keeping a fixed frequency
can help you quickly gain more
subscribers posting videos is like
almost like blogging I always say start
small if you could do one blog post a
month and then once you get in a routine
then you can ramp up the frequency so
from one blog post you could do two a
month then four times a month and once a
week or twice a week same with the
YouTube videos you want to get into a
rhythm you know start with once a month
and ramp it up okay you'll find that the
more you ramp it up the more subscribers
you're gonna get so tip three optimize
your YouTube videos so optimizing your
videos will help your content rank
higher on YouTube so this is a give must
it's not a given it's a must you must
optimize your videos if you want people
to see them of course if you don't
optimize people aren't going to see them
then people aren't going to engage and
then not subscribe so it's just kind of
a snowball effect so this is an
important tip so I mentioned it at the
beginning when we were going over all
the items we're going to discuss this is
the one item that is a must and a given
to some degree because if you don't
optimize your videos they're just not
going to be found so you need that
audience to watch your video so
audiences who tend to interact more with
your content have more chance to
subscribe to your channel but they're
not going to subscribe if they don't
even watch your video so there is a
snowball effect in play here if we don't
optimize your videos so okay Rob what
are some of the tips to optimize your
YouTube video well let's go through some
of those tips so to ensure your videos
reaches the relevant audience on YouTube
you need to optimize the title
description in the video tag okay Rob
what do you mean by title description
video tag so let's take a look at that
so when you actually create your YouTube
video you're going to have an
opportunity to put in a title you're
going to have an opportunity to put in
the description and you're going to have
an opportunity to add text so those are
the three key areas okay so once you put
in that what it looks like on the front
end is this so if I go back to YouTube
and here you can see another video that
we did about a month ago you could see
what is SEO so if that's our topic
that's our title uh or of the content of
the video then the title of the video is
going to be what is SEO and you can see
we also added in some other content for
the title so what is SEO and how does it
work SEO tutorial for beginners and then
our brand name so we have some content
to work with for the title okay and then
the description we have a lot of
characters to work with descriptions so
use as much as you can here to describe
what the video is about here you can see
we did that and so it's always good to
include this information okay and then
you can see we have tags up here seo seo
tutorial for beginners digital marketing
so we put in the necessary information
here on this video to help us rank
because if we don't optimize it we're
not going to rank and so you can see we
just put a lot of relevant content
around the description around the title
and around those tags by doing so we're
able to optimize this video and get
found so that's just an example three of
the things you can do to help optimize
your YouTube video so if you want to
watch more on how to optimize meta tags
then I suggest maybe watching the other
video we did on the subject how to rank
YouTube videos so this goes into more
detail about how to optimize the title
The Meta description and The Meta tags
but there's a three quick fields or
areas that you can use to optimize your
video so just something to keep in mind
write a long description with keywords
timestamps and links so what I mean by
time stamps for timestamp an audience
can choose the section of the video that
they want to look for and then links
prefer to include relevant Links of your
other videos so those are just some
additional tips to help keep your
content engaging so remember when your
content is engaging then people are
going to like it people are going to
share it and watch it later so upload a
captivating thumbnail okay so you want
to include a thumbnail that's going to
grab people's attention you want to
upload a transcript of the video so that
goes back to when you're creating your
content when you write your original
content you want to keep a transcript of
the content of the video so that you can
upload that as well and then add a start
screen and end screen to your YouTube
videos so that way you know it's
somebody plays the video they're going
to see it what it looks like up front
and then the way they finish it they're
going to see an end screen at the end
and so you just don't want to keep it
dark and black and non-descriptive so
according to backlinko using an exact
keyword word in your video title can
help you with rankings so high ranking
more views more views more subscribers
so that's what I've been saying all
along you need to get these videos
optimized so again use an exact keyword
in your video title so let's go back
again to that video I just showed you a
couple minutes ago what is SEO so here
we started out with a question what is
SEO that's the name of the title that's
one exact title of the video that's our
exact keyword okay so what is SEO and
how does it work and then SEO tutorial
for beginners so what is SEO is our
exact keyword and that's part of the
video that's the content of the video
that's in the title and we use it
throughout the description as well so
using that exact keyword in your video
title can help with the ranking so
whatever your topic is your title the
video or the topic of the video included
in the title so backlinko also mentions
that there is a moderate correlation
between a Channel's total subscribers
and rankings and so for some of you you
this may be common sense it's just like
organic search if you're not ranking
you're not going to get traffic on
YouTube if you're not ranking you're not
going to get eyeballs on your videos and
you're not going to get subscribers so
higher rankings can help you to get more
subscribers but you can't get those
rankings unless you optimize and so
again just for the sake of Simplicity
going back focus in on your title make
sure your title matches the title of the
video itself when you're publishing your
description use all the amount of
content available to you so you can see
it this entire description has a lot of
content maximize the content and then
use tags using those three Fields those
three areas can help you optimize your
video and gain the necessary ranking you
need to get viewers which will turn into
subscribers so tip four optimize your
YouTube channel so we just talked about
optimizing our videos now we're going to
turn our attention to our YouTube
channel so one of the easiest ways to
ask your viewers to subscribe to your
channel is really by creating a good not
even a good a great YouTube channel
trailer you also want to add Channel
keywords a description and some good
artwork and then having sections and
playlists to keep your videos organized
these are all good tips to creating a
good YouTube channel so let's talk about
some of these these tips here so we want
to give your audience a preview what
your channel is offering so this is by
hooking your audience with the trailer
so you can create a trailer to you know
just give your audience an idea of who
you are as a brand what kind of videos
you're going to be posting and give them
a kind of a taste of what the future
videos are going to be like okay you can
even tell them your release schedule and
the trailer so you can start off by
saying hey hey guys we're new to this
we're going to be posting one video a
month but as we get rolling maybe two
per month and you know one per week you
know just being honest and open and
talking to your audience and get them
excited about future videos that's what
the trailer is all about so you also
want to keep it that the channel
description's short and interesting so
in your channel you want to have a
description of what the channel is all
about what kind of videos you're going
to be posting so in addition to the
trailer you want to write something
short and interesting then we want to
use keywords in our Channel descriptions
just like in the videos with what is SEO
we included what is SEO in the title we
included you know what is SEO in the
description and so we want to be true to
what our channel is so pick keywords not
only include those keywords in the
videos but include them in the channel
description pay attention to the first
100 to 150 characters I have your
channel description because that's
what's shown next your channel on the
search results so for example here you
can see we have a description here
simply learn is one of the world's
leading certification training providers
we partner with companies and
individuals to address and so you can
see those characters 100 to 150 are what
shows up in the channel description when
somebody's trying to understand hey
simply learn just uploaded this video
who is simply learned so you want to
write short interesting Channel
description so that when somebody's
first introduced to your video they
could see what your Brand's all about so
end your description with an appropriate
call to action so short and interesting
good call to action at the end of the
video a good call to action would be hey
check out our next video or check out
our latest video something that's going
to gauge somebody and get them to watch
one of your videos so you want to pick
interesting channel art so let's turn
our attention to the simply learn
Channel page and here you can see we
recently had reached a milestone so
recently reached the 200 000 K
subscribers so 200 000 subscribers is a
big achievement for simply learn we went
ahead and updated our Channel are and
I'm sure we will reach 500k we'll update
the artwork then too but the point is
you want to keep your channel art kind
of interesting hip and cool and feel
free to change it out every once in a
while so you have that option in YouTube
to do I mean it's very simple so here
you can see it simply learns Channel if
we go home we get all our videos listed
here we got the about us you know
something very short and interesting
about us here's our call to action for
more information visit simply learn so
you want to make sure when you create
your channel get some good artwork in
there put your description in play and
create your first videos and get them
posted up there and optimize them
accordingly okay so this is the other
tips to go with that channel art and
description is a profile picture
relevant to your brand so you always
want to maybe put the the company logo
up there okay so here you can see we
have the company logo at Accurate
relevant Channel keywords so if we go
back to who we are who are we we're the
world's leading certification training
provider okay that's who we are okay we
partner with companies and individuals
so we're all about training and training
is one of our keywords so you can see
let's simply learn we provide online
training and machine learning AWS Amazon
web services devops Big Data digital
marketing project management a lot of
different topics so make sure that's
included in the channel description
feature the playlist on your home page
so if we go back to the home page we can
see here we have our channels so you can
see we have ai machine learning trending
Technologies cloud computing tutorials
devops tutorials popular videos big data
we have a lot of different channels so
you want to organize your videos into
different playlists so those playlists
are going to feature on the home page of
your channel so how you organize the
playlist is totally up to you but I
would certainly create a playlist for
different sections so depending on your
product your services think about how
you want to organize don't just stick
all your videos in one playlist then
optimize the playlist titles and
descriptions for search rankings so just
like the videos themselves just like the
channel description you have an
opportunity to optimize the playlist
titles and descriptions so be very keen
on aligning the right keyword with the
playlist title so here you can see
programming language tutorials project
management tutorials digital marketing
tutorials so we're very clear on how we
go about choosing our titles because we
want to optimize those playlist titles
okay we can rearrange our videos in a
playlist so we want to rearrange the
videos in a way that we're maybe putting
the freshest the most newest the video
that's been published last first so
almost in descending order if you will
so we want our users to see what video
has the latest in that particular
playlist so they're saying the most
recent first but you can rearrange your
videos any way you want feel free to
play around with it of course you can
also take the video that's the most
popular and put that up front so people
could see that first vice versa you can
take a video that maybe hasn't gotten a
lot of views or is it ranked
particularly High maybe put that video
up so it can get some views and some
shares and likes so how you rearrange
your videos is totally up to you just
have some rationale behind that so
choose a playlist thumbnail from a top
performing video so for example if I go
back to our YouTube page you can see the
top performing videos here you know for
example this one we got a nice thumbnail
here what is machine learning so if I
click on that
most popular videos so 3 000 likes on
this video a lot of views 250 000 plus
views so have a thumbnail to go along
with that particular video so according
to backlinko YouTube SEO ranking fact
actor's study discovered that channel
keywords have a small yet significant
correlation with Higher YouTube search
rankings so Channel key words so when
you're optimizing your channel and you
want to include keywords start with your
description so if I go back to our
Channel okay if I go back about us make
sure your description has those relevant
keywords in it that's where it all
starts so in case you have any doubts if
you're not sure about everything we
talked about on optimizing the channel
go ahead and drop a comment below
because we do respond to every comment
that gets posted on our videos so if
you're not sure how to go about
optimizing your channel when you say
align keywords with the channel what
does that really mean so if you want
some clarity on that go ahead and drop
it's a channel if you're not sure about
the trailer video drop us a comment
we're more than happy to expand upon the
explanation of how to best optimize your
channel okay tip number five AI produce
high quality videos so we need to get in
the habit of producing high quality
videos because viewers don't prefer to
watch videos that have poor audio and
video quality it's just that simple you
need to know what it takes to produce
high quality videos if you don't you're
just going to discredit you're not going
to come across as relevant you know I'm
going to come across as qualified
professional there's a lot of things
attached to poor quality videos so we
need to create high quality videos for
the end users so let's talk about some
ways in which you can create high
quality videos and so the first is to
avoid any noise in the background so you
want to have a nice quiet atmosphere no
distractions so people can hear you
clearly and only you clearly you want to
use good audio recording equipment
there's plenty of options available on
the internet usually I would recommend
going with something paid not overly
expensive because you get what you pay
for so if you use something free it
might not be of good quality and you
might not have all the features and
bells and whistles with a free option so
you know use good audio recording
equipment again it can be online or it
could be some software just make sure
that you're able to produce good high
quality video and audio so when you do
purchase that audio recording equipment
you want to have something similar to an
input volume meter that way you can see
whether your audio is coming across or
not so if you're not seeing green lights
then your audio is not coming across if
it's red it might be distorted and so
you want something that's going to
signify that you're really pushing out
good quality audio you want to create
your videos in 1080 pixel size okay
that's HD and so you want to have at
least minimum 1080. so anything less
than that it's probably going to come
across as not so good maybe staticky
blurry not professional all not high def
so you want to create a high def video
and 1080 is about the minimum you want
to go and then you want to plan your
video script before filming so it goes
back to some of the other points I made
earlier you always want to have a video
script available so you know what you're
saying when you're recording your audio
that way you're not doing something on
the Fly then you want to use good
lighting for video recording so you
don't want to be in a dark place you
want some nice lighting so your video
comes across well lit people could see
you they're not struggling to strain
their eyes on what it is you're trying
to show and appear because of poor
lighting again it just comes across as
professionals so if you can you know
shoot a high def video with good audio
speaking clearly having a professional
script with some good lighting then
people are going to take you serious and
they're going to start to listen and
engage and see the video as good quality
and very relevant and informative and
share it so use slow motion and jump
Cuts why wisely so there's some features
you could do with your video you know
using slow motion and jump cuts are some
of the features you can use to
accentuate your points and then set up a
green background for recording again
this is for you know making sure that
the video part of it comes across in
good quality and stabilize your video
recordings with a tripod that way you're
not moving your video camera all around
and and again it's coming across as
shaky and poor quality shoot horizontal
videos you don't want to go vertical it
tends to cut the screen so you want to
stay horizontal so that people can see
everything that should be included in
the video okay you want to capture a
wider shot using a clip-on lens again a
good feature a good tip to use use that
wider shot okay so you could do that
using a clip-on lens and then choose
good video editing software I can't
State this enough because you're putting
all this time and effort into a video
you need to be able to edit it to cut
out you know some of the things you
didn't want to say or maybe some poor
quality or or you know you just want to
have a smooth professional output for
your video and so you gotta have good
video editing software there's plenty of
options available on the internet again
I would go with something low cost but
paid usually free isn't exactly the way
you want to go if you're trying to
create a high def good quality video and
at the very least review your work
before publishing I just said it a
minute ago I'll say it again you want to
be able to have a really professional
video and high def when you have a good
professional video in high def with good
audio horizontal shots you know nice
green background image nice well lit
it's going to come across as
professional and if you have a
professional video then people are going
to take you seriously they're going to
see you as a professional and then share
or subscribe and like and then they're
going to watch more videos and and
that's how you start to build up a
reputation Mission as being a very
professional organization so just
following these simple tips on producing
high quality videos so you want to
review your work because if you don't
you put all that effort into it and then
you're going to realize hey your video
is low quality and then you're going to
have to do it all over again so follow
these tips get a high quality video and
you should be on your way to ranking in
fact according to backlinko you two
preferably ranks HD videos so you got to
have that 1080 uh pixel size that way
you know your video is going to come
across crisp and clear and YouTube
prefers that tip six add a subscriber
Watermark to your videos so this is a
great feature in YouTube so it's a
feature that allows you to add a
watermark that can be shown on all your
videos the reason why you want that
Watermark because you want to keep
reminding your audience to subscribe to
your Channel The Watermark can be
whatever you want but normally it's
going to be some type of logo or brand
and a call to action and so so how do
you add a watermark to your video well
you log into your YouTube account it's
it's pretty simple at the top right
corner you're going to select your
creator Studio icon and then you're
going to go to channel select branding
and then add a watermark to your video
so if we look at that in YouTube so here
Creator Studio on the left side
navigation I'm just going to click
Channel then I'm going to click branding
and then once you click brand name you
have the ability to add your watermark
and then you can add it to the entire
video at the end of the video at a
specific start time and then just click
update and that's pretty much it so you
want to be able to add this so that you
can brand your videos with an image and
then add that CTA so this is a good good
feature for YouTube it allows you to be
consistent with all your videos by
branding and adding that call to action
tip 7 engage with your audience so you
want to be able to interact with your
audience as much as possible just
because the video and you can't see
people doesn't mean you can't engage
with them so when you interact with your
viewers especially when you interact
with them immediately there's
gratification you know everybody likes
to be responded to nobody likes to be
ignored and so when somebody is
responded to there's a higher chance
that your viewers are likely to gonna
become customers it's just customer
service is how you really want to look
at this okay so when you engage you're
creating a service for your customers so
here are some tips on how to engage with
your audience so first is at the end of
every video convey a thank you message
to your viewers you know thank you for
spending the time out of every busy day
to watch this video you know some of our
videos go an hour plus long and so when
somebody's taking an hour to watch a
video it's only the least you can do is
thank them now you can thank them and
give them some information about where
to go for more information because if
they watch the whole video they're
already engaged and they're probably
going to want to learn more so you
always want to follow up to thank you
with where to go for more information
just like our videos always convey at
the end okay you always want to ask your
audience for their feedback or ideas on
the video so with YouTube there's a
comment section and you always want to
encourage comments so comments can be in
the form of feedback so as you're
watching this video feel free to leave
feedback on other ways to engage with
your audience or some other tips to
increase your subscribers on YouTube so
we're always looking for those ideas we
want to keep it engaging so somebody may
have some other ideas that we didn't
think about and so we always appreciate
that from our audience so we very much
appreciate the feedback that our
audience gives us so not all the
feedback there's always going to be
positive some of the feedback could be
less than positive or even negative
there could be mistakes so the idea
behind getting feedback is you want to
look at it you want to read it and you
want to react to it you want to react to
it positively in the form of you know
what thank you for the feedback and
looking at the feedback weighing it and
incorporating the feedback so you don't
always want to make the same mistake
twice in a video so if there's something
definitely wrong with the video that
we're doing for example and somebody
looked at it and gave us feedback on it
we'd certainly definitely take a deep
look into that and try not to do the
same mistake twice because likely that
user is going to watch the video again
so you always want to learn from your
mistakes okay and you want to turn those
mistakes or turn those comments into
future videos okay so create videos
based on your commenter's request the
audience is giving us feedback we should
take that as positive and sometimes
that's creative sometimes those ideas
for more videos okay you always want to
ask questions to your audience and
reward excellent commenters so we try to
ask questions in our videos and when
users respond with the answer if there's
an excellent comment or excellent answer
you know we can reward them you know
award them in the form of say some type
of gift card or gift certificate or
promotion or something there's always
some way to incentivize somebody who
provides excellent feedback you can
always give Emoji Hearts there's so many
emojis out there that you can use emojis
just to engage with your audience based
on the feedback that they're giving the
point is if your audience is taking the
time to give feedback you always want to
respond to it and you want to respond to
a pause so emojis tend to have a
positive connotation to them and so
responding with an emoji especially to a
favor comment goes a long way so you can
reward your community both on and off
YouTube for their engagement and support
and that's just being creative you can
reward in many ways many ways not
necessarily monetarily but by
recognition you could do promotions you
could do something fun there's always
ways to reward and prefer to host live
streams and interact with your audience
so you don't always have to do a
pre-recorded video there's certainly
YouTube has
um other platforms like Facebook have
them Instagram so you can certainly
reach out to your audience with a live
stream and that's talking directly to
your audience right there in the flash
so when you can have an opportunity to
talk to your audience and engage with
them that's always going to work because
they can see personality they can see
what you're all about and there's
two-way conversation and so that will
lend to more of a you know relationship
so to speak with your audience so you
want to create videos for subscribers if
subscribers can get impressed when a
channel dedicates a video for them so
you know take the time out to create a
video just for your subscribers
subscribers are the ones who are most
likely going to engage with you okay
they're your loyal fan base so if you
create something for them that's a form
of a reward so you can Captivate your
viewers by uploading interesting YouTube
stories as well you can also hear from
your audience and and get their videos
and use their videos and upload them to
your channel so according to back video
comments of a very strong correlation
with rankings so as you create a video
feel free to talk to your audience and
ask them hey do you have any comments
feel free to put them in the comment
section right below this video I see
that a lot now with a lot of videos and
I'm gonna ask my audience right now to
do the same thing if there's anything
you see about rewarding the audience or
engaging with the audience feel free to
comment we'd love to get your
suggestions because if you can engage
with the audience even more then that's
only going to net positive results not
only in rankings but with your
subscriber base so comments are the way
to go solicit comments respond to the
comments reward the comments tip number
eight promote your videos on different
platforms so promoting your videos on
different platforms has been around for
many years it's a good strategy once you
create your video on YouTube you want
people to see it you want to get it out
there so if you want to increase your
YouTube subscribers this is a strategy
you you have to perform so let's take a
look at all the ways you can use and
leverage different platforms to increase
your subscribers so before you do that
you want to research discover how you
can use different platforms so the first
thing you want to do is look at the
platforms you're already using if you're
using Facebook and Instagram that's
probably a good place to start but
there's other platforms you can also
leverage and we're going to talk about
those so social media most companies
most individuals are on in some form or
fashion amongst the most popular like
Facebook and Instagram so you could
start there so with Facebook you can
post something include the link of your
YouTube video with Facebook if you're a
business you have a business page you're
communicating with your community and
that's a great way to get started by
promoting your YouTube video you can
also do the same on Twitter or Instagram
or whatever platform you're on go ahead
and post something or tweet something
and include that link to YouTube you can
participate in forums and blog
discussions so there's plenty of forums
and blogs out there where you can
participate in discussion and include a
link to the YouTube video if it's
relevant and natural so for example here
there's a Blog about machine learning
you can include if you have a video
about machine learning and the response
to that conversation in this example
we've done that on Reddit you can list
your video in relevant and reputable
directories there's plenty of
directories out there there's plenty of
video directories okay that you can just
go ahead and publish your video on you
can use testimonial link building okay
so somebody can provide a testimony and
include the link of your video you can
opt for influencer marketing so if
there's somebody that is associated that
likes your brand or product and has a
large following you can ask them to post
a video on your behalf it's a great way
to reach an audience fairly quickly okay
you can earn backlinks from relative
relevant and authoritative websites so
for example if you look at this website
here touchgenics okay there's a article
here about you know certificate of
achievements okay for AWS so if you
scroll down we could see our video is
included here in this particular web
page so this is a high quality web page
okay that's generating a backlink for us
not only is it generating a backlink
it's also generating traffic and
awareness for the video go ahead and and
find out if there's any websites that
are relevant to your video topic and see
if you can collaborate with them on
producing a web page to include that
video you can also take advantage of
email marketing by adding your YouTube
link in the email signature for example
it's a simple email any email client
like Gmail or Yahoo or even Hotmail or
Outlook is going to have an ability to
or give you the ability to add a
signature in the signature you could
simply just include a link to the video
or to you YouTube channel it doesn't
have to be to a specific video but it's
a way to get people to your YouTube page
or to that video so the whole idea is
more eyeballs more potential subscribers
engage your Audience by posting your
video links on community pages so for
example you know we're promoting
something here on a community page and
that's going to get some additional
traffic over to us you can always
bookmark your videos on bookmarking
sites like stumbledupon.com again this
is free very little time to do this but
it's a chance for you to get the video
out there and even generate a backlink
you can collaborate with other YouTube
channels this is always a good strategy
if you're creating a video on a
particular topic on YouTube chances are
there's probably somebody else out there
doing the same thing it doesn't have to
be necessarily a competitor it can be a
complimentary product or service and if
you offer that then go ahead and
collaborate with them and see if you can
exchange your videos on their their
Channel and you could take their video
and put it on your channel in a
particular playlist okay so that's a way
to collaborate with other YouTube
channels is swap videos you could join
High PR QA sites and post answers to the
questions related to your video like
core is always a good example or ehab
okay so core there's always a question
of being posted and if you have the
answer to that question in the form of
your video then go ahead and post a
response with a link to the video on
YouTube it's a great way to get the
video noticed and it's relevant and
natural okay you can embed videos in
your blog posts or if you're using a
platform like WordPress for example very
easy to go ahead and just take that
video you can even just put the link in
the blog post I like this option I think
blog posts are always good because you
don't have to be text Heavy with a blog
post you want to create a blog post
that's nice and balanced with an image
and text but if you put a video to
support your blog post that goes even
further and blog posts themselves can be
engaging and interactive with your
audience so having a video in your blog
post always goes well in my opinion okay
so you can promote other videos in your
end screen for example at the end of
your video you can always promote
something related like we've done here
in this example so lots of ideas get
your video out there use them in email
use them in your blog post go to free
bookmarking sites like stumble upon you
know collaborate with other people on
YouTube you know go to core respond to a
question use social media to your
advantage there's lots of opportunities
to get your video out there the more you
can get your video out there the more
traffic you're going to get the more
traffic you get to the video the more
subscribers you're going to get so
that's how the game is played in order
to get your video out there but these
are relatively you know low time
consuming ideas to get your video so
we're going to talk about how to get
traffic to your website so thank you for
joining and let's get started so let's
imagine you're setting up your own
website okay you're clicking away You're
developing using some good tools you're
developing you're designing you're doing
some QA you're testing you're sharing
with Friends and an alpha version and
then finally your website is all set up
congratulations well when you hit enter
and your website is finally published
what's gonna happen well a few days
later you're checking your website and
you're looking at analytics and you
notice your traffic's very low okay well
you're scratching your head because
you've done all this work with your
website but you're not getting any
traffic so the reason is
you spend all your time developing
designing the website to make it look
good but you didn't do anything or any
planning or any strategy around bringing
users to your website so the two go hand
in hand you just can't build a website
without thinking about how to drive
users to the website and so before I
tell you how to bring traffic to your
website let me tell you why this is so
important okay why do we want to bring
users to our website I mean it has to be
on equal ground as web development and
design is somebody who goes to your site
and then does something when they get to
your site so you have users and when
there's user get to your site they're
generating page views and traffic and
you want to turn that traffic into
engagement okay so each Page's traffic
is configured independently of all their
pages so when you go when somebody goes
to your website they look at a page
that's a page view and certain pages on
your website you want to turn that page
view into a conversion okay whether that
be you know looking at a video or
purchasing something so think of these
pages on your website as salespeople
they're trying to convert visitors
should come to your website but first we
need to get the visitors to your website
so when you get visitors to your website
again you can generate sales which means
revenue or you can increase brand
awareness or you can earn Revenue
through sponsored posts and
advertisements so if you have for
example a lot of content on your website
you can turn that in to revenue by
hosting ads on your website so when
somebody clicks on that ad you're going
to earn a percentage of that click okay
what that click is worth so having a
website means a lot of good things for
you but first you're going to get the
traffic there and so what we're going to
do is we're going to tell you how to
drive traffic to your website so there's
lots of different ways in which you can
bring traffic to your website well the
first is paid advertising so paying to
advertise your products services with
ads is one of the easiest ways to drive
traffic to your website so some of the
options available available are search
ads social media ads or display ads so
search ads or ads that are displayed in
the search engine results so when a user
types in a keyword query you want your
ad to show up based on that keyword
query okay so an example is digital
marketing course somebody types in
digital marketing course and simply
learn is the first ad that shows up how
do we know it's an ad because you could
see the word add next to the domain so
when somebody clicks on that link simply
learn is going to pay Google so that's
how search advertising works okay the
next is social it's a social media
marketing involves increasing traffic or
engagement or brand awareness lots of
different strategies but you're instead
of doing this on search you're doing it
on a social media platform okay so for
example you can advertise on any
particular platform and the way you
advertise could be with an image she
could be with a video so in this case
you could see cobrao is doing a
sponsored ad here how to succeed with
Google ads and then another form of
advertising is display so display means
creating ads that are placed on specific
websites so with display unlike search
you have a choice in the ad format with
search you only have Tech stats but with
display you have text Edge image ads
rich media ads video ads so you have
lots of different options in which you
can advertise on other websites so the
idea here is to get your ad in front of
the Right audience when they could see
your display Banner your banner ad then
it's going to be more visual more
appealing generate some brand interest
and hopefully you can get somebody to
click on that ad and over to your
website so that's paid advertising again
through search through social through
display but you can also promote your
site on social media up so once your
content has gone live you could take
advantage of different social media
platforms I mean it really depends on
what you're trying to promote because
what you're trying to promote needs to
align with the appropriate social media
platform so Facebook is best suited for
Industries like food and Beverages and
news and media and if you're selling a
product so you fall into one of those
categories and Facebook could be the
right platform for you if you're
involved in again beauty or food and
beverage or e-commerce then you can also
leverage Instagram which is part of
Facebook's ecosystem so if you advertise
on Facebook you can also advertise on
Instagram and or Instagram so it doesn't
have to be and Facebook and Instagram it
could be Facebook or Instagram you also
have LinkedIn as a platform LinkedIn is
great for B2B so if you're trying to
promote industry news or or tips and
best practices or job postings then
LinkedIn is the place for you it's a B2B
platform it's great for targeting
specific Industries targeting specific
job levels or job descriptions okay so
LinkedIn is great if you're into B2B
focusing on the business side of it so
you also have YouTube now YouTube is
part of Google's ecosystem YouTube is a
video platform okay so it's great if
you're trying to promote gaming or
entertainment if you're a vlogger okay
so YouTube's a great way to promote your
site by getting your product out there
in the form of a video and then you have
Twitter Twitter to me encompasses a lot
of different Industries Beauty and
fitness news and media entertainment
okay you have limited number of
characters but a lot of people are
active on Twitter and it's a great way
to generate some awareness and get some
clicks over to your website so these are
just some of the most popular social
media platforms of course first there
are plenty more out there the third way
in which you can drive traffic to your
site is guest plus blogging so most of
you already know what blogging is all
about well if you're blogging for your
own site you can jump on somebody else's
site and blog on their behalf so having
the opportunity to guess post on another
website can be very helpful because one
that other blog could have lots of
traffic and have a a well-known brand so
if you're blogging on another blog it's
going to build your brand awareness and
potentially increase traffic to your
blog or website so it exposes to you to
targeted traffic so if you're going to
guest blog guest blog on a site that's
very relevant to your business or
industry that way you're targeting the
Right audience okay you can expand your
personal Network so getting yourself out
there getting your brand out there in
front of a different audience and then
obviously for surfs because it generates
a backlink so serps search engine
ranking Pages means that hey if you want
to rank organically you're going to have
to generate some backlinks so guest
blogging isn't a way to generate some
back links to your site and in effect
that's going to help you get your pages
ranked higher because Google is going to
recognize the relationship from one blog
to your blog and build up your relevancy
so some other benefits here to guest
blogging is you can grow your social
media following because you can then
promote that on social media that you're
guest blogging okay again you can
improve your online Authority okay
because when you're guest blogging and
you have recognition on that guest blog
if it's a popular blog then that's going
to help your domain and Page Authority
for SEO and then the end result is going
to improve your backlink score so the
lot of benefits to guest blogging to me
at the end of the day it's just about
reaching out to your audience using
another platform to do that in the form
of a Blog and the results of that that
is going to mean more brand awareness
for you and turning that traffic from
that other blog into qualified leads so
you can also interview industry thought
later so that's another way an
interesting way to generate traffic to
your site so reaching out to thought
leaders for interviews okay could
generate some credibility for you and
the other person so it's reciprocal so
it means that you're active in the
industry that you're in and it allows
you to engage with other leaders in the
industry and the indirect net result of
that could be increased traffic because
if you do the interview and you record
it or if it's via video then you can
obviously post it on other platforms and
that could in turn Drive traffic to your
website obviously just like guest
blogging it's going to increase your
reach so getting yourself out there
nobody knows who your brand is and they
know who the thought leaders are and
they see you're interviewing the thought
leaders then that's going to put you in
front of these people and so it's going
to increase your reach another way to
drive traffic to your website is just to
make sure your website's responsive and
what do we mean by responsive well we
mean does it work on multiple devices
specifically mobile so depending on the
device your website hides shows shrinks
enlarges or moves content so that it
conforms to the browser that that
person's looking at on your web for your
website so if somebody's looking on
mobile at your website you want to make
sure that your website adjusts
accordingly so you want to be able to
you know test to make sure it's
responsive and so as content arrange
based on importance okay does it work
across different browsers on different
devices and do the images text and
everything else align just like it does
on desktop so there are plenty of tools
out there on the web all you need to do
is just do a search for you know check
my website for responsiveness you know
so you you can use plenty of tools to
check to see if your website is
responsive towards multiple devices why
is that important because if somebody
goes to your website Via Mobile and your
site doesn't align properly or the
content's all stretched out and somebody
has to maneuver their browser just to
see your website then chances are
they're not going to come back chances
are they're not going to convert okay so
you want to be able to revise your
device browser combinations you want to
make sure that everything works
accordingly you want to be able to test
those fonts make sure they look good and
then you also want to make sure that
people can navigate so if they're on
mobile are they going to navigate just
as easy as they can on desktop and if
you have any pop-ups you want to
probably make sure they're removed so
that way when somebody's looking at your
website they're not getting interfered
with on mobile and then of course you
want to make sure that these Pages load
Okay so they load just as quick on
desktop as they should on mobile and
vice versa so this should not take a
long time to load so moving on from
responsiveness on mobile to building a
brand community so brand community
refers to a group of people who identify
your brand and use your brand as a
platform to exchange ideas and
contribute content some advantages of
having a brand Community are promoting
brand evangelism and loyalty it can be a
source of feedback loyalty and ideas so
build a community build a brand
Community who you know identify with you
okay so continue to you know treat these
people as loyal customers okay maybe
give them a promotion uh to use
specifically just for them that they can
use on your website or talk directly to
them because you know that their
followers they're repeat customers they
purchase for you multiple times so talk
to them differently as well you know who
the these people are and that's what
building a brand is all about it's about
identifying your brand with other people
okay and identify people who identify
with your brand and messaging and
talking to them as if they're part of
your own Community your own family so
you can use user generated content that
provides future marketing strategies so
the feedback you get from your own
Community could be in turn used to
promote or used in future marketing
strategies I.E advertising I.E post on
social okay can also provide PR
opportunities so it's a chance for you
to you know put out press releases based
on the community that you built so any
brand regardless of who it is should be
able to identify with your audience
their target audience and that target
audience eventually going to become part
of a community these are group of people
who identify with you what you're trying
to sell out what your cause is what your
mission statement is what your services
they identify with you so leverage them
and reciprocate identify them talk to
them separately give them the what they
deserve the respect and loyalty that
they deserve as well because they're
communicating and they're following you
as a brand so the next thing you could
do to drive traffic is Be Active in the
comments section so engage in relevant
and thought-provoking conversations on
other blogs and sites it doesn't
necessarily have to be another blog per
se it could be other sites like Reddit
or quora or media sites that have a lot
of content that are broken out by
industry that allow you to engage in
conversation and allow you to either
upvote or share or respond okay so be
active because when you're active people
are going to see that hey you're a
leader in the industry you know what
you're talking about you have some some
brand and Equity you have some thought
and some knowledge on the specific topic
and subject so it just puts you in a
better light when you can respond and be
active on these different platforms okay
let's turn our attention to search
engine optimization also known as SEO or
organic search so in order to drive
traffic to your site you're going to
have to implement an SEO strategy why do
you want to implement an SEO strategy
because it can help you improve your
overall searchability and visibility on
search engines and obviously that comes
with advantages one of those advantages
is obviously more traffic to the site
search is still King in terms of volumes
of people using search on a daily basis
so you have a great opportunity to be
found it also builds trust and
credibility because still a majority of
the people who do a search click on an
organic search listing and so if you're
found organically and you're ranked
number one then chances are somebody's
going to click on your listing and it
provides increased engagement in traffic
and so what that means is more traffic
more engagement and engagement is
something you define it could be again a
download of a document or the clicking
on the play button of a video or or
submitting a form or signing up for a
newsletter or calling these are all
forms of Engagement so the the amount of
traffic you drive from organic search to
your website is only going to improve
engagement okay so you can also provide
and improve user experience and what do
we mean by that well if you're getting
lots of traffic from organic search you
have a really good opportunity to do a b
testing and when you do a b testing you
can improve user experience meaning
you're showing one variation against the
other from people coming from organic
search and so this is helpful all and
that you know if you're running an A B
test the variation has a chance to
improve or outperform the original and
if it outperforms the original you're
improving user experience and then it
helps Target quality traffic so SEO to
me or all search is the only medium in
which you're meeting somebody halfway
you're you're addressing what they're
looking for so somebody's looking for a
pair of red women's Nike shoes the 2019
model and you have that particular
product to offer well you have a chance
of showing up via organic search
somebody types in you know women's red
Nike shoes size whatever at the year
2019 model then of course they're gonna
probably likely click on your listing
because you have what they're looking
for and and that goes with any keyword
any industry any business any segment
any type of product you're selling so
again you have a chance to really be
visible for what people are looking for
and so that's the beauty of search
engine optimization you have a really
good opportunity here to meet people
halfway to drive quality traffic to get
them to enjoy a good user experience all
the while generating engagement and
along with SEO we want to be able to
build backlinks so SEO is a two-pronged
approach meaning you have two strategies
in one on page and off page and so off
page involves backlinking so backlinks
are just links that direct users from
other websites to your own website so
with that inherently it's going to drive
traffic qualify traffic to your website
because if somebody's on a relevant
website that's linking to yours and they
click on that link and go to your
website it's likely going to be
qualified meaning they're going to be
relevant and so backlinking because it's
an off-page strategy why isn't an
off-page SEO strategy because if Google
crawls that other site that has a link
to you then that's going to give you
credit because Google will say hey this
site's getting some links from some
relevant sites we must think they're
relevant and therefore we're going to
trust the site so by Google trusting
your site it's going to improve your
organic ranking and with the organic
rankings being approved meaning it's
going to mean faster indexing so what
does that mean so you want to be indexed
by the search engines and so the quicker
Google can find your pages even if it's
on somebody else's site then that means
they're going to follow that link go to
that page on your site and take that
page back to their servers to be indexed
okay so the quicker you can get index
the quicker you can get found and then
it helps with referral traffic so again
we noticed that our efforts are on SEO
organic search but if you're getting
traffic from another website hey that
still counts that's referral traffic
okay so that's a side advantage to
having backlinks is good traffic from
other sites okay so those those are
inherently the some of the reasons to do
backlinking okay never hurts I mean
there's brand awareness reasons to being
on other sites as well there's industry
leadership meaning if you you post
content on Reddit okay you're coming
across as an industry leader but yet
generating a backlink which helps with
SEO and referral traffic so there's a
lot of benefits to building backlinks
and the opposite of backlinks are
internal links so you want to do
internal linking and that just means
connecting one page on your site to
another and why is that beneficial
because it can help direct visitors to
other Pages they wouldn't normally
otherwise find via your navigation so if
you're active on a Blog don't be afraid
to include multiple internal links you
want to move people through your site
you want the flow of traffic to go from
one page to another to another and so
when you do internal linking just like
with backlinks it's going to improve the
indexing of your website Google's going
to follow those links and index those
pages and Google does give credits from
an SEO perspective from an internal
linking perspective so if one page is
linked to another and that page has
really good relevance in the eyes of
Google then the other page is probably
going to benefit from that the other
reason you want to do internal linking
again you want to move people from your
one page of your site to the other and
when you do that it's going to reduce
bounce rates so bounce rate is simply
the rate at which people land on a page
and then leave so if I have a hundred
people in on my home page and only one
person went to another page and the
other 99 left the site then that's a 99
bounce rate so by putting internal links
in place you're helping people move from
one page to the other and thus reducing
the bounce rate and that's what you want
you want to keep people on your site you
want to be greedy it also drives traffic
to older posts so again when we say
older posts we're really referring to
blog posts so if you have a relevant
blog post and you're writing a new blog
posts then link the two together if it's
relevant link it I don't you know
regardless of how old it is you know you
want to show Google that these older
blog posts just because they were
written a year ago doesn't mean they're
outdated and old-fashioned okay or
useless you want to keep them alive by
linking to them so to me that's a good
strategy for internal linking link to
older blog posts you know show people
you're an industry expert you've been
doing this for a while and then you have
lots of content to share okay so the
longer you can keep somebody on your
website the more likely it is they're
going to engage and convert and some
other inherent benefits improves
pagerank so what we mean by Page rank is
simply just a rank that Google gives
pages so the more internal linking you
have the better off you are and then it
helps spread link juice across websites
and when we bit by link juice again just
like backlinking it builds relevancy so
just keep all these inherent benefits in
mind to internal linking the end result
is keeping the flow of traffic on your
site and all these other benefits will
fall into place okay so another way in
which you can really hone in on traffic
to your website is long tail keywords
and long tail keywords to me are more
than just one or two key word phrases
okay so there are usually three or
longer keywords in a phrase okay it's a
long tail keywords really nowadays
account for most web searches people
really take the time to even post
questions as a search query say likely
somebody it's unlikely somebody's going
to go into search and just type in the
word shoes they might type in red shoes
but that's unlikely what they're
probably going to type in is you know
red Nike running shoes 2019 or some
variation of that okay that's a long
tail keyword and some of the advantages
of using long tail keywords to be found
for are less competition so if you're
using broad keywords like red shoes then
who doesn't want to be found for Red
Shoes well you don't necessarily you
don't want to be found for riches
because it's too broad you don't know
what type of shoes somebody's looking
for you just know they're looking for
Red Shoes it could be running shoes it
could be work shoes it could be you know
boots it could be slippers okay it's too
broad so long tail keywords help narrow
it in and the more narrow and focused a
keyword is the less competition is going
to have and when something's not
competitive in the form of a keyword
then that means your chances of ranking
for that keyword are going to be greater
and the chance of you ranking faster are
going to be greater and then of course
if somebody's looking for exactly what
you have to offer then you have a higher
chance to convert that person so if you
have exactly those 2019 red Nike women's
running shoes and somebody does this
search for that and that's a long tail
keyword and they click on your organic
listing if you have the right price then
they're probably going to convert so you
have a really good chance of converting
somebody using long tail keywords so my
point here is if you're looking for
keywords to use focus on longer tail
don't focus on one or two keyword
phrases what it also does is it brings
targeted traffic so even if somebody
doesn't convert hey they could be back
because it's exactly what they're
looking for and if you're focusing on
longer tail keywords like I just
mentioned stay away from the shorter
ones it's just easier to optimize your
page for SEO so remember SEO is a
two-pronged approach on page and off
page we talked about off page with
internal linking and backlinks on page
is all about making sure there's
keywords you choose are integrated in
with the page you want to be found for
and so if you're using a long tail
keyword it's just easy to work that
keyword in so it enables easier on-page
optimization okay let's switch away from
SEO to email marketing so let's focus on
email marketing as a form or method of
driving traffic to your website so email
marketing has been around a long time in
terms of digital marketing why because
it provides an effective way to convert
leads into sales why because you can
send personalized emails to a target
audience so when you send an email to
somebody on a regular basis you know who
that person is so what are you doing in
the email you're writing a specific
message to that person well email
marketing is the same thing except
you're just sending an email to a larger
group of people and when you send an
email to a larger group of people you're
still going to personalize the message
right you're not going to send a generic
email to 1 000 people okay nobody's
gonna do that so make sure your email is
targeted and if it's targeted it could
be cost effective why because sending
large amounts of emails or let's just
say an email to a large amount of people
or a large group of people is going to
be cost effective it's not cost per
click you know it's not cost per open
okay so email usually depending on the
the email provider you're using really
is a flat fee so just really depends on
how many emails you're sending or how
how many people you're sending the email
to as well so but email generally tends
to be more cost effective than other
forms of marketing so look at the email
content provider you're using and just
get a sense of what they charge but if
you look at it and do a comparison email
generally is cheaper than say doing
pay-per-click because with pay-per-click
you're paying for each click okay so
that could be expensive depending on the
keywords so email marketing is also time
saving okay meaning it's a one-time
thing and done so once you send the
email it's just a matter of you know
watching and looking at the metrics and
learning what's going on so you don't
make the same mistakes again but it is
time conducive meaning you send out one
email and that's it with pay-per-click
you're constantly measuring and managing
the campaigns and it provides real-time
marketing so when you do send the email
more than likely a majority of the
people on day one or the day you send
the email are gonna be able to view it
open it click on some of the links and
convert so that's normally what happens
in email majority of the people open it
on day one and it kind of tails off from
there so think about it as real time so
when you send that email and if you have
a thousand people on your email
recipient list break it up send the
first 500 first with a different subject
line and then you can see the data come
in and if you don't see the good results
from the subject line or the body of the
email or you know the page they're going
to then make adjustments before you send
the other email to the next 500. so
that's a great thing about emails you
can break up the email into to two
groups the first group and then the
second group with different subject
lines and you can probably send them a
little bit of time apart that way you
can learn from the first email because
with email you are generally going to
get results right away okay within the
first 24 hours so that's a great thing
about email okay so the other thing
about email it's less intrusive so
normally people who are going to get the
email are the ones who sign up for the
email so they're almost expecting your
email so when they get your email again
as long as you're not sending an email
on a daily basis normally most companies
send it monthly or bi-weekly it's not
going to be as intrusive okay and then
it also helps build credibility increase
visibility and brand awareness meaning
you're going to build your brand in that
email you're going to put content in
that email that's going to show off your
credibility meaning you could put some
testimonials in the email you can put
some good affiliations you can put a
good article to to an industry article
you just wrote so email is going to
inherently continue to build brand
awareness for you okay and it's an easy
way to track Roi so if your e-commerce
it's pretty clear you send the email
somebody opens it clicks on it checks
out and purchases something it's easily
trackable because you could track it
right from that email so one thing I
want to say there is just if you do send
an email make sure you're tracking that
campaign and you want to be able to use
an analytics program like Google
analytics okay if you use Google
analytics you're going to be able to
track when you send the email who clicks
on it and who converts so you want to be
able to measure an Roi for these emails
and you can and that's the beauty of
email marketing okay let's move away
from email marketing to webinars so
webinars great method for Effective
social media promotion it's a great way
to bring traffic to your website so why
do we recommend webinars well because it
provides direct content content contact
within your target group what do we mean
by contact with your target group well
you're going to host a webinar and
you're going to invite this targeted
group of people who are interested in
your product or service so if you have a
Facebook Community you can do a Facebook
live event or you could do a YouTube or
you know you can even set up a webinar
and another platform but promote it on
social media and if you're pronouning
something on social media you're
probably promoting it to people who are
already following you or like you and so
that's what we mean by direct contact
with your target group so you're going
to be able to create a webinar and talk
directly to that group and that's going
to help build brand awareness and
credibility and the great thing about
webinars is you don't need some fancy
software I mean I'm talking to you on a
webinar right now and so webinars are
free all you need is a video camera and
a recorder that's all and that's all
built in with software so there's plenty
of software out there that allows you
just to do a webinar really quick and
easy there's lots of opportunities in
software so and a lot of them are very
cost effective so if you want to build
create a webinar you can do that by
spending very little money in webinars
again allow you to talk to your your
targeted group your community maybe
prospective clients it helps build
credibility and in effect Drive traffic
to your website and when somebody does
attend a webinar they're likely going to
be highly engaged because you're
inviting them they're going to opt into
the webinar and the great thing about
webinars is even if they don't attend
the webinar the day you have it it's
going to be recorded so they can always
go back and watch it so whoever watches
the webinar is going to be engaged
because it's going to be a topic they're
interested in and then users are likely
to become prospective customers so
having a webinar talking about something
inherently interesting to maybe a larger
group of people you can promote promote
that on social media and potentially get
prospective customers to sign up and
watch the webinar and if you do they're
going to be engaged and then take the
next step oh I like what this guy this
person has to say they seem to be
credible I like their personality I like
their brand I like their product I'm
gonna go check their web out their
website okay so webinars allow you to
kind of pull in more people as well as
just your community because you can
promote the webinar and you can promote
it in advance and you can leverage
social media for that okay so something
related to webinars incorporating video
content so videos have been proven to be
a really good way to attract new
visitors and it just it makes your
website very engaging when you have
videos on your website as well so if you
create video you have an opportunity to
post it on various video platforms like
YouTube or Vimeo okay there's plenty of
video platforms out there or just embed
added in a blog post or embedded in a
Facebook post or a tweet okay so you can
do a lot with video and having video on
your site is going to increase
engagement okay when you increase
engagement good things happen that's
going to lead to increased conversions
and sales or or Roi or just like we
mentioned the webinar can help build
trust with your audience so even that
webinar you could post on your website
so you want people to engage by watching
this video they watch the video they're
going to gain trust in you because
you're talking directly to that person
that user that audience that visitor to
your website and when you get Bell trust
it's going to increase engagement and
that's the beauty of video unlike text
or imagery videos really do engage with
the audience and so the more video you
could do the better off you are because
again you can leverage social to draw
attention to your brand and product and
service and then you can have that video
on your website to increase engagement
which in turn increases conversions and
sales and improves Roi so always think
video there's plenty of video software
out there that you can leverage and the
great thing about video two is hey most
people are using mobile phones these
days smartphones and so video works just
as well on mobile as it does on desktop
so keep that in mind you know video is
going to be engaging regardless of what
device somebody uses and then of course
if they're watching the video on
Facebook or YouTube then chances are
they're going to share that particular
video which is going to bode well for
your brand and traffic okay so video if
somebody likes a video it's very easy to
share video especially from a mobile
phone so YouTube just makes it so easy
to share or like or subscribe to a
channel it just it becomes that much
easier things can go viral and chances
of them going viral with video are going
to be greater okay so other ways to
drive traffic to your website is submit
your content to content aggregators so
what's a Content aggregator well a
Content aggregators like Reddit that
provides a great platform for you to
post your content so that's what a
Content aggregate is really a site like
Reddit or medium or quora where you
could post content to a large number of
people okay so with Reddit people are
either going to upvote it or downvote it
so the more upvotes you get are thumbs
up or likes or people who encourage that
content the more of a chance it has to
be found and so first thing out of the
gate if you do provide content to a
Content aggregator like Reddit make sure
it's good quality content that's
interesting and that should be a case
the case around across the board whether
it's a social post or blog post make
sure the content's unique professional
and interesting and then if you do say
put something on medium or you do put
something on quora and and it is
professional and interesting and thought
provoking then people are going to react
to it and then that again could lead to
traffic but even if it doesn't lead to
traffic it helps build brand awareness
so if you have content just like videos
leverage it put the content out there
okay and when you put content out there
it's only gonna especially if it's good
content put it's going to put you in a
good light so don't be afraid to share
your content on the likes of Reddit or
medium or core or some of these other
content aggregator websites because good
things are only going to happen and
again referral traffic SEO brand
awareness conversions so all these are
inherent benefits of just sharing your
content okay and then finally we want to
learn from analytics okay so what do I
mean learning from analytics so there
are plenty of analytics platforms out
there one of the most popular is Google
analytics so you want to make sure
you're tracking traffic on your site
with Google analytics so I have have to
do is just go to Google analytics via
search sign up add the analytics code to
your website and voila they're doing all
the heavy lifting they're going to track
traffic coming your website and not only
they're going to track traffic but
they're going to tell you how that
traffic engaged and so the benefits of
it Google analytics is hey you can
figure out where users are coming from
are they coming from that email campaign
that I sent out to a thousand people are
they coming from YouTube based on that
video I posted or are they coming from
Reddit based on the content I just
posted there or they coming from organic
search it is so Google analytics can
help us understand how much traffic
we're getting from organic search so
it'll help us measure our SEO efforts
and then with Google analytics you can
segment so we could segment by mobile we
can segment by desktop returning user
new user by campaign by Page by Language
by city by region I mean there's so many
ways in which to segment your audience
and segmenting simply is breaking up the
entire group of people who come to your
website into different segments based on
what you want to say so if you want to
look at you know females between the
ages of 18 to 24 who come from mobile
via organic search that's a segment and
you can look at that information and
analytics if that's your target audience
then you could see how they're
performing okay so Anna there are a lot
of benefits to Google analytics
definitely want to take advantage of
segmenting in Google analytics you could
look at your competition so there's a
benchmarking report the great thing
about Google analytics you can also look
at content and how your content is
performing once somebody lands on your
website are they what page are they
spending time on what page are they
engaging on the most okay what pages
have the highest bounce rate or the
lowest time on page so you can really
determine what pages work best and then
of course the end result out and
analyzing all this data is you want to
be able to fine-tune your website so
take advantage of the data that Google
analytics or any other analytics
platform has given you by learning once
you learn what's going on with your
website you can make adjustments to your
website to improve user experience okay
so we went over a lot of different ways
to drive traffic we're going to talk
about SEO tools so let's get started so
if you're doing SEO and you're doing on
page and off page SEO for an
organization or website you're going to
need some tools to help you so you can't
go at it alone you can't do anything
manually you have to lean on tools to
help you work more efficiently help you
gain an advantage and so if you're doing
SEO you're going to need tools for
keyword research you're going to need
tools to help you with the technical
aspects related to SEO you're going to
have to use some tools for off-page SEO
including backlink monitoring and
Analysis and then there's tools for
helping you track where your keywords
and Pages rank so there's tools for
every element of SEO and today we're
going to take a look at some of the best
tools out there on the market to help
you do your job better so let's start
with the keyword research so with
keyword research tools you can do your
job a lot more efficiently finding the
right relevant keywords I mean that's
really key to SEO is finding keywords
that are relevant to your business
product or service that you want to rank
for so you want to be able to choose
keywords with high search volume and low
competition so where do you get those
numbers you get those from certain tools
you also want to get forecasts for
certain targeted keywords you want to be
able to generate a list of latent
semantic indexing type keywords keywords
close to the keyword you're trying to
Target you want to be able to select
primary and secondary keywords wisely so
having a list of keywords or certain
data points will help you do that and
you want to be able to identify the
keywords that your competitors are also
ranking for so good keyword research
tool will help you do all of those
things so what are some of the the tools
out there well look no further than some
of the free ones that Google offers like
Google Trends so Google Trends is a good
tool that you can lean on if so if we
look at Google Trends all you need to do
is trends.google.com you can type in a
keyword I can look at the volume or
interest of that keyword over time here
I'm looking at football versus American
football and I could see how it's
trending then I could see you know how
it Trends in specific regions of say the
United States as my market I can also
look at other related queries similar to
football or American football and so
Google Trends is a good tool helps you
look at the volume helps you look at
what specific regions helped you look at
other keywords you know if you want you
can simply just do a keyword search or
you can actually just see what's
trending just by looking at the latest
stories and insights so we could see
International women's day you know
started to pick up steam it's picking up
more steam Etc so it's certain keywords
that tend to Trend well and you can pick
up on what those keywords are using
Google Trends now you could also use
another Google tool called Google
Keyword Planner the only difference is
this one's paid you need a Google ads
account so if we go into Google ads hey
you'll need to go to tools and you'll
need a Keyword Planner but when you're
in Keyword Planner you can find new
keywords so if I type in for example you
know online marketing and click get
started what the keyword tool is going
to do is give me the data that I need to
do appropriate keyword research it's
going to give me my keyword and similar
keywords it's going to give me the
average month and volume and the great
thing here is I can actually see the
trend for that keyword over time just by
clicking on this little bar graph so for
digital marketing I can see what the
trend trend is over time I could see
what the competition is I could see you
know if I'm going to bid on this keyword
I could see what the bidding range is so
more important I could see the volume
and I can see the competition here's my
volume for this keyword over the last 12
months on average and here's my
competition so Google's Keyword Planner
gives you the necessary information you
need to choose relevant keywords wisely
now there are other tools out there that
are paid that help you look for Relevant
keywords like sem rush or keyword finder
that's a freemium tool so there are
plenty of tools available to you you
know another tool I use that's not
listed here is Moz so if you just type a
keyword let's just type in the same
keyword like online marketing for
example okay so what Moz is going to do
is going to give me some volume it's
going to give me some other keyword
suggestions okay it's going to tell me
how difficult that keyword is and it's
going to tell me who else is ranking for
that keyword so it gives me again all
the relative information I need
including competitive information so you
can use these two these keyword tools
moz's freemium summer paint some are
free there's plenty of tools out there
but these are the ones I would recommend
for keyword research now let's turn our
attention to technical SEO so for
technical SEO you're going to need to
use some tools there's no getting around
that because you want to be able to
monitor how your website is performing I
mean is it loading slow for example does
it have a lot of uh issues with the
website in terms of server-side
rendering for example or server response
time what about four fours and redirects
so you want to be able to gather a lot
of the technical information that could
Aid or prohibit your site from ranking
so you want to be able to also you know
look at what the Bots are saying and how
they're viewing your website so if
Google goes to crawl your site are they
experiencing you know a slow server
response time were they experiencing
Pages not found you also want to see if
if you have a site map you know what's
the site map are these Bots crawling
your site or getting the pages from
assignment again you want to be able to
lean on some of these tools to help you
fix errors that you may encounter like
meta tags or four fours or canonicals so
you need a good tool to help you manage
all that and so I'm going to go back to
Moz starting out so if we go back to Moz
Moz is a good tool it's an all-in-one
it's a great SEO platform so if I go to
Moz and I log into an account I can just
go to site crawl and so what Moz is
going to do it's gonna give me a lot of
information about how Moz is bot is
seeing my site okay so if I go to the
site crawl I can look at all the
particular critical uh issues that I've
experienced so I could see four or four
errors okay reiter X related to that I
could see Meta descriptions missing meta
descriptions duplicate content so
there's a lot of different issues that
Moz is detecting for this particular
site and the great thing about mod does
and this is why I use Moz as my SEO
platform I don't work for mods I've just
used them a long time is if you do have
issues then they give you ways to fix it
the how to fix it section so if I see
missing description here if I just click
on review and get a more in-depth
analysis as to what the issues are here
but I can also click on the why and how
to fix okay and they're going to give
you some information about how this is
impacting SEO and what you could do to
fix the issue they lay out the issues
pretty prominently here you can see for
all the metadata issues I have I have
you know 142 total metadata issues I
have 10 title tag two Longs I have 122
missing meta descriptions so they lay it
out nicely here up the top so you can
kind of get a sense of what to work on
and again they prioritize it based on
the severity of the issue and then they
break it down into several categories
for example I just looked at metadata
issues you can see if I click click on
content issues I have some duplicate
content that Moz is recognizing or
missing or valid H tags so Mazda does a
really really great job playing on all
the issues out for you to recognize okay
there's another tool that I like to use
called screaming frog it's a pay tool so
if we go look here great thing I like
about a screaming frog it will crawl
your site and it will give you some list
of issues just like Mazdas of you know
what it sees in your site is
experiencing four fours broken links are
there any redirects it's picking up
duplicate content site Maps you know
they're JavaScript issues how is it see
the site architecture so it really does
take a deep look at everything that
could impact your website from ranking
okay there are other tools out there
like you know deep crawl or woo rank
they're both paid and so pay tools are
really great as well it just depends on
you know your price structure what your
budget is but really when it comes to
all these tools they all more or less
overlap and do the same thing you just
need to rely on one of them to make sure
that you're able to see what the issues
are now there's nothing wrong with using
two of them just as a second reference
point to see if both are picking up the
same issue and of course I like to use
search console I always like to lean on
Google search console because that is
the source so search console will also
you know give you some feedback on how
Google's bot is crawling your site so
that's under the crawl error section
here so you can also you know use search
console to upload a site map so that's a
key to SEO you want Google to be able to
find your web pages quickly so you can
simply just signify to Google where your
site map is located so the search
console does a lot more gives you some
HTML improvements gives you some
backlinking uh and then the process of
updating the search console user
interface so there's a new user
interface that you can use with Google
search console the great thing is it's
free and it has everything you need to
know about your website and how it's
affected by SEO organic search the only
thing you have to do with search console
is verify the site but once you verify
it it has all the relevant information
you need so let's talk about backlink
monitoring and Analysis okay so this is
related to off-page SEO so you're going
to need a good tool to help you monitor
your website backlinks and backlinks are
simply just links from external sites
pointing to your site and you need to
keep an eye on what sites are linking to
yours are they spammy related sites are
they good at relevant sites or anything
in between so you need to really be able
to analyze what the good links are and
what the bad links are pointing to your
website and you can also you know given
the tool also perform so competitor
analysis so you should be able to use a
tool to be able to compare how your
site's ranking against your competitor
okay you want to measure the ratio
referring domains to backlinks so how
many pure domains are linking to your
site so you want a tool that's going to
be able to tell you that you want to
identify and disavow Port backlinks okay
so you want to be able to recognize
which sites are linking to yours that's
actually hurting you from an SEO
standpoint and you want to be able to do
something about that okay you want to
measure citation flow and Trust flow you
want to check the ratio of Link
distribution in terms of is it internal
or external or you know what kind of
sites are linking to my site are they
you know social related are they pure
content related and then you want to be
able to track the number of do follow
and no followings you know how many
links pointing to our site are actually
telling Google and other Bots not to
follow the link or how many are actually
allowing the Bots to follow that link if
a bot follows a link it's going to pass
what we call link juice so you're going
to get credit for the backlink if it's a
no no follow you're not going to get
credit for the backlink and we want to
be able to measure that and so we want
to have tools that will help us do that
so what are some of those tools well
hrefs is a good tool it's a pain tool
Majestic is a freemium tool Moz again
Moz is the tool I use SCM rush and then
again I gotta mention Google search
console so let's take a look at some of
these tools in terms of backlink
monitoring and Analysis so let's start
with Google search console again it's
free you just have to verify your site
and so if I go to Google Search console
I can look at links and I could see what
external links I have pointing to my
site okay so I could see I have 17 000
in this example pointing to the home
page of this particular site okay so if
I click on that I can see all the the
top sites pointing to my home page now
from an off-page SEO perspective do you
want every backlink or external link
pointing to your home page no so you
want links pointing to internal pages so
you want to be able to measure that so I
could see with the top linking sites are
and I could also see what the anchor
text is so do I want my anchor text
always to be my brand name no I want it
to be you know keyword we're trying to
Target search console also gives you
some internal links okay what are the
top link Pages for internal links so
from an SEO perspective you always want
to have a nice balance of internal
linking so this report helps you
understand what pages are getting links
and are the links evenly spread so this
is Google search console this is the
links report this is totally free this
is provided by Google all you have to do
is verify your site now if we go over to
Moz we type in a domain any domain so I
just typed in simple and learn okay Moz
has some metrics that are important to
off-page SEO including domain Authority
so the higher your domain Authority the
better off you are and so what helps a
domain Authority grow is how many
quality links are pointing to that
domain and so here we could see over
seven thousand five hundred linking
domains to Simply learn so what's
important is we just don't want any site
we want quality relevant sites pointed
okay so we could see how many total
inbound links and then how many ranking
keywords we have okay so here Moz is
going to give me kind of an idea of what
my domain Authority has been over time
they're going to tell me the top fault
links to this site so they can tell me
you know what are those links pointing
to my site and what's the page authority
of those sites okay here I can get a
nice graphical breakdown of the linking
domains by domain Authority so you want
pages with high domain Authority
pointing to your site so here I can see
69 linking domains between 91 and 100 so
that's really good we want High relevant
domains linking to our site so just like
search console I can see the top anchor
text being used okay and I can see the
top pages that have you know good page
Authority day on the side I could see
following versus no follow on internal
and external links so this is just the
overview so Ma's really really does
break down for you you know what those
pages and linking domains are so if I
just click on linking domains now I
could get a detailed look for my home
page what domains are pointing to our
domain so I could see microsoft.com has
a domain authority of 100 YouTube 99 and
so not only does Moz provide you with
the domains it also provides you with
your domain Authority score and spam
score so you want to keep an eye on any
particular site that has a high spam
score so having a site with a high spam
score and a low domain Authority will
hurt your domain and Page Authority for
that page so Mazda does a great job of
breaking it out and this is for any page
it doesn't necessarily have to be the
home page okay if I take a look look at
another example here Majestic so
Majestic again I can use a free version
of the tour they have their own metrics
citation flow trust flow so when they
say trust flow what's the link quality
all about okay citation flow what's the
link volume and they can get an idea of
how many external backlinks are pointing
to the site and what's the trend on that
referring domains so Majestic does a
really good job again some of the same
metrics that we could see here except
they go into detail about languages as
well so this is majestic and you got
search console you got a lot of other
tools and then I'm going to just revert
back to Moz because you want to be able
to compare link profiles if you're in a
competitive space and you're doing
off-page SEO you know Moz will help you
compare how your site stands against
maybe another competitive side or
relevant site so just doing this
analysis I can compare my domain
Authority spam score how many total
links you know how many external file
links or external no follow links a
breakdown of linking domains so it does
a nice job of comparing one site versus
another that's going back to Moz and
that's what you want you want a good
tool that's going to help you do that I
mean there's other tools out there not
listed like bright Edge that will also
help you compare linking profiles so at
the end of the day if you're doing
off-page SEO you want to get a sense of
what sites are linking to yours are they
quality sites are they spammy what
anchor text are they using are they no
follow are they do follow you know are
they top domains how do you compare
against your competitors I mean all
these metrics are related to off-page
seos you want a good tool that's going
to help you measure this okay so let's
talk about rank tracking so when we do
keyword research we're looking for
Relevant keywords we find our relevant
keywords we sign primary and secondary
keywords to Pages we optimize those
pages we do off-page SEO and we're doing
all this work for SEO okay we want to be
able to measure the fruits of our labor
we want to be able to measure how we
perform for on and off page SEO for the
keywords we covet in the pages they're
related to and so that's where rank
tracking comes into play so we want to
be able to track our website's ranking
and not just our website all the pages
we've optimized we want to be able to
measure our click-through rates and
Impressions we want to be able to track
the ranking for both desktop and mobile
for specific locations and we want to
identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords so in other words we
want to look at Trends is a keyword
ranking is it going up in ranking is it
going down and ranking if it's going
down in ranking then you need to take
action so you need a tool a good tool
for rank tracking so we can look no
further than again Google search console
it's free it's right from the source so
let's take a look at what Google search
console has to offer in terms of rank
tracking so if I go to Google Search
console and I put in a URL what it's
going to do is it's going to give me and
this is the search query support it's
going to give me what queries people
have used to actually type into
google.com and it's going to be able to
tell me how many times my pages show
Pages showed up for that query it could
be more than one page that's an
impression and if I did receive an
impression meaning did my page show up
in the organic listing then did I get a
click as a result and so in this case if
I got 68 Impressions and 10 clicks for
keywords somebody typed in that's a 14.7
percent click through rate and so with
search console we'll also do is say hey
look for that particular keyword you
appeared on average in position 4.1 so
it gives you really good insight as to
you know what people are typing in and
how you're being found for those
keywords it breaks it down by Pages it
breaks it down by country breaks it down
by device so I could see you know mobile
I've had
899 Impressions over the last three
months on mobile and I received 33
clicks as a result my average position
on mobile is 2.6 so search console does
a really good job again this is free
information
providing you the actual keywords
somebody's using on Google search as a
query and how many Impressions you're
receiving for that keyword how many
clicks click the rate and then average
position so in theory the higher you are
positioned on Google the more clicks
you're going to receive so if I'm not
positioned properly for keyword let's
say page two then I'm probably not going
to receive as many clicks as I would
like so that search console there are
other tools out there like hrefs again
does a good job of tracking AMZ tracker
we look at wincher so there's some good
tools out there I'm just going to show
you another one again I'm going to go
back to Moz for example so Moz has a
tool called so if I go back into the
account so Moz has a rankings tool that
you can look at to see where your
keywords are ranking so if you've
already chosen keywords and optimize
Pages for those keywords then you want
to be able to load those keywords into
Moz and so Moz allows you to do that and
so what Moz does they do a crawl once a
week and they'll be able to tell you
where you rank for all your keywords are
we moving up in the rankings are we
moving down how many keywords do we have
ranked between positions one and three
11 through 20 4 through 10 21-50 so
we'll be able to see where our keywords
Rank and so it gives you a breakdown
here of nationally in the United States
where this keyword is ranked and if it's
moved up or down and for what URL is it
ranked for and so you can label so the
keywords and and this is what you want
to look for in a good tool you want to
be able to organize your keywords and
label them so for all our brand keywords
we want to be able to label them branded
because ideally you don't want to
optimize for your brain keywords so
maybe we want to exclude our brand
keywords and look at our non-brain
keywords in terms of ranking and so you
can certainly add location and look at
specific locations the whole idea
between a good ranking tool is to be
able to measure you know if a keyword is
trending up or down okay so I can simply
look at a particular keyword and I can
see the trend of that keyword and then
you know if a keyword is not ranking
then we want to wonder why it's not
ranking well is it difficult is it not
ranking because of its difficulty or can
we do a better job of optimizing for
that keyword and so Moz also has a page
optimization tool so if you're not
ranking for keyword you can flip over
the page optimization tool then put in
the keyword put in the URL and mods will
give you some idea as to what you can
further do to optimize the page okay so
that's Moz you know this is hrefs so you
can see ahrefs does the same thing they
provide you some visibility average
position how much traffic you know where
you're ranking in terms of positions one
through three four through ten eleven
through fifty and so you want to be able
to get a sense of where my track
keywords are trending are they trending
up are they trending down and the whole
idea again Beyond a ranking tool is if
you're trending down you want to be able
to address why it's trending down so you
want to start with on-page SEO can we do
a better job of optimizing or off page
does that page need more backlinks so
that's why you need a backlink tool to
support your ranking and ahrefs does
offer up some competitor information as
well so you can see how your competitors
are performing so these are some good
examples of ranking tools that you could
take advantage of now there are also a
few important SEO tools that can be
helpful in different ways for example if
you're doing video so there are some
tools to help you measure how you're
performing via video for example vid IQ
so let's take a look at vid IQ so if I
load in say video in YouTube in this
example how to rank YouTube videos I
have a vid IQ extension loaded into my
browser and chrome and so now I can get
a good eye sense of how many views the
duration the engagement rate the like
ratio how many people shared it on
Reddit but further I can look at how the
video was optimized so they're telling
me the title's too long here maybe
shorten it up but we have tags we have
descriptions we have cards we have end
screens it's been shared on Facebook it
hasn't been shared on Twitter okay it is
public we do have pinned comments and we
do have hearted comments and so this
gives me an idea of how we did in terms
of optimizing this particular video okay
so if we wanted to tweak it we could
tweak the title tag make it a little bit
shorter to help it rank better on
YouTube so you want to be able to use a
tool like this because if you have
videos then you want those videos to
rank and so you can certainly watch this
video on how to rank your YouTube videos
and in that video we do allude to vid IQ
so you want to be able to use a tool
like this because you know YouTube it is
a video portal but it's the second
largest search engine behind Google so
if you do have videos you want to be
able to rank for them and you want a
tool that's going to help you measure
and help you understand if you are
ranking if you're not ranking why are
you not ranking now for Content
optimization there are tools you can use
like SCS site checkup or site analyzer
are some good tools if you already have
Moz as an example just going back to Moz
as you already know I use mozz a lot so
they have a page optimization so you
could check the content and how you're
optimized your content so it's going to
give me some good feedback on you know
is your page title meta description are
they in line okay so it's going to give
you some good feedback on that you also
have again I have to allude to search
console you can always look at a
particular page in search console see if
it has any errors as well so is it
duplicated meta description is it
duplicated title tag is it any Pages
missing title tags your meta
descriptions so when it comes to content
you can look at search console you can
lean on Moz or you can lean on some of
these other paid versions like site
analyzer when it comes to traffic and
metrics look no further than Google
analytics there is a free version of
Google analytics as well as a paid
version so if I go into Google analytics
it's going to tell me all of my website
Behavior okay who's coming to my site
how they got to my site how they behaved
once they went to my site and are they
achieving the goals I set out for them
to achieve via conversions and so you
want to look at first and Google
analytics how much traffic you're
getting so if I go to Google analytics
if I go to acquisition all traffic
channels I should be able to see how
much traffic organic search is driving
over a period of time so I could see how
many users how many sessions then if I
click on landing pages I can see what
landing page they went to we're going to
talk about SEO tips and tricks so let's
get started and throughout this series
we're gonna have a few tips to share
with you and we'll start out with tip
number one up for smarter ways to do
keyword research and so if you listen to
any of our SEO tutorials in the past you
know that keyword research is the first
step but the most crucial step in
starting SEO so when we do keyword
research we want to be able to basically
find keywords that we feel are relevant
to our business that we want to be found
on search for and so here are a few tips
that can help you do that research in a
more efficient manner the first thing we
want to do is identify a list of
keywords that are relevant so we only
want to focus on relevant keywords for
our business that's a given so what I
would suggest is as a best practice
maybe you know put down some of these
keywords in a spreadsheet so think of
them as theme of keywords because when
you do research you're going to want to
include a theme of keywords related to
one another so you can pick the best
ones out of that theme and so as an
example if we have a company that sells
dried figs in a spreadsheet as an
example if I show you a spreadsheet
maybe we want to focus in on just dried
fig and maybe we want to focus it on
dried fig recipes so go ahead and put
those in a column you know some of these
keywords that you know you want to be
found for so that's really the first
step they need to be relevant so put
them in a spreadsheet so that you can
build keywords around that list then we
want to choose keywords and when we
choose keywords we want to have some
criteria around choosing them and so we
always want to choose keywords with a
lot of volume and what I mean by volume
I mean how many people on average type
in that keyword or a related keyword per
month the second criteria is the keyword
a product fit meaning you know is the
keyword relevant you always want to stay
true to relevancy the third is
commercial intent what is the intent of
the keyword is it trying to get us a
sale is it answering a question so what
is the intent of that keyword and then
last it's difficulty so we want to
definitely take a look at how difficult
a keyword is to rank for on organic
search so that's some of the criteria
you may have some additional criteria
that you want to use but this is the
criteria basically for choosing keywords
so again we want to prefer keywords with
high volume you want to be careful of
seasonality so remember seasonality in
this example Christmas tree you're only
going to have a spike you know during
the winter or excuse me the October
November December months so be careful
of seasonality when choosing high volume
keywords and again keywords that are
relevant to your product even though it
doesn't have much search volume reality
always trumps uh volume or any other
metric commercial event so we want to
look at keywords that for example have
Buy in them they may have low search
volume but if somebody's typing in that
keyword then we can insinuate that the
consumer who typed in that keyword is
ready to make the purchase so we want to
look at what the intent is of that
keyword and then again the difficulty
always opt for keywords that have low
difficulty or competition and so in
order to get these metrics we can use
third-party tools and I'm going to show
you a couple of examples of third-party
tools you can use that will give you
some of this information so the first
tool I'm going to show you is Google ads
Keyword Planner so if I'm having Google
ads account I could simply go to tools
and then choose the Keyword Planner and
from there I want to find new keywords
so if I choose the keyword dried figs
because that's the keyword I put in my
spreadsheet that I'm interested and
optimizing for and then maybe drive fake
recipes that was the other keyword theme
so if I enter those two keywords in just
to begin with basically what Google is
going to give me is the average search
monthly volume so here I can see dried
figs I have an average monthly search
volume eight thousand one hundred that
means on average over the last 12 months
not so many people have typed in that
keyword here I can see a little bit of a
trend so I just hover my mouse over that
graph I could see again for seasonality
impact if there is any seasonality what
the volume is on average per month then
I could see the competition is high and
because this is Google ads because it's
paid search they're going to give me a
sense or an idea of what I should be
bidding on that keyword now that's
another topic for another day but it's
good information to have because if
you're not ranking for a keyword you
could decide to bid on it for paid
search so don't discard the bidding
information go ahead and put it in a
spreadsheet for later use but for now
we're focused in on keywords that are
relevant how much volume how much
competition okay so once I get this
information here I can simply go back to
my spreadsheet and put that information
in there what's the volume for dried fig
what is the competition now for
competition notice that Google ads gives
us a high or low now if you're trying to
measure ratio between volume and
competition we want to get an actual
sense of what that competition is so
what I always do as a best practice is
go into Google search if I go to Google
Search and I type in dried figs I'm
going to see the actual volume is 34
million 500 000. so I could see that's
the actual search volume for this
particular keyword however if I add a
syntax called all in title before that
keyword with the colon space and then
hit enter Then I could see the actual
volume reduces to 31 000. and basically
what this tells me is that 31 000
listings or results have the keyword
dried figs in the title tag so if a web
page has dried fig or targeted keyword
in the title tag then ideally we can
insinuate that that page is trying to
rank for that keyword so therefore in
order for us to rank number one on
Google we have to jump over 31 000
results so we want to be able to include
this information into our keyword
analysis so if I go into our keyword
analysis here and I go ahead and enter
in that information so what's my keyword
my keyword is dried figs okay my volume
was 80 100 my competition was 31 000 and
so that gives me a ratio of 81 divided
by Thirty One Thousand if I make that
into a percentage basically 26 percent
so that's my keyword Effectiveness index
or Kei or ratio between volume and
competition and so that's a way that you
can gather information is by using
Google ads enter the information into a
spreadsheet and then sort all your data
by Kei you could sort it by volume you
could sort of a competition all these
metrics matter alternatively as another
tool you can use Moz so Moz has a
keyword Explorer tool okay so if I type
in the keyword dried figs I'm focusing
on the United States I could see that
Moz says hey look there's anywhere
between 4 300 and 6500 in terms of
volume out of 100 the difficulty is 41.
and so I can expect a click-through rate
of you know 41 and so basically the
great thing about moz's keyword Explorer
tool is I can also look at the serp
analysis search engine results Pages
what serp stands for and I can analyze
the serp for a particular keyword in Moz
so I want to be able to understand what
my competition is doing in so here I
could see if I really want to try and
optimize for that keyword I could see
what the other pages are ranked for that
keyword in the on page one I can also
see what local results show up for that
keyword so here I can see that we have a
number of different sites listed here so
if we want to be number one these are
the sites that are basically above us
that we need to climb over to be number
one on Google so I find that the keyword
Explorer tool in Moz is very helpful for
understanding your competition as well
as getting a alternative check on volume
and competition or difficulty if you
will and so remember we want to identify
a list of keywords that are relevant I
can't stress that enough we want to
choose keywords based on difficulty we
want to choose keywords based on volume
on Commercial intent and more important
relevancy we can also identify Trends
from a site search query like Amazon and
know what your competitors are ranking
for so we can also go back into Moz and
we could see just by typing in some of
the keywords we're focusing on we can
see if our competitors are ranking for
the same keywords just by using that
keyword Explorer tool and then another
thing we want to look at is LSI or
latent semantic indexing so that's a
fancy word which basically means we want
to find keywords related to the topic of
the page you're trying to optimize so if
there are other keywords on that page
then you could sway in that direction
and so when it comes to choosing
keywords you want to choose always a
primary and secondary keyword and so if
we go back to our spreadsheet it doesn't
necessarily always have to be just one
keyword it doesn't necessarily have to
be dried figs we could choose another
keyword that has a good volume to
competition ratio so we want to choose
keywords that are always relevant and if
we're analyzing nothing but relevant
keywords then we want to be able to
choose keywords that have a good ratio
between volume and competition so you
always want to choose at least two
keywords per page we could also stay up
to date on industry news as we'll help
you learn new jargon so it doesn't hurt
to subscribe to sites like search engine
watch or search engine land they have
lots of good tips so here I'll show you
what that one of those sites look like
if I simply just go to search engine
watch.com I find this is a good resource
to stay up on the latest news when it
comes to search engines here we could
see the Y SEO and front-end developers
are the perfect search marketing team
another article about optimizing your
channel YouTube channel five easy steps
so there's a lot of information here on
search engine watch that pertain to SEO
and keyword research we could also look
at other third-party sites like
Wikipedia Reddit and core for example so
if I go to quora I can do a search for
dried figs and I could see what's being
written about that topic so that should
give me some ideas to build a keyword a
list around so for example the health
benefits of dried figs okay our dry figs
safe for diabetes best ways to eat dried
figs so those are all good keyword
themes that we could build a keyword
list around and I did that simply just
by typing in dried figs on cora so
that's a a good tip for you to leverage
when you're trying to build out a
keyword list okay let's uh talk about
tip number two which is publish high
quality content to get more traffic to
your website so it's all about content
so we've already done the keyword
research we still need to kind of merge
the two but when we talk about merging
the two it's not just building content
around those keywords it's much more
than that when it comes to SEO and so
that's why we always talk about high
quality content so let's talk about some
of the tips that can help you create
high quality content so first tip is we
want to be able to publish longer and
engaging content longer in engaging
content 10 story kind Google why because
you have more content to work with and
when you have more content to work with
you can optimize it you can structure it
you can insert different assets like
videos and images and by keeping it long
you're gonna likely keep it engaging and
so Google tends to lean in favor of
content that is well organized
structured and long because it is more
likely to be engaging for the end user
we definitely want to include this
target keywords so you want to be able
to you know insert those keywords into
those meta tag descriptions into those
title tags into those alt tags but you
want to work them in naturally you don't
want to force anything content should be
naturally written because if it's
naturally written it's going to be
engaging so we want to use LSI keywords
and the content so LSI or basically
latent semantic indexing basically just
means different terms and concepts
related to your target keywords so feel
free to use terms that are similar to
what you're currently using these
keywords can definitely be used for SEO
because they can create more visibility
and potentially higher rankings because
it gives you an opportunity to use
keywords that are natural and work for
different variations and let's look at
examples so if you're optimizing an
e-commerce category page and your
keyword is one mix use for men so we
want to use keywords closely related to
one mixed use for men for example
running shoes for men or sport running
shoes for men outdoor sports shoes or
air cushion shoes let's take a look an
example of Amazon so if I go to Amazon I
could see the one mix shoes for men page
and if I look at this page I can see a
lot of product and each product has
basically some content associated with
it I.E the title title of the particular
product and so you want to be able to
use different descriptors for this
particular product for example men's
running shoes or breathable lightweight
gym sports shoes or lightweight casual
sneakers or walking casual sneaker all
of these are LSI related keywords
they're similar to what we're trying to
optimize for so you don't necessarily
always have to be brand heavy or stick
with one keyword you could definitely
show variation especially on the
e-commerce side if you're dealing with
different products so we want to make
the content readable with the help of
visuals subtitles and bullet points so
if your e-commerce you want to make sure
that page is laid out properly easy to
read here I could see the descriptor
along with the title all kind of merged
together and so there's no breakout of
okay this is the product name this
description it's kind of one all in one
which I like it just makes it more
natural sounding okay and you can see
see these are all broken out uh pretty
well laid out page and Amazon is more or
less you know consistent in terms of how
their pages are laid out so make it
readable add visuals add subtitles add
bullet points it helps break out a lot
of the content especially if you have a
long amount of content or large amount
of content so the use of subtitles
bullet points and visuals will help
break it out structure it and make it
more engaging for the end user you
definitely want to write an effective
and organized content in order to reduce
the bounce rate so there is correlation
between engagement and bounce rate the
more you structure the more you add
visuals the more you add subtitles the
more engaged somebody's gonna be the
less likely they are to bounce from the
pitch we also want to share customer
reviews and ratings so if you have a web
page you sell products even if you don't
sell products it's always good to have
testimonials or some type of customer
review so if we go back to our example
on Amazon and we clicked on a product
one of the running shoe products we look
here we can see the image we could see
kind of the description well I may not
be so interested in buying this product
I want to know a little bit more about
it well that's where the breaking point
comes in that's where the decision
Factor comes in where if I read other
reviews then I can possibly have my mind
made up to buy this product so here I
could see that not only their reviews
but there's testimonials so I could see
that here you can see that there's a lot
of stars and you can see the kind of the
review title these running shoes are
very comfortable and lightweight so you
have a lot of different feedback and so
reading custom reviews is always helpful
because even though you're making the
decision it kind of will help sway you
in one direction or another at least it
does for me so that's the the beauty of
a customer review and a rating we want
to be able to use those to our advantage
and then you want to be able to update
your content on a regular basis this so
and that goes for testimonials and
reviews you want to make sure you're
always getting reviews because if you're
always getting reviews then that's just
adding to the particular product and so
if you're always updating your content
on a regular basis as well then Google's
going to be able to see that and Google
likes fresh content okay we also want to
include the benefits of the product so
if you're selling a product any product
you always want to include the benefits
you want to do as much as you can to
make your product engage into the end
user enticing so that they can buy it so
in addition to customer reviews or
adding content about the product you
want to include benefits so if we go
back to Amazon here we could see Amazon
list a lot of the benefits or one mix in
this case list a lot of the benefits so
here you can see all the descriptors
about the particular product it's got
Rubber Sole it's got a breathable
textile lighting you get free hot
quality socks with every shoe so these
are some of the features then if we
continue to scroll down we can see some
of the details about the fabric type the
specifics about the fabric and a lot of
information on this product page even a
sizing chart so a lot of different
features that will help the end User
make the decision so don't hold back add
as much information as you possibly can
as much information as you have
available it doesn't hurt because in the
end what you're trying to do from a
product perspective is sell the product
and you can't really sell it unless you
have information that's going to
convince the user that this product is
what they want to buy so include the
warranty size recommendation return
policy and some offers so it should all
be listed on the page easy for the end
user to see so can't stress it enough
provide as much product information as
possible go back here here it has a
sizing chart what colors are available
again some of the descriptors if I
scroll down here I can see so some more
of the benefits you know waffle rubber
outsole soft deodorant insole again
fabric type it's got all sorts of
information it's got images about the
fabric itself the shoe itself how it's
structured so a lot of information about
this and it even does a comparison and
so there's a lot of information about
this particular product so don't hold
back add as much as you can to give ends
the end user so in the case uh the one
mix on Amazon you know they had a sizing
chart you know they had an FAQ they had
additional information what other
products that customers view from one
mix and then testimonials so these are
some of the basic bits of information
you want to add on your page if you
don't have customer reviews it's okay
add FAQ in its place again the end
result is to convince the customer to
purchase the product and then build a
comprehensive internal linking structure
of web pages so every product page
should link to similar products so if I
go back here here I can see other
products from one mix so you should
always have a linking structure so that
if the end user doesn't want to
particularly buy that particular product
then you have links available so they
can go to another page and then add
different varieties and related short
videos of the product so if we go back
to our product page you know they have
different varieties that they're
showcasing here they have the size chart
they even have a size convertible chart
so if you're dealing with metrics you
can go over to us metrics feed vice
versa you can add a video you know show
a video uh if you're selling running
shoes several video somebody working out
you know it doesn't have to be a
full-blown commercial per se but it
could be a short 30 second video of what
the shoe looks like on somebody else's
feed so that they could see somebody
walking with those shoes on so video
doesn't have to be a big production you
could do it right from your phone so
review your content before where you
publish this goes without saying you
want to do that just you make sure you
include everything possible because when
the content does get published remember
Google is going to index that content
when they index it it's going to show up
in the search results so we want to make
sure we have all the information readily
available not only for the end user but
for Google as well we want to be able to
analyze our meta tags in url to improve
click-through rate so this is important
because the meta tags I.E the title tag
and The Meta description and the URLs
what shows up in Google search results
so we have title tags the first that's
the first important element that's what
shows up in the search results so what
we want to do is we want to optimize the
title tag and when we optimize it we
want to use modifiers and when I say
modifiers I mean you know feel free to
use the word best or cash back or free
shipping or discount so for example if
you're selling running shoes 25 best
sneakers or I up to 70 off or free
shipping or buy shoes on discount very
action oriented but you know it includes
these modifiers that are going to help
somebody click on that link so some tips
for optimizing the title tag in addition
to modifiers we want to watch the title
length and we want to include there's
Target keywords in the title tag so
remember you're likely gonna have two
keywords to work with you want to have
at least one of those keywords in your
title tag so with the modifier you know
up to 60 to 65 characters in length with
that targeted keyword should get you a
good title tag that's going to get
somebody to click on it so let's look at
an example so if I type in the keyword
best recipes for dried figs you know
here I can scroll down here's my title
tag stands out my URL is right
underneath that and underneath the URL
are is the meta description and so here
I can see some modifiers 188 best autumn
dried fake recipes or 25 fantastic fig
recipes or 10 best cooking dried fig
recipes so these are all modifiers are
going to help somebody get the click get
them to click on your link and go to
your website so when you don't hit the
65 character lemonade if you go over
that Google's going to cut off the title
tag so we want to avoid that at all
possible so the whole idea is you know
like 10 best cooking dried fake recipes
by yummly that's a good enticing title
tag okay it takes them to a kind of
modifier includes the targeted keyword
and is under the 65 character count some
additional tips for writing meta
description we always want to provide a
unique description for each web page of
the website so no duplicate tag
descriptions every page use needs to be
unique then we also want to be specific
about what we're offering so if you have
say you're selling headphones and you
have a particular regular set of
headphones from a different specific
brand include that in the meta
description if you have that particular
product from that brand on sale include
that in the meta description so you want
to be as specific as possible the whole
idea behind a meta description is to
describe the page but also to get the
end user to click on your link so here's
an example of using modifiers and
describing a page if we look at Amazon
again we can see this example here and
if we look at it on Google search
results so if I type in Amazon Bluetooth
headsets ten dollars are on sale here we
can see a lot of Amazon listings in
Google search here you can see the use
of modifiers in the title tag and also
in the meta description here we could
see that you know this particular
headset Bluetooth headset is on sale 50
off so if something's on sale feel free
to include it be descriptive about the
page let people know where there they're
going and use those modifiers don't be
afraid to use numbers in The Meta
description even if it's the price
itself even if it's not on sale but it
is the price included it's not going to
hurt the more information you can
include in a meta description the better
chance you have of somebody clicking on
that link use numbers symbols you know
percentages off always help use catchy
words like discount or cash back when
you're competing with other listings on
the page so if you have something on
sale if it's on clearance list that it's
on clearance here I can see they even
included the coupon code so feel free to
list as much specific information about
that page as possible the whole idea is
you're competing with your own web pages
but in other cases with competitors so
the meta description along with the
title tag and the URL helps separate out
you from the rest of the listings on
search engine results and we don't want
to keyword stuff we want to keep it
within 100 160 something characters or
160 65 characters because Google will
break off The Meta description just like
they do with the title tag and so we
want clean natural written meta
descriptions that separate you from the
competition so that means including the
keywords we're making sure those
keywords are naturally included in the
meta description so if I go back again
to valleyfig.com and I could see the
meta description hey welcome to the best
resource online for dried fig recipes
saver is sweet snacks are healthy dried
fig recipes we've got it all start
cooking with figs and so it's natural
sounding it does include the keyword
it's not keyword stuffing it's natural
sounding that's hopefully going to get
that person to click on this particular
website let's turn our attention to the
URL so we want to make sure that the URL
is basically taking into account best
practices so if we take a look at this
particular URL here it doesn't
necessarily look as attractive as we
would like so first of all I don't
understand some of it so that makes it
unpleasant boring and messy to say the
least so you want URLs that you know
basically are clean and understandable
so in other words we want to make them
SEO friendly because if they're SEO
friendly somebody understands the URL
then they're likely going to click on it
so the old rule of thumb is if you can
read the URL then the search engines can
read the URL so here are some tips for
creating friendly URLs for SEO make it
readable you want to include the target
keyword in the URL so if it's dried figs
the overall should include dried figs if
it's dried fake recipes make sure it's
dried fig recipes now avoid using too
many subdirectories in the URLs so we
want to keep it as close as possible to
the root directory and match the URLs to
titles most of the time so let's go back
to our example here here there we could
see this is valleyfig.com recipes not
necessarily dried fig recipes but
recipes nonetheless it's in the root
directory okay so at all costs now this
is in some cases unavoidable given that
you may be dealing with an e-commerce
website that's calling you know content
from a database so if that is the case
you're going to have some Dynamic
parameters in the URL which is fine just
make sure you avoid having too many of
those Dynamic parameters it's
understandable about parameters but the
rule of thumb generally is no more than
two different parameters in the URL so
prefer to create short URLs that's
really the way to go the shorter the
better is the rule of thumb and you know
if you're going to break up the URL then
use hyphens instead of underscores it's
just cleaner it's a more understandable
search engines tend to read it a little
bit easier if it's hyphen so here's what
a friendly only URL looks like for
search you got your domain you got a
subcategory broken up with a hyphen and
then the product so that's like just to
clean URL for particular e-commerce site
that has categories and subcategories so
again we got amazon.com your category
can be Electronics your subcategory it
could be earphones and your product
could be boat earphones it's that simple
let's start with talking about rich
Snippets this is tip number four so we
want to add Rich Snippets to improve
your website's visibility on serps so
tip number four is all about rich
Snippets so let's start out by asking
ourselves what is a rich snippet so rich
snippet is simply just a term used to
describe structured data markup that you
as a website owner can add to your HTML
so hypertext markup language or HTML is
what is basically constructs a page so
if we can add more information into that
that will internalize search engines
like Google to better understand the
information that's on that web page so
the more Google understands about that
web page the more they can put into the
search engine results page so rich
Snippets is basically some structured
data markup that we can add to our
existing HTML and so if we want to add
Rich Snippets to search engines then how
would you prefer your products to be
displayed well if we have products then
we want to make sure that maybe we have
reviews or maybe we have so other
information in there like links to our
site okay so there's a lot of different
types of Rich Snippets that you know we
can add that Google can recognize and
add to the search engine results so if
you have a product then there's a lot of
things we can add like specifically
product reviews so we want to be able to
add more information to the search
engine results by working in some rich
Snippets so basically the whole idea is
to set up the rich snippet to drive
targeted traffic okay so because the
more information in the serp the more
likelihood you're going to get the click
and the more likelihood that click is
specific traffic so some of the benefits
of structuring the data for Rich
Snippets are as I mentioned increasing
click-through rates you know also
increasing conversion rates so when you
get the traffic from organic search to
your website if somebody's looking for
specific product and you have a number
of different good reviews showing up
let's just say five stars out of five
stars and you have a hundred reviews
showing five stars then you know
somebody's probably going to send take
some trust in your brand in your
conversion rate probability is going to
go higher it also helps improve your
search engine visibility because you're
adding more information so in other
words the more Google knows about your
page the likelihood it's going to rank
that page and it's more likely that that
information that's contained in that
rich snippet is going to get featured in
either the knowledge graph which is that
graph on the right side or any featured
snippet which usually shows up at the
top of search engine results so in other
words the more information you can give
Google the more they can use that
information on their search results page
and there's no disagreeing that the more
information that you have in your search
engine result the likelihood of getting
more traffic increases so for Rich
Snippets you could always start with
images so some of the common properties
that you can add to your product page if
you have a product page is the page
itself is an image you can always start
there you can always add a description
you can always add in ratings and you
can always add in reviews so these are
some of the most common attributes you
can add as a rich snippet so if you add
that Google picks it up it's going to
include that information in the search
results okay some others are offers
prices site links links to your site and
product availability so all the
information can be conveyed to Google
Google understands what you're trying to
pass along it's going to include that in
the search results so did you know that
according to hrefs over 99.58 percent of
featured pages that have structured data
already rank in the top 10 list of the
Google search results page so in other
words if you have Rich Snippets in your
page your chances of ranking in the top
10 of a Google result is going to be
very very very good okay let's talk
about tip number five optimize your site
structure for great user experience so
let's go over some of the tips that you
would do for planning a good website for
SEO and so tip number one is you want a
Ural structure that follows your site's
navigation hierarchy so obviously home
page interior pages so depending on what
type of site you have obviously the
navigation needs to follow that site's
navigation that site hierarchy and it
all starts with a home page you want to
optimize your home page to try up
traffic to your product pages so the
home page is not the more than a doorway
into your website and so the site's
navigation should link to all those
different products so if you have an
e-commerce site with sub categories or
category subcategories then you want to
be able to make sure your navigation
reflects that you want to build a
comprehensive structure for internal
linking as well because when you're from
the home page obviously you want to be
able to easily navigate to other Pages
however when you're on other Pages you
want to be able to have a link pointing
back to relevant pages and not
necessarily on the home page so this
serves two purposes one for the end user
obviously you want the end user to
navigate through your website sites
seamlessly right second for the search
engines they're following links they
want to be able to understand how your
website flows and links together so you
don't want a scenario where it's a
one-way street from the home page to
Interior Pages you want basically a home
page to Interior interior to other
relevant interior pages and that could
be a lateral or that can be a situation
where it's a hierarchy for example home
page category subcategory subcategory
Etc you want to be able to make sure
your site is constructed in a manner in
which the search engine can read it so
CSS or cascading style sheets or
hypertext markup language HTML are your
two most common languages that's
basically what browsers load that's what
search engines like to index it just
makes it easy for them to understand
what your page is all about remember we
talked about rich Snippets in the
previous tip red Snippets are nothing
more than some supplemental HTML to
describe what the page is all about so
that the search engines can understand
that page and include reviews or include
site links in the search engine results
so this is all based on HTML so the more
you provide the search engines in a more
structured manner via HTML the more the
search engines are going to stay on the
page adding breadcrumbs to your product
pages is also a good practice if you
have an e-commerce site and you have a
category then a subcategory then a sub
subcategory then a product page well
it's probably not a bad idea to make
sure you have a breadcrumb so that was
that way somebody can easily go right
back from the product page to say the
category page or to the subcategory page
directly without having to hit the back
button or having to go through the
navigation some good examples I think
Amazon does a good example of using
breadcrumbs giving the amount of
products they have on their site so go
check out Amazon if you want a good
example herbal for breadcrumbs and then
canonical tags we want to make good use
of canonical tags and that's in order to
avoid duplicate content so an a
canonical tag is nothing more than a
link element basically or an HTML
element that basically prevents
duplicate content issues so in other
words if we have a canonical tag as a
meta tag basically we're telling the
search engines this is the preferred or
canonical version of a web page okay so
use this web page so it signals to the
search engines which page they should
basically index and pay attention to and
avoid at all the other pages that have
similar content so that's the idea
behind a canonical tags so that's a good
best practice and then optimize your
site for desktop and mobile I can't
stress the mobile part enough most users
begin their Journey on mobile so if
you're not sure about what the search
engine like or don't like you can always
refer to Google search console for an
example so if you go to Google Search
console they have a report called mobile
usability so if you click on mobile
usability you can see what pages they
like what pages they don't like from a
mobile perspective and if you have
errors they're going to tell you what
those errors are so if your website has
text that's too small to read They're
going to tell you that these are the
pages with this error and so that allows
you to go and address those errors
because from a Google perspective if you
have if a page has a mobile usability
error then Google will not index that
page so leverage Google search console
to get a sense of what type of Errors
your site has from a mobile perspective
you also want to prefer to keep your
checkout page simple so again from an
e-commerce perspective you want to keep
the checkout page as simple as possible
for obvious reasons you want the end use
there to have a good experience and you
obviously want the conversion so when I
say keep a checkout page simple really
now with today's technology you can
create a one-page checkout process you
want to optimize your site map so when
we talk about site Maps we want to make
sure that it's a file an XML file that
basically includes all of our URLs and
we can then turn around and give that
site map to the search engines so if you
have a sitemap in XML make sure you go
to Google Search console so if I go to
Google Search console and I click on
sitemaps I can just simply just tell
Google where my site map is located and
when they recognize that sitemap they're
going to be able to basically index the
URLs from unsymap so we could see here
how many URLs they discover and how many
they index so make sure you create the
site map in an XML format submit the
sitemap via Google search console and
then you can and go back and see how
many pages they've indexed versus how
many you've submitted and you want to
make sure that sitemap is dynamic
meaning anytime you publish URL that URL
is added to the sitemap fixing broken
links so broken links is not something
you want but it's something every
website has it's unavoidable you know
people publish Pages all the time
there's test Pages there's all sorts of
reasons why a site has broken links you
want to be able to address those and
again going back to Google search
console we can basically see just by
looking at some reports what pages I
have broken links and which ones don't
so we could certainly look at search
console to get information about
basically what pages are broken which
ones aren't and then we want to prefer
predictive searches and integrate
product typographic errors on your
search bar so basically have a search
bar that's a best practice but it
anticipate knowing what people are
typing in so that means maybe going into
Google analytics and looking at the
Search terms report so we can go into
analytics and look at Search terms to
get a sense of what people are searching
for but you know when we talk about
integrating product typographic errors
we're talking also about fonts so we
want to make sure we're using the latest
fonts so that we don't run in any issues
on our website uh people not being able
to read based on a specific font that
you're using and then as a best practice
what I found and this is not necessarily
for everyone but using a live chat
widget sometimes helps in fact I would
even go beyond sometimes on most the
time again depending on your business
but I see most businesses now have live
chat enabled and so basically having
live chat enables somebody who has a
question to immediately reach out to
somebody versus picking up the phone
versus sending an email it's just
instantaneous is gratification in some
ways so inserting live chat on a website
is more common practice than not
nowadays given it it lends to a better
user experience tip number six improve
your page speed and reduce the bounce
rate so let's talk about page speed and
how page speed correlates with higher
bounce rate if it's a high page load and
so according to Crazy page speed is an
important overlooked SEO tactic because
for every second delay and Page load can
result in 11 fewer page views sixty
percent decrease in customer
satisfaction seven percent decline in
conversion rate so you know you can see
here regardless of how specific the
numbers are when you have a page that
loads slow you're going to have lower
user engagement and a poor user
experience so you have to pay attention
to page speed and so since 2010 Google
has been using page speed as a factor
for page ranking in the search engine
results so here's some tips to focus on
making sure your pages are optimal in
terms of speed so enable browser caching
okay you can reduce plugins if you're
using Wordpress as an example you know
disable plugins you're not using get
using a simple website design going back
to tip number five stick with CSS and
HTML don't do anything fancy in terms of
Technology because it's only going to
complicate matters optimize your code
Minify files meaning hey if you're not
using any code just get rid of it
because code has to execute and that
slows down page load time so if your
website has numerous CSS and JavaScript
files basically Minify and combine them
and so that's what we're talking about
there you know you don't necessarily
need a lot of you know JavaScript on
your page you can leverage Google tag
manager or you know other features that
help minimize the number of JavaScript
files you have and so you can also get
some of these ideas by going into Google
analytics so in analytics under Behavior
under site speed under page timings you
can basically see how quick each page
loads and then if you click on speed
suggestions right below page timings
what happens is Google's going to
actually give you some suggested ways to
increase speed so if we let this report
load we'll be able to see some speed
suggestions per page and so here you can
see for example the home page has an
average page load time of 4.89 seconds
you can see right next to that we have
page speed suggestions seven total so if
we click on that basically what it's
going to do is going to launch another
Google product called page speed
insights and what page speed insights is
going to do is it's going to analyze the
page in question whether that be the
home page warning Chariot page and what
they're actually going to do is not only
analyze the desktop version of your
website but also the mobile version and
so now we can see opportunities to
improve our page speed by making sure
the images are properly sized making
sure server response time is changed
again defer unused CSS not using CSS
that's or getting rid of CSS or
minifying it so there's lots of things
you can do and again this is desktop and
mobile so on the mobile side we could
see some of the other issues too that
are causing High page load and so
analytics site speed reports page speed
insights are good ways to get an idea
really excellent ways to really address
page load time issues so again these are
just some of the common issues with page
load time there could be other factors
so leaning on those page speed insights
reports will definitely help reduce page
load time so basically according to
Google a website should have you know
time to First Bite lesser than 200
milliseconds milliseconds are very very
fast so in case your website is slower
than 200 milliseconds such as 500
milliseconds or more you need to improve
it so you don't even have to measure it
by milliseconds you can even go by
seconds which is what most of us count
time and again you can see that simply
going into these speed suggestions
report in Google analytics so ideally in
terms of seconds you want something
that's about you know four seconds or
less three seconds or less obviously as
fast as possible so case study Walmart
Walmart reported the following results
so Walmart experienced a two percent
increase in conversions for every one
second of page speed Improvement so
think about that there's definitely
correlation between pay age load time
and speed so in conversions and user
engagement so the quicker your page
loads the higher the engagement so with
that Improvement they also experienced
an increment in Revenue so meaning the
pages load people had a better user
experience they were able to check out
easier and that led to more Revenue so
they were able to measure Revenue
against milliseconds and that's
something you can certainly do in
analytics you can correlate Revenue with
bounce rate you can correlate Revenue
with page speed tip number seven build
quality links and increase their domain
authority of your website so Google's
top three search ranking factors
includes link building so you need to
have quality links from quality sites
pointing to your site and so that's a
factor in terms of ranking so that's
falls under off page SEO you need to
build references and links on on quality
sites and so building quality links to
your content can give your product or
category Pages or even content of blog
posts a boost in the serps so it's all
about quality over quantity so it's
always building quality links not
quantity so let's talk about what kind
of strategies you should Implement so if
you implement these strategies then
you're going to likely see a lift in the
serps so earn backlinks from relevant
and authoritative web pages so what's
authoritative well authoritative is
subjective to some degree but it's also
measurement in others so you could use
Moz as a good tool to measure page
Authority or domain Authority so if I go
into Moz Moz has a page in domain
Authority score between 1 and 100 and so
you can actually see what sites have
good domain or page Authority just by
entering in the domain so so relevant
you obviously want to rank to something
that's relevant so if you're in the food
industry something food related you want
to promote your content regularly on
social media so social media I always
consider it a whole low hanging fruit
when it comes to backlinking you know
there's so many different social media
platforms available Facebook LinkedIn
Twitter there's so many varieties from
images to Pinterest and Instagram to
video being YouTube so there's lots of
ways to get your content out on social
media that will allow you to not only
promote your band build a community but
also establish a reference back to that
page you can opt for guest blogging okay
so you can reach out to another blogger
and blog on that platform and it can be
reciprocal as well a blogger can
certainly you know blog on your platform
and have a link back and it works both
ways influencer marketing so influencer
marketing is working with somebody who
has a large amount the followers who can
influence those followers to you know
mention you in a hashtag link to your
particular product or brand or even
drive traffic to your site so you want
to take advantage of social media
platforms and start your own page as
well so Facebook's a good example it
could be you have any YouTube channel if
you're into video you can certainly set
up a YouTube channel build a following
around YouTube as well so always start
your own page if that's the platform of
choice the last thing you should do is
set up a page on social media and not
keep it updated you could certainly
participate in forums you can
participate in other websites like core
or Reddit that's very you know content
based content driven user driven I
always recommend starting your own blog
blog is a good way to not only generate
content but it's a good way to
incorporate different types of content
so you can set up different types of
content and categories to a good way to
incorporate different assets like images
and video it's a good way to get users
engaged by having comments or having
social share buttons it's a good way to
leverage that content onto other social
media platforms so there's lots of
benefits to blogging very few cons the
only con would be a time constraint but
it's better to have one blog post in one
month consistently than not blogging at
all so getting listed on high quality
link directories like Yahoo directory is
still a way to add a link from a high
quality site and then make use of broken
link building so again on the last tip
we mentioned search console search
console certainly has reports available
for you that allow you to see what pages
on your site are no longer there and
allow you to see what pages they're
linking from okay you can also do
testimonials there's lots of ways to
generate quality links in a way you
almost have to get create creative but
create it in a way that's going to
generate quality not quantity quality is
the key so even if it's one source
whether that be somebody else's blog so
be it as long as it's quality that's
what counts today we're going to cover
search engine optimization interview
questions and answers so thanks for
joining again and here's how it's going
to work so if you have any questions to
these questions or answers feel free to
just comment right below this video and
we'll get back to you as soon as
possible we're going to go through a
series of questions and I'm going to
answer those questions for you okay so
the first question that you might be
asking an interview is differentiate
between do follows and no follows okay
so if you take in or listen to my SEO
courses on YouTube for SEO we talked a
lot about do follows and no follows and
and simply put I mean do follows are
just signals to the search engines is to
follow the link so there's a link on
site a pointing to site B we're going to
basically tell Google Bing and some of
these other search engines hey go ahead
and follow that link now I know file is
just the opposite so no follow link
doesn't allow the search engine crawlers
to follow it so if we have a link on our
site site a pointing to site B we could
put a nofollow tag in there and what
that's going to do it's going to signal
to the Crawlers hey don't follow this
link so in the end if the Crawlers don't
follow the link then there's not going
to be any link juice passed and so
Google is not going to give you credit
or give that site credit for having a
link pointing to it or pointing to
another site or from another site and so
it's all about linking so we can control
if there's links on our site whether we
want the Crawlers to recognize those or
not simply with no follow tags so just a
reminder our link juice is the
reputation or Equity passed from one
website to another so if you have a link
on another website and that website is
of high quality meaning their page
Authority their domain Authority is high
they have a lot of content you know
they're not spammy they're really rich
and they're relevant then you may want
to make sure that the link pointing from
that site to your site is a no follow so
that way that Google can recognize the
link from that side to your site and
basically that reputation is going to be
passed on to you okay so that's a do
follow versus a no follow and why would
we do a nofollow well it just pens it
really depends a lot of social media
platforms like Facebook have no follows
if you have a lot of content you may not
want to be pushing out a lot of do
follows it can actually look bad from an
external linking standpoint and so a lot
of sites are really particular about who
they want to pass link choose onto and
give credit for the link so it's a
business decision and at the end of the
day there's really no hard fast rule
here except from an SEO perspective if I
have a site and I have a lot of external
links pointing outward to other sites
I'm going to be particular about who I
allow the search engine to follow and
what links I allow not to follow okay so
here's an example of what they look like
so do follow is simply just the href
notice the nofollow has the the tag
appended to it the href tag with a
nofollow so if the search engine's
crawling your site and they see that no
file there they're not going to follow
that link and vice versa if there's a
link on another site pointing to yours
and there's a no follow there you're not
going to get credit the search engines
aren't going to pick up that link okay
so question two what is 301 redirect and
how is it different from a 302 redirect
so three one redirects tell users in the
search engine specifically that an
original page has been moved and this is
the keyword here permanently so
permanent only moved we're going to
explain that in a minute so it's just
moved from one page to another and so if
we don't have a page anymore we have a
new page let's just say you built a new
website with new URLs you want to make
sure the old page is pointing to the new
page with a 301 redirect so for 301
redirect is permanent then a 302 is
temporary so we want the search engines
to recognize that we have 301 permanent
redirects in place why because if we
have temporary then it might alert
Google to not keep that page in its
search engine rankings because it's
temporary so why would Google want to
keep a temporary page or even a page
that is pointing to another page on a
temporary basis so they may remove both
pages from its index okay but if we have
something permanent in place Google may
say okay this page is permanently
linking to another page redirecting to
another page therefore it's stable it's
permanent we're going to keep that new
page in the index and eventually remove
the old page so really something
permanent is more stable in the eyes of
the search engine something temporary
may not be as stable in the eyes of say
Google and if they don't see it as
stable then they may remove both pages
from the index okay so the idea is we
want to be found in Google search index
and we get it sometimes Pages go away
for a variety of reasons and if it does
go away just make sure you have a new
page for it and that new page is a 301
permanent redirect okay so question
three why are backlinks important in SEO
well we kind of hinted on that a bit
with the nofollow because if we have a
link from another website pointing to
ours and that link from that other
website is really relevant and and it
has a high page and domain Authority
then it's going to benefit us and so
backlinks are important because if we
have backlinks from high quality sites
it's going to improve the credibility of
our site especially if it's a do follow
tag so the search engines are going to
recognize the relationship between the
site that has a link pointing to us okay
so it's just going to build our
credibility it's going to increase
increase our domain Authority and then
the net effect of that is if we're
credible and we have high domain
Authority then that's going to increase
the rankings of our pages and when the
pages increase in ranking then we're
going to get a more of a Lion's Share of
the traffic for certain keywords that
our pages are found for and if our pages
are found and getting traffic then
because we have increased rankings we're
likely going to have increased traffic
and then it's just a snowball effect so
more traffic leads to more engagement
and conversions so the whole idea for
SEO is remember you have an on-page
strategy and an off-page strategy
building external links is part of an
off-page SEO strategy and we want to
make sure that you know we are relevant
in the form of a link or in the form of
content on other high quality sites
being on a high quality site only
benefits us because again increases
their domain Authority Google sees this
is more relevant therefore pages are
going to benefit by ranking higher and
therefore when we rank higher we get
more traffic so it's a snowball effect
so having backlinks is important because
it snowballs all the way through to
conversions okay so what are the best
practices to rank your videos on YouTube
this is a great question really great
question given the importance of videos
especially with SEO because videos are
found YouTube in itself is a search
engine so if we have a video how are we
going to get it to rank on YouTube well
first things first you never want to put
a video out there and want it to rank if
it's not engaging or informative so make
sure you go ahead and follow the best
best practices of having engaging and
informative content in your video now
once you have that video in place you
want to optimize it and then some of the
key factors for optimizing a video are
you want to choose a title that has high
search volume and low difficulty just as
you would keyword for example for web
page you want to choose a title with a
keyword in it that has high volume and
low difficulty IE low competition okay
so you want a nice ratio there and you
know what you want to choose a title
that's going to get people to watch the
video too so it's not all about just
choosing a title just for the sake of
high volume you also have to choose
something that's relevant that's going
to be catchy as well and then with that
title goes the description so you want a
description that's very relevant to your
title okay because most people aren't
going to click on a video just for the
sake of a title they're going to want to
probably get a sneak peek via the
description of what it is so again you
want to optimize that description make
sure the description is is just as
snazzy as the title okay you also want
to use accurate and relevant video tags
just as you would on Twitter Facebook
tag these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really short and to
the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention Okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant then that's
gonna grab somebody's attention and then
again we set it similar to the video
tags we want to use relevant hashtags
again just as you would with Twitter and
Facebook go ahead and throw some
hashtags in there that people could see
because people search via hashtagging
and then this goes without saying you
did all the work created a really great
video it's engaged and it's informative
you optimized it feel free to promote
your video on other social media
platforms okay don't just stick with
YouTube per se so the benefit here is if
you post it on Facebook or LinkedIn or
whatever platform of your choice and it
gets engagement people click on the link
go to YouTube they're gonna like it and
then other people are gonna see that
engagement they're going to see how many
people liked it or how many subscribers
you have so promote your videos to help
you with the ranking of the video on
YouTube so that does play into it so go
ahead and promote it so other people can
watch it like it comment Etc and that's
going to engage other people to want to
do the same so what is mobile first
indexing this is a really important and
timely question mobile first indexing
means Google's just using mobile
friendly content for indexing and
ranking websites so in other words
Google for example has two Bots they
have the traditional desktop bot and
they have a smartphone bot and
eventually everybody it has as a website
is going to be migrated over to the
smartphone Bob and so with that
smartphone bot goes to your website and
starts crawling what do you think
they're looking for their smartphone bot
they're looking for mobile friendly
content if it's not mobile friendly
meaning the page isn't designed for a
smartphone browser or let's just say the
images are way too large or you have to
expand the text just to read it you know
a lot of these these issues that
somebody would have just simply trying
to read something on a web page on their
mobile device Google's not going to grab
that content so you want to make sure
it's mobile friendly so it gets indexed
and so if your website has a responsive
design Google will rank your website
based on its performance on mobile
devices okay so you want to make sure
that your website is mobile friendly and
if you're in an interview and somebody
asks you this question you can even take
it a step further and say look I'm going
to measure how friendly my wall my web
website is for mobile devices and Google
search console because Google search
console has a report that will show you
what pages on your website are not
mobile friendly and it's not a guarantee
but I could tell you if I'm Google and
I'm crawling your site with my
smartphone Bob and that page or one of
my pages is not mobile friendly I'm
probably not going to index it or rank
it so you want to leverage that report
in Google search console to see what
pages are mobile friendly so that's a
little bonus for you to really impress
the interviewer who asks you this
question because how are you going to
know if one of your pages is mobile
friendly or not if you don't look at a
report so keep an eye on Google search
consoles mobile usability report okay
number six list down the most important
local SEO ranking factors okay so
organic local ranking is just as
important as anything else in organic
search because if you have a local
business you want to use the likes of
say Google my business to show up when
somebody types in you know looking for a
florist or you're looking for a coffee
shop so what you want to do is you want
to create a web page for every product
and service okay you also want to opt
for your business listings on Google my
business and and there are plenty of
other local business directories out
there like Yelp for example or Bing even
has one so go ahead and also make sure
you have a business listing as well but
since Google in the United States has a
huge market share you want to start with
Google first you want to update your nap
citations on your website maintain
consistency of your nap okay so nap is
name address phone number so you want to
make sure that that's current and
consistent so if you have a number on
your website make sure it's the same
number on Google my business okay you
can embed a Google map on your website
it could certainly optimize The Meta
tags and content not only on your web
pages but within your Google my business
directory so you can add your business
to other local directories like I
mentioned Yelp and then also just as
important opt for reviews and ratings
okay so the more reviews The Hat you
have the better off you are okay so I
always say this with the with local
search three of the main factors in
showing up for local search on say
Google is obviously the keyword the
second is the proximity of where that
person is and then third is the reviews
so you can't really control the
proximity but you can't control the
keyword and you can control the reviews
to some degree so work hard at getting
reviews for your business but at the
same time you can certainly work in some
keywords let's just say for your product
and service pages on your website but
also you can translate that over to
Google my business Okay so so working in
those keywords making sure your your
number your address your name they're
all consistent and and really just
spreading your the the business out on
other directors that's really all these
are really key factors for local SEO
okay so question number seven how to
avoid duplicate content getting
penalized for duplicate content so for
example if you have two different
versions of a web page you may result in
a duplicate content issue so it's just
SEO 101 you never want to have two two
or more pages with the same content so
what do we do well we can avoid this and
having Google penalize us by again
setting up a 301 redirect remember three
or ones are permanent we can also use
what they call canonical tag and a
canonical tag basically alerts the
search engines as to which page is the
original okay so if we have an original
page we want to point to that page with
our canonical tag and there third option
is opt for preferred domain and Google
search console okay so if you have
multiple no names make sure you set up a
primary one in search console so those
are ways to work around it of this three
I would always go with the canonical
tags because that's just a tag that's
going to sit on the page it's going to
alert Google as to what the original is
just in case they get their hands on the
duplicate so all the pages that have the
same content are going to have the same
canonical tag pointing to one page so
again three ones are permanent you can
simply just redirect one to the other if
you end up having duplication or you
could just tell the search engines hey
this is the original page or you can go
through search console okay number eight
what are the tactics to increase a web
page speed okay so what are some of the
tactics well when you build a site
especially for mobile you want to keep
it as simple as possible and what I mean
by simple as possible really I mean hey
use a simple website design don't get
overly creative if you will most
websites all websites have images you're
not going to be able to get around that
but just make sure you optimize your
images made in other words don't have
such a large image size if you don't
need something very large don't have it
okay you want to improve server response
time and what do we mean by that well
your site's sitting on a server
somewhere you could own that server or
you can be renting it out from say
Amazon web services or let's just say
GoDaddy as your register they also have
web hosting well if you have it on say
GoDaddy server you may be sharing that
server with other businesses and at
certain times of the day other
businesses may get a lot of traffic and
suck up a lot of bandwidth what is that
going to do that's going to reduce the
server response time for your site and
so you want to make sure you have an
idea of you know what server your web
page your website is on and you want to
be able to can have some control over
that because if your server is slow
that's going to slow down everything
else in terms of loading in the browser
and that's not going to be good for SEO
okay optimize your code what do you mean
by optimize minifying when we see
mimifying we mean get rid of some of the
Redundant code if you have CSS you know
get rid of chop some of the get rid of
the JavaScript you're not using so
that's what we mean by optimizing code
readies redirects okay ideally you just
want to have one redirect in place you
don't want to create a daisy chain so to
speak of redirecting and redirecting
after that that's never going to bode
well and it's going to slow things down
as well enable browser caching so if you
enable browser caching basically if
somebody comes back to the page they've
been on say two days ago they're
probably going to see a cache version of
that page and then opt for the content
delivery Network as well so these are
some of the ways to reduce page speed
now if you're curious about the page
speed of your website site you can
always go to Google's page speed
insights tool and all you have to do is
just Google page speed insights or even
just something generic like Google page
speed and you're going to get this tool
page speed insights and all you need to
do is just plug in a URL when you plug
in the URL Google is going to analyze
the URL for both mobile and desktop and
so here we could see Google gives a
score so we could see the score from low
ball and we can see the score for
desktop just by clicking on desktop and
so here I could see some of the issues
that the site may be having in terms of
page load time for their desktop if I
flip over to mobile you know here I
could see some other issues for example
they have a server static assets with
efficient cash policy now if you're not
sure what the heck that means you can
always just click on it and you can see
some specifics here and where you can
just always Google it as well uh here
you got to reduce the impact of
third-party code okay so that's another
thing uh reduce JavaScript execution
time so again going back to a lot of
some of the comments we made about
coding okay so sometimes too much code
or code not functioning as well as it
should we'll tend to slow down the site
okay so you can use page bin insights
you can always get a glimpse of how
pages are loading simply by also going
to for example Google analytics under
Behavior okay you can go to site speed
and if you click on overview okay Google
what Google does is they do a sampling
of pages over time and in this case
based on 89 Page views they have an
average page load time and so you can
get a sense of how quick specific Pages
load or your site overall simply by
looking at the site speed overview
report in Google analytics to get a
sense of how quick your pages are
loading now there's certain factors that
do a effect load time so obviously the
way the page is built with the code the
images Etc but also the browser each
browser loads differently okay so you
want to take a look at it by browser
also by country every country has a
different network and you can be in the
United States and have worse network
service than you do say in you know
Ivory Coast in Africa okay so it really
depends on the network you're on so and
also the page every page is built
differently so you want to get a sense
of what pages are loading quicker and
which pages are not you can simply just
go to page timings and Google analytics
you get a sense of what pages do not
load fast and which ones do and maybe
hone in on the pages that aren't loading
fast and address those pages first okay
so you have two tools at your disposal
one Google analytics and one page speed
insights okay so let's look at question
number nine here so when should an
individual Target short tail and long
tail keywords okay so remember short
tail are usually one to two key words
very Broad in nature long tail keywords
or maybe three four keywords in a query
or maybe an entire sentence those are
considered long tail keywords so usually
short tail keywords have higher volume
but also higher competition longer tail
keywords usually have lower uh volume
but also lower competition but the great
thing about long tail keywords the
conversion rate will tend to be a little
bit higher than say a short tail because
it's less vague and more specific so you
can use short tail keywords if you're
trying to drive a lot of visitors
because those keywords are going to be
vague or Broad in nature long tail
keywords are used for targeted Pages
such as product pages and articles so if
you have a specific product with a long
name you can certainly optimize that
page for that product name again the
product name may have low volume but if
somebody types in exactly that product
name you show up the chance of you them
converting are going to be very high so
you don't have to always be that
specific at the product name but try and
be as specific as you possibly can in
order to get somebody to click on your
link in the search engine results and
get them over to your site to convert
okay so those are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for a short tail keyword you're probably
going to get a lot of traffic the
conversion rates may not be as high as
something say long tail where hey maybe
you're just honed in on a few set number
of products and you're not care you
don't care of a lot about the traffic
you just care about getting the relevant
traffic to your site to convert okay
number 10 what are they Port elements to
focus while developing a website so
we're talking in terms of SEO okay so if
somebody asks me this question in an
interview what am I going to focus on
when I developing a website well the
answers are right here yes we talked
about mobile mobile is so important
because a lot of websites are going to
be indexed with Google smartphone bot so
mobile usability is very important so we
need to make sure our website is
responsive for mobile just some basic
practices when it comes to site
architecture navigation we want to have
a simple URL structure okay no overly
cumbersome the navigation should simply
be clean and need okay if you have five
products okay maybe you have uh in your
navigation you have something called
products with all five listed or you
have all five products in the main
navigation the key is you just want to
make it clean and neat and easy for
somebody to find the the rule of thumb
is if it's good for the end user
probably going to be good for Google but
if complicated for the end users
probably going to be complicated for
Google you always want to create a site
map now what is that sitemap a site map
is simply just a formatted file with two
that includes all your URLs and assets
your images and your videos they're
going to be sitting on your server as
well so you want Google or these these
Bots to be able to find your pages and
assets and by the way you want to take
it a step further and make sure you
upload that site map which is sitting in
the root directory meaning domain.com
sitemap.xml okay you want to take that
site map and make sure you input that
site map location in Google search
console that way Google search console
has a one-way ticket to grab the
elements in the sitemap another
important element to focus on while
developing a website is having a robot's
text file and all A robot's text file is
it's like a lock I always say to a house
so if you lock a door in your house
nobody's going to be able to get in that
door so it's all a robots text file is
you're telling Google and these other
Bots that are coming to crawl your site
what's locked and what's not locked
meaning what they have access to what
they don't have access to so you want to
be able to make sure you have a robot's
text file if you're trying to non-index
specific pages of your website because
if you tell Google don't crawl these
Pages or this directory they're not
going to get crawled and if they don't
get crawled they're not going to get
indexed so robot's text file is an
important element to focus on while
you're developing your website and why
you're developing your website it could
be on a you know in a directory just
called new website so you probably want
to have new website as the directory in
the robots text file and just to let
Google know don't go into this directory
because it's my new website I'm not
ready to go live yet so you don't want
it indexed so there are a lot of reasons
to have robots text files that's the
main reason sitemap you want Google to
get these pages and assets quickly okay
you want to make sure that your side
texture navigation is in order you want
to make sure your site is mobile
friendly and you also want to make sure
you have content on your website that's
the key because that's what's going to
keep people on the website and engaged
and when I say content I don't
necessarily just mean words I also mean
videos I also mean images you know
something interactive okay you want to
keep people engaged that's the key
behind it trust me if an end user finds
your site engaging Google is likely
going to find your site engaging okay so
those are good brownie points to bring
up if somebody asks you this question in
an interview so just a recap here it's
important to have a better site
structure so the Bots can easily access
into next content okay with a responsive
design helps to make your website mobile
friendly and user friendly would also
increase the amount of time a user
spends on your website which may improve
your site's ranking sitemap is simply
just a file that helps search engine
Bots to understand the structure of the
website okay how many pages are on your
website and where are they located along
with the videos and images okay and then
the robots text just instructs the
search engine crawlers to understand
what pages should not be indexed okay
this is simply just a text file and it's
added to the root directory again think
like a door think of a lock okay you can
tell you can lock whatever doors you
want in your house then give it that way
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on SEO Focus I hope it was
informative and interesting if you have
any questions about the topics covered
in this video please ask away in the
comment section below our team will help
you solve your queries thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning